YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT TODAY FOR OUR JOINT
SUNSET OVERSIGHT HEARING OF
THIS IS THE JOINT HEARINGS
HOSTED BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND THE SENATE
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT A WELCOME TO ALL F
THE MEMBERS WHO ARE JOINING US
IT'S GREAT TO SEE EVERYONE HERE
AND SENATORS IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU ON THE SCREEN CARPET A WE
DON'T GET A CHANCE TO SEE YOU
AS MUCH ANYMORE SO THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY. TO SEE YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR OUR JOINT
PARTICIPATION A FEW LOGISTICAL
ITEMS THAT I'M OBLIGATED TO
READ. I DO TO CURRENT STATE
HOME ORDERS WE ARE PRACTICING.
A PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAYBE
PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY TODAY
VIA WEB CONFERENCING
TECHNOLOGY. AS WILL WITNESS IS
ALSO LISTED ON THIS AGENDA.
THERE MAY BE BRIEF DELAYS OR
SMALL TECHNICAL ISSUES AT THE
ASSEMBLY CONTINUES TO ADAPT TO
THIS TECHNOLOGY. AND ARE
COMMITTEES PROCESS WE THANK YOU
IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO TESTIFY REGARDING
ANY OF THESE- AT REGARDING ANY
OF THE- BOARDS- PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO CALL IN THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE
OKAY TIMOTHY. TWO SIX TWO FOUR
TWO AGAIN THAT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE TWO SIX.
TWO FOUR TWO. AND NOW THAT WE
GOT A NUMBER OF THOSE ISSUES
OUT OF THE OR THE WAY I WANT TO
ALSO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK YOU MAY RAISE
YOUR HANDS TO SIGNIFY THAT YOU
WISH TO SPEAK BY CLICKING ON
REYES HAND. THE REYES HAND ICON
THAT APPEARS WHEN HOVERING OVER
THE NAME. AND WE ASK THAT WHEN
YOU CALL IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE TO HELP
ENSURE THAT WE CAN REDUCE. THE
SOUND DISTORTION. THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACE
IN THE QUEUE BASED ON THE
ENTITY. FOR WHICH YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY WILL BE
HEARING TO. ENTITIES SUBJECT TO
THE SUNSET REVIEW. A FIRST OFF
IS THE- VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT EACH BOARD
DEPARTMENT OR BUREAU. TODAY MAY
NOT HAVE OFFICIAL POSITIONS ON
SOME OF THE ISSUES COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY RAISE. BUT PLEASE
PROVIDE AN INFORMAL OR STAFF
LEVEL ANSWER TO THAT THAT
COMMITTEES MAY BE INFORMED
AGAIN. A FOR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FEEL FREE TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY TO THE
BOARD AS THEY MAY NOT HAVE
TAKEN OFFICIAL POSITION- BUT
THEY WILL CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP
WITH US AND THE STAFF LEVEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO OUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR AND CHAIRMAN
ROTH SENATE ROTH FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS. AND I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO SENATE ROTH AT SHOULD YOU
HAVE ANY OPENING REMARKS. WELL
THANK YU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
I WANT TO THANK YOU ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR HOSTING
IS. OVER HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY YOU KNOW THIS IS MY
FIRST- STANDS ON THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AS YOU
WELL KNOW. AND THEN- TAKING A
LOOK AT THE MATERIAL TODAY AND
THINKING ABOUT IT I. COULDN'T
HELP BUT NOTE THAT THE ASSEMBLY
IN THE SENATE HAVE A REMARKABLE
TRACK RECORD OF JOINING
TOGETHER EACH YEAR TO REVIEW
THE- REGULATORY PROGRAMS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS FRANKLY. AN INCREDIBLE
HISTORY OF COOPERATION ALL THE
WHILE. WORKING TO BALANCE
ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMUNITY. WITH
ESSENTIAL CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
EFFICIENCY AND- GOVERNMENT
EFFECTIVENESS. AND I CERTAINLY
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS NEXT YEAR
THE CONTINUING THAT JOINT
EFFORTS- WITH YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY SO
THANK YOU FOR THIS TODAY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATE ROTH
WE ALSO A WELCOME. THE
DEPARTURE FROM THIS- SENATE AS
WELL WE SEE THAT OF THE
COMMITTEE OF BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS HAS INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY IN SO WE WELCOME
YOUR FULL PARTICIPATION. ANY
OPENING REMARKS FROM MANY
MEMBERS ON THE SENATE OR THE
ASSEMBLY BEFORE WE BEGIN. ANY
QUESTIONS OUR OPENING REMARKS
WILL PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOU TO A CERTAINLY. A CENTER
JONES PLEASE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU'RE ON THE GREEN CARPET. I
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE BOARD AS
WE'VE VINCE INSTRUCTED PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY SENATOR EGGMAN.
THESE ARE JUST A FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC YOU'RE JUST
OBSERVING ANTICS OF MY FAIR
COLLEAGUES OF WE DON'T GET A
CHANCE TO SEE EACH OTHER THIS
OF THIS IS OUR ONLY TIME- SO
YOU'LL- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PATIENTS. AT SENATOR HER TITLE
AN AMERICAN ASK IF A GIVEN A
QUESTION COMMENT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY I JUST STAFF
HAVE A QUICK COMMENT AND BEFORE
WE GET STARTED I WANT TO. SAY
AND EXPRESS A BIG HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO SENATOR SUSAN
EGGMAN. AVAILABLE SOMEONE
RECOGNIZE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
ANTICS OF BIRTHDAY WISHES OF
BEFORE WE BEGIN. AS THE MEMBERS
KNOW THAT GIVEN THAT THERE IS A
NEW MAKE UP OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP IT IS OUR DUTY AND
OUR OBLIGATION AND THIS
COMMITTEE ON BOTH THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY ON CONSUMER
PROTECTION WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE PLUS
BOARDS IN VERO THAT REGULARLY
COME BEFORE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR US TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO HEAR FROM
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICERS AND THE
VOLUNTEER BOARD MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S WORKING WELL
AND WHAT AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT
THERE ARE ENSURING THE BEST
FACILITATION OF THE LICENSEES
AND FOR THAT OF THE CONSUMERS
SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT SOME OF
THESE BOARDS. OF RETHINKING THE
PERSPECTIVES OF WHAT'S WORKING
WELL WITH THE LICENSEES AND
ALSO THE CONSUMERS WILL THEN
GET STRAIGHT INTO THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD
JOINING US TODAY AS PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE DOCTOR MARK NUNEZ
BOARD PRESIDENT KATHY BOWLER
ABOARD VICE PRESIDENT. AS WELL
AS THE BOARD'S EXECUTIVE
OFFICER SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO-
WE HAVE LIMITED THE OPENING
REMARKS TO THREE MINUTES. AND
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU JUST- I
THOUGHT WE WERE THE ONLY BOARD
THAT COULD USE TO PAY FOR THAT
AND TEXAS ARE SHORT. THE OTHER
DO AS WELL- AND ALSO FOR YOUR
INFORMATION I AM I AM ATTENDING
VIRTUALLY AND NO ONE ELSE IS IN
THE- HOUSE WITH ME. THEREFORE
I'M NOT GOING TO ASK- GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN LOW CHAIR ROTH
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE YOU
AND SPEAK ABOUT THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD MY NAME IS DR
MARTIN YES AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD WITH ME
TODAY IS THIS KATHY BOWLER THE
BOARD'S VICE PRESIDENT AND IS
JUST CáC FROM AND- THE BOARD'S
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. I WOULD LIKE
TO FIRST THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF OF THE THROW BACKGROUND
PAPER. IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I WILL BE BRIEF I WILL BRIEFLY
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE KEY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. I SINCE THE
LAST CENSUS WHAT IF AMENDED
JUNIOR LICENSE TYPES ONE OF
WHICH INCREASED CONSUMER
PROTECTION BY PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES. ACCESS AND THE
OTHER REMEDIES TO THE PUBLIC
SHOULD ADAM WOULD BE HARMED BY
A VETERINARIAN PRACTICING IN
THE UNIVERSITY CENTER. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE BOARD
UNAPPROVED THE CALIFORNIA
TECHNICIANS- I'M A REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIANS AND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE BOARD VOTED
TO ELIMINATE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD EXAMINATION OR THE
MERITS. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THIS
BILL THAT'S WHY THE POP- THE
REASON WHY WE DO THIS WAS THAT
POLITICS. WERE DEEMED READ.
ZERO THE OTHER EXAMINATION THE
NATIONAL EXAM THAT THEY HAVE TO
TAKE- WE BELIEVE THAT REMOVING
THESE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO
LICENSURE WILL LIKELY INCREASE
THE LICENSE POPULATION A RESULT
IN INCREASED TAXES EVEN
MEDICARE IN CALIFORNIA. NO GOOD
DEED CN BE DONE WITHOUT DOING
ALL THE PAPERWORK AND
ELIMINATING THOSE EXAMS AS A
RESULT OF THE BOARD IS SEEKING
LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANCE TO
REPEAL FIVE STATUTES AMEND FOR
AB ONE TWO CONDENSED LESSEN
YOUR- LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS
SPEECH ONE STATUTES. THE
LEGISLATIVE WAS PASSED THE
BOARD WILL THEN REPEAL FIFTEEN
REGULATIONS AND AMEND FIVE.
ONCE FULLY IMPLEMENTED THESE
PROPOSED CHANGES WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY STREAMLINE THE
LICENSURE PROCESS EIGHT
DIFFERENT LICENSE TRANSACTIONS
WITH JUST. ELIMINATING
CONFUSION STRONG APPLICANTS. IN
REGARDS TO RECIPROCITY
REGARDLESS OF WHERE A
VETERINARIAN GRADUATED RPG-
WHAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE AN OUT
OF STATE- LICENSE ALREADY
MINIMIZED APPLICATIONS WERE
FILED ONE MORE COMPLICATION FOR
THEIR INITIAL. LICENSE CURRENT
PROCESSING TIMES TO THIS
APPLICATION IS EIGHTEEN DAYS
THE BOARD ANTICIPATES BEING
ABLE TO REDUCE THAT TIME FRAME
EVEN MORE WITH PENDING. SYSTEM
ENHANCEMENTS. IN RESPONSE TO AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT. THE
REMOVED THE REQUIREMENT FOR. TO
SCHOOL CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
WHICH OCCURRED MORE THAN SEVEN
YEARS AGO EITHER INITIAL
LICENSE LICENSING APPLICATION.
THERE ARE LESS PROCESS- CAME
THE FIRST YOU SEE A PROGRAM
WITH THE FACT OF REGULATIONS.
IMPLEMENTING AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. GARCES CONTINUING
EDUCATION THE BOARD HAS-COLLABORATED WITH THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF PREMIER STATE
COURTS TO UTILIZE THEIR NERO
REGISTRY OF APPROVED CONTINUING
EDUCATION WILL RAISE PROGRAM.
WHICH LASTED TWENTY TWENTY. THE
PROGRAM ALLOWS THE BOARD TO
AUTOMATE C. E. THAT'S GENERATED
COMPLIANCE REPORTS AND QUICKLY
VIEW UNPACKS YOU REQUIREMENTS.
ARE WE LAUNCHED THE FIRST CD
OUT OF PROGRAM IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE BOARD
RESTRUCTURED IT IS IMPORTANT
UNIT IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO STREAMLINE.
IS AN ADDED. SIX LIMITED TURKEY
FORTUNATE ANALYST. ANOTHER
ENFORCEMENT. TO ADDRESS THE
BOARDS FORTUNATE BACKLOG. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
REDUCING UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
TO LICENSURE. YOUR MIND THAT'S
PROCESS AND PROVIDING BETTER
SERVICE TO CONSUMERS UNLESS
IT'S- I'LL WITH THAT WE ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MARKET AND-
JUST AS A REMINDER THESE
CHAMBERS ARE RELATIVELY LARGE
AND IT'S DIFFICULT AS THERE
MIGHT BE AN ECHO SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU TO SPEAK LOUDLY AND
CLEARLY INTO THE MICROPHONE
WHEN YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM
ANY OF YOUR COLLEAGUES. OF
ABOARD PRESIDENT NEWNESS. THEY
HAVE AN OPENING STATEMENT
THANKS OF COURSE THEY WOULD
LIKE TO ADD SOMETHING. YOU'RE
MORE THAN WELCOME TO- THIS IS
KATHY MILLER- GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AND HONORED TO BE BEFORE YOU I
JUST BRIEFLY WANT TO SAY WHAT
AN HONOR TO HIS BAND AND IT IS
FOR ME TO SERVE ON. THE
VETERINARY BOARD FOR CALIFORNIA
AND- AND I TRULY BELIEVE OUR
BOARD SYSTEM- AND DCA HAS IS
SUCH A ENORMOUS PROTECTOR OF
CONSUMER. OF CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S JUST AN
HONOR TO SERVE. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VICE
PRESIDENT ELECT. I NEED
ADDITIONAL OF COMMENTS FROM STE
THE STAFF AT THIS TIME. ASCENA
YES PLEASE. OTHER SCIENCE
NOTHING. GREAT THANK YOU OKAY
THEN WELL- TURN THE
CONVERSATION TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AND- THE INITIAL GOT
A QUESTION FROM COMMITTEE AND
THEN WE CAN GET TO ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT SO ANY INITIAL
QUESTIONS- FOR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. WE BEGIN
WITH SENATOR PAT. I THANK YOU
CHAIR LOW AND- ACTUALLY SO IN
THE- THE REPORT ACTUALLY KNOWS
STUFF FIRST OF ALL AND REGARDS
TO FREEZE IMPLEMENTATION IT
LOOKS LIKE THE BOARD IS- WELL
THE MOST RECENT ONE THAT YOU
HAVE HERE IS FOR FISCAL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. BUT
BASICALLY FOR ABOUT THE LAST
FOUR YEARS THIS IS PAYING
APPROXIMATELY. IN OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND A YEAR
FOR REASON AND IMPLEMENTATION-
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S YOU
KNOW IT IT ONGOING YEARS AT HE
SAME TIME WE ALSO SEE THERE'S
BACKLOGS AND DESIRE FOR STAFF
AND SO FORTH- AND I ASSUME THAT
THAT ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THE
BACKLOG WHAT WAS ACTUALLY TWO
THINGS ARE CITED STAFF IN
BREEZE. SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THAT ARE WE ARE WE THROWING
MONEY DOWN THE DRAIN BY PUTTING
REQUIRING THE BOARD TO SPEND SO
MUCH MONEY ON BREEZE I MEAN
THAT MOUNT OF MONEY YOU CAN BUY
THESE PAPER TO STAFF PEOPLE.
AND WE AND- IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
CONTRIBUTING TO YOUR BACKLOG SO
CAN THERE BE A COMMENTS ABOUT-
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH REASONS
PATIENTS LIVES IT'S SO
EXPENSIVE AND THE HOUSE THAT
IMPINGING ON THE BOARD'S
ABILITY. TO DO ITS JOB
INITIATION. YOU ALSO WANT TO
RAISE FEES. BECAUSE YOU NEED
MORE MONEY AND YET WE'RE
SPENDING THIS MUCH MONEY. ON
GREASE AND SAID OF HIRING
STAFF. TO DO MAYBE HELP DRESS
THE BACKLOG SO- CAN CAN SOMEONE
ADDRESS THAT. EVER PRESENT THAT
TO. THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR JUST
BECAUSE HE FOR ME THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I
THINK THE FIRST THING THAT I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT IN. GREECE IS
ONLY GOING TO BE AS GOOD AS
WHAT YOU PUT INTO IT AND I
THINK I'M I CAME FROM ANOTHER
BOARD IT FROM ONE OF A COMMON
DREAM SPENT A LOT OF RESOURCES
DESIGNED INCREASE. I'M AND I
THINK WHEN COMING HERE AND
THEN. ALTHOUGH EVERYBODY IS
USING THREE ZERO USING PER USE
DIFFERENTLY AND SO WHAT I FOUND
IS THAT THERE'S A LOT OF.
DESIGN ISSUES OR COMPLICATIONS
BUT WITH THIS BOARD ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE LICENSING
SIDE OF IT I THINK THAT. THERE
ARE A LOT OF. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE PRE SYSTEM
AND WE SPENT THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF REALLY CORRECTING A LOT
OF THE- ISSUES WITH WITH THE
BREEZE SYSTEM. I'M AYE SO I
DON'T. THINK THAT WERE WASTING
MONEY WITH THE MONEY THAT WE'RE
PUTTING INTO THREE. I THINK
THAT WITH ALL OF THE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE'RE WE'VE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED AND THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY. WORKING ON IT
WILL STREAMLINE THE PROCESS A
LOT MORE FOR THE LICENSEES. AND
FOR OUR STAFF. OKAY WELL I
GUESS- JUST AND FOLLOW UP JUST
SAY THAT- I'D LIKE TO SEE AT
LEAST BASICALLY LOOKING AT
THESE DOCUMENTS AS YOU LIKE
BREEZES MORE PROBLEM THAN A
HELP HOWEVER- IF THERE IS. A
REPORT YOU CAN PROVIDE IT SHOWS-ME HOW BREEZE ACTUALLY SAVES US
MONEY AND ALSO HELPS LOWER
LICENSING FEES WHICH ARE
FORTUNATE KEEP GOING UP- THAT
WOULD MAKE ME FEEL MUCH BETTER
BUT SO FAR BASED ON AT LEAST.
JUST PUTTING ST DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THIS REPORT TOGETHER. IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU NEED MORE HELP.
YOU'RE CHARGING MORE FEES AND
YET THE SAME TIME. YOU KNOW
WE'RE SPENDING THIS MUCH MONEY
I MEAN WE'RE JUST NOT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THE QUARTER
MILLION A YEAR FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON YOU KNOW THAT'S UP TO
NINETEEN TWENTY CELLS- AND-
YEAH. I MEAN I SINCE BEING BORN
DISCUSSES BEING BORN BODIES-
LICENSE HOLDERS RIGHT IT'S NOT
WE'RE NOT USING GENERAL FUND
REVENUES. SO AND I WON'T GET
INTO THE LONG SORDID HISTORY OF
BREEZE. BUT IT IT REALLY IS
TROUBLESOME TO ME THAT YOU'RE
SPENDING THAT MUCH MONEY FOR
WHAT MAINTENANCE AGREES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU HEARD THE
TERMINOLOGY BREEZE. OFFERED IN
A NEWER MEMBERS THAT'S WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS THAT I. T. IN
TECHNOLOGY- THAT THERE HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT. CHALLENGES WITH AS
YOU CAN- UNDERSTAND I T. IS NOT
THE STRONG SUIT FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND WOULD YOU OF
THE OBSERVER SENATOR PAN IS
QUESTIONING A WITH RESPECT TO
THE INVITATION AND THE VALUE.
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AND AGAIN-
IT IS OUR OBLIGATION AND DUTY
AS THIS COMMITTEE ON THE
OVERSIGHT. FOR THE APPROPRIATE
QUESTION THAT SENATOR PAN. I
JUST ASKED. THEN MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT QUESTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TIM GRAYSON. IF THANK
YOU SIR HELLO AND- ALONG SAME
LINES- THERE IS THE PROPOSAL TO
RAISE FEES. HOWEVER OTHER WAYS
THAT WE COULD- REALIZE SAVINGS
IN LIEU OF RAISING FEES. ONE OF
THOSE. AREAS THAT I SEE WAS
ACTUALLY IN THE PRESENTATION
ABOUT. COMBINING AT AN
EXAMINATION. OR THE ELIMINATION
OF ONE. ARE THERE GOING TO BE
SAVINGS REALIZED FROM. BRINGING
THOSE EXAMINATIONS TOGETHER
WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ADMINISTER A SECOND EXAM. AND
IF THERE ARE SAVINGS COULD
THOSE SAVINGS GO. TO- HELPING
REDUCE THE INCREASE REDUCE THE
INCREASE OF PLEASE. DOCTOR DANI.
SPEAK TO BE OF BUT AS FAR AS
THE PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS I
THINK THAT. I CAN'T PROMISE
THAT WE CAN REDUCE EASE THE
WHAT PROMISES A BETTER SERVICE-
I CAN PROMISE THAT A LOT OF THE
SYSTEM HAS BEEN ALREADY IT
HELPS AREN'T LICENSING CYCLE
TIMES. I IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER IT TLKS ABOUT HOW AND AT
WHAT POINT IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY WITH MY STAFF WAS UNABLE
TO PROCESS APPLICATIONS UNTIL
AFTER EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY WEEKS
THAT'S ONLY COUNTING THE TIME
IT TOOK STAFF TO. TOUCH THAT
APPLICATION FROM THE TIME CAME
INTO THE DOOR SO WE ACTUALLY
NOW HAS AND I'M LAST MONTH WORK
WERE PROCESSING APPLICATIONS
IMPROVING THEM WITHIN SIX TO
SEVEN WEEKS I'M FOR THE INITIAL
LICENSE APPLICATION BECAUSE OF
A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WE
ALREADY REALIZE. WHAT PROCESS
THE MOST INITIAL APPLICATIONS
WITHIN TWO AND A HALF WEEKS SO
WE ALREADY HAVE REALIZE A LOT
AND EFFICIENCIES WE ALSO PLAN
ON AND WE'RE WORKING RIGHT NOW
ON YOUR FACE WITH THE NATIONAL
EXAMS. I'M WITH HI CD IN AB SP
TWO- AUTOMATICALLY TRANSFERRED
BY. EXAM SCORES INTO OUR SYSTEM
LIMITING AND NOT A LOT OF THE
PROCESSES THAT ARE HAPENING
AND WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON AND
MOVING MORE PEOPLE TO RENEW
ONLINE ONE OF THE BIG THINGS
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE BEEN. LIVE IN
BREEZE FOR FOUR YEARS NOW AND
HE WILL LAUNCH IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND- BY THE BEGINNING
OF TWENTY NINETEEN MOST OF THE
APPLICATIONS WERE STILL KEEPER
AND SO IN TWENTY TWENTY WE-
WANT TWENTY MILLION TWENTY
NINETEEN WE LAUNCHED AN ONLINE
CAMPAIGN. AND NOW IN IN TWENTY
TWENTY OR TWENTY ONE WE'RE
LOOKING AT 99% OF THE AND THE
WHAT THE CASE IS BEING REVIEWED
ONLINE FOR VETERINARIANS AND
90% OF OUR BATISTE AND SO THIS
IS ALL OF THESE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE WE'RE BUILDING INTO THE
SYSTEM. IT'S SIMPLISTIC NIKOLAY
IMPROVING. THAT THE BACKLOG
THAT WE HAVE. I WOULD LIKE ADD
TO THAT- READ. WHEN ARE LOCATED
LIKE THEY WERE. THERE IS SOME
THEY- IT MIGHT BE DON'T TO PAY
PREPARE THOSE. EXAMINATION BUT
THERE'S ALSO REVENUE. THAT IS
LOST. BECAUSE WE NO LONGER.
THOSE FROM THE- APPLICANTS TO
TAKE THE EXAM. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THAT WE- ISSUES
EXAMINED. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
RAISING MY NAY THE SOLE PURPOSE
OF THE EXAMINATIONS. IN SHORT
THE UP. AND RECEIVED EDUCATION
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE SHE WANTS
TO BE A VETERINARIAN WELL BEING
RBG UNSUPERVISED. SO THAT THEY
DON'T. THE MAY POSE A RISK THE
CONCERN. SO YOU CAN THE- WE
FELT THAT THE NATIONAL EXAM.
SITUATION PLAYED THAT WASN'T A
NEED OR STATE EXAM I WAS THE
SOLE REASON WHY ABOUT THE. PART
OF THAT OR THE FEE PART OF THAT
HE WASN'T HARD TO DISCUSS
THERE'S PLENTY OF REASONS WHY-
OUR BUDGET WAS CHALLENGED IN
THE REASONS WHY WE HAVE TO.
THIS ARE THE FEES- BASIC-
SYSTEM STAFF SALARIES BENEFITS
OFFICE- THE SIMPLE THINGS LIKE
THAT- WE ALSO HAD TO DEAL WITH
SOME RACES FROM THAT J.
GENERAL'S OFFICE- I THINK THERE
ARE FEES FOR ATTORNEYS WAS
RAISED BY 30% AND THEIR FEES
FOR- PARALEGALS REYES FIVE
SEVENTY ONE PERCENT- THOSE WERE
BEYOND OUR CONTROL AND LEAD TO
THE REASONS WHY WE HAD TO RAISE
THE FEES. I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY
THAT- WE DIDN'T MAKE THE
DECISION ON OUR OWN WELL
INCREASE FEES WERE BASED OFF OF
A- THIRD PARTY AUDIT THIRD
PARTY PRODUCTS- WHEN WE HAD TO
DO TO MAKE OUR FIND. NOT A LOT
OF FUN TO BECOME INSTALLED
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE TO KEEP OUR FIND OF A
CERTAIN LEVEL NOT FALL BELOW
THAT LEVEL- THE WAY I'M- I
THINK THAT'S ABOUT. HOPEFULLY
SUFFICIENT ACCESS YOUR QUESTION
ON THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- NEXT UP IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VINCE FONG. THANK YOU
CARILLO I COULD JUMP TO- TO
ISSUE FOURTEEN MEGABYTES ANIMAL
SHELTERS- I'VE HEARD FROM MY
LOCAL- ANIMAL SHELTERS- THAT IT
APPEARS THAT THESE- POTENTIAL
REGULATIONS COULD HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES- OF
PUTTING WHO YOU KNOW SMALLER
ROLE SHELTERS IN AN IMPOSSIBLE
SITUATION. AT A TIME OF- YOU
KNOW OF TREMENDOUS BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS NOW OF- FACING A
PROFIT THING- AND COUNTIES AND
CITIES- AND OF COURSE- THE
EXISTING VENTURERS IS THERE- I
LIKE TO GET YOUR COMMENTS ON
THAT AND IF THERE WAS A CHANCE
TO REVIEW THESE REGULATIONS
WITH MORE INPUT FROM- FROM
ANIMAL SHELTERS. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS KATHY MILLER
AND ALL ANSWERED I'LL TRY AND
ANSWER THAT- JUST TO CLARIFY
ANIMAL SHELTER AND FIRST OF ALL
THE REGULATIONS ARE VERY EARLY
IN THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW I
BELIEVE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN-
SUBMITTED TO DCA FOR REVIEW AT.
SO YES THERE IS AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS FOR MORE INPUT AND-
FROM ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT- BUT
A LITTLE BACKGROUND ON IT
CURRENTLY ALL FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE VETERINARY CARE ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO BE
REGISTERED WITH THE BOARD AND
IDENTIFY CALIFORNIA LICENSED
VETERINARIANS ARE LICENSING
MANAGER- SO THEY ARE ALL
CURRENTLY HELD. ALL SHELTERS
ARE CURRENTLY HELD TO THE
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR FACILITY
RIGHT NOW. OF WHAT THESE EXIST
AND WHAT THESE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS THAT THE BOARDS HAS
DEVELOPED- WHICH WAS AFTER.
SEVERAL YEARS BY FIVE YEARS NOT
SINCE I'VE BEEN ON THE BOARD OF
HEARINGS- INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS- THROUGH OUR MDC.
ARE THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS
ACTUALLY HOPE TO REDUCE THOSE
MINIMUM STANDARDS ARE RELAXED
THEM FOR SHELTERS SEEING THAT
SOME SHELTERS ARE HAVING HAVE
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS. WITH
COMPLYING- AND YOU MENTION
VETERINARY SHORTAGES AND
WHATNOT- AND WE TOOK ALL THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION IN THE STATE
IN THESE PROPOSED REGULATIONS-
SO THAT CURRENT THE MDC- TOOK A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND WITH A LOT
OF STALLS DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE SHELTER
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS OUR
VETERINARIANS AT LARGE. AND IT
TO COME UP WITH THESE
REGULATIONS ARE AND THEY HAVE A
LOT OF SHELTER INPUT DURING
THAT TIME OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE
MORE OPINIONS OUT THERE AND WE
WANT TO INCLUDE ALL OF THOSE-
BUT WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT.
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS BOB FOR
ALL ANIMALS IN SHELTERS OR
OTHERWISE I NEED TO BE. NEED TO
BE YOU KNOW HELP TWO EIGHT ARE
FAIRLY HIGH STAY- THE WRITTEN
OR THE WAY THE REGULATIONS ARE
WRITTEN NOW ALLOWS FOR
VETERINARIANS. TO WRITE UP
ORDERS SO THAT- THE STAFF ON
SITE THE R. B. T. OR THE AND
BETTER NERI SYSTEM. CAN AND
MINISTER VACCINES- THEY CAN
ADMINISTER PARASITE PREVENTION-
CLINICAL- CLINICAL- I MEAN I'M
SORRY- CLINICAL CONDITIONS- TO
TREAT. AND THINGS LIKE THAT
WITHOUT OF THAT BEING ON SITE
IF THOSE STAFF ARE WORKING
UNDER THE ORDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN- SO WE WOULD LIKE WE
WELCOME MORE EMPLOYED IT'S
EARLY IN THE PROCESS WE
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME
SHELTERS OUT THERE- THAT ARE
STILL HAVING DIFFICULTIES WITH
EVEN BEES. BUT WE HOPE THAT-
DURING THEIR- ABOUT PUBLIC
OPINION WE WILL CONTINUE TO
REFINE THESE BUT WE FELT THAT
THIS WAS A WAY TO RELAX THEM
FOR ITS FOR SHELTERS THEY CAN'T
FLY RIGHT NOW. IS LAW IS RIGHT
NOW THAT THEY- IS KIND OF
UNIFORM- AND- IF- WE NEED TO
CONSIDER OTHER THINGS WILL DO
THAT BUT THAT'S THE- BACK OF
THE CHAPTERS I WILL SAY THAT
DURING THAT WHOLE- M. D. C.
CHARING CROSS- SHELTERS WERE.
FAIRLY WELL REPRESENTED ARE R.
RV T. ON OUR OWN ON OUR BOARD
WAS A SHELTER RBG AT THE TIME.
AND THERE WAS A SHELTER
VETERINARIAN- ON THE RBT ON
THEM IN DC AT THE TIME. SO WE
TRIED TO INCLUDE- TESTIMONY AND
INPUT FROM ALL. ALL SOURCES. SO
THAT'S AND MARK YOU MAY HAVE
SOMETHING TO ADD OR JESSICA BUT
THAT'S SORT OF THE BACKGROUND
ON THESE REGULATIONS AND AGAIN
THERE EARLY IN THE PROCESS. I
WOULD I WORK AT THE. A QUARTER
CAN REGULATES THE PRACTICES
THAT AMERICA'S. I ON THE ISSUE
OF MINIMUM STANDARDS UP THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE MINIMUM
STANDARDS IS. I ASSUME THAT ALL
OF YOU HAVE PETS AND- WHEN YOU
TAKE YOUR PET TO THE VETERINARY
HOSPITAL IT'S BECAUSE OF
MINIMUM STANDARDS THAT- THEIR
MEDICAL RECORDS FOR THAT THE
TALK ABOUT PREVIOUS VISITS
PREVIOUS MEDICAL CONDITIONS
WHEN YOU'RE TAKEN INTO THE
EXAMINATION ROOM WONDER IF
THAT'LL HAPPEN AGAIN. THE
EXAMINATION ROOM IS CLEAN- THE
NEED ALSO TELL YEARS FOR GIVING
INJECTIONS OURS STERILE. ALEX
THE YEARS OR THE ASSEMBLY.
STANDARD IF MINIMUM STANDARDS
WE'RE IN PLACE THEN IT WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO THE CONSUMER.
PREVIOUSLY THERE WAS ONLY ONE
SET OF MINIMUM STANDARDS BUT
DEFINITELY TIMES HAVE CHANGED
PRACTICE ACT CHANGES EVERY YEAR
AND WE REALIZE THAT THERE'S
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PRACTICES
THE PROBABLY WOULD REQUIRE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF STANDARDS.
IN PARTICULAR SHELTER MEDICINE
WE DEFINITELY REALIZED THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE WHEREAS-
REVENUE THE ABILITY JOB FULLY
STAFFED- THEIR PRACTICES- BEING
IN RURAL AREAS NOT HAVING. A
VETERINARIAN BROWN'S JERSEYS
AND SO. WE LOW INTEREST- TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO
PRACTICE VETERINARY MEDICINE.
BLACK WHEN DEALING WITH
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES IS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE A POINT WHERE BOTH
SIDES JUST. HAVE DISAGREEMENTS-
WE CERTAINLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE NO MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR THE SHELTER
MEDICINE. BECAUSE THESE
SHELTERS ARE NOT ONLY FULL
ABANDONED PETS WITH NO OWNERS
SOMETIMES THE SHELTERS ARE
FILLED WITH THAT'S THE
HAMBURGERS AND- CONTRABAND OF
ONE OF MY OWN PETS LOST AND
ENDED UP IN A SHELTER. I WOULD
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THERE WERE
SOME MINIMUM STANDARDS PRESENTS
AT THAT SHELTER SO THAT MIGHT
HAVE MY CHILD. WOULD BE TAKEN
CARE OF- I KNOW THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT WHERE WHERE SOME OF
THEM THE SMALLEST. TO ME. EVEN
THESE MINIMUM STANDARDS AND OF
COURSE WILL ALWAYS CONTINUE TO
ACT IN GOOD FAITH HE TRIED TO
REACH UP SOMETHING THAT WORKS
FOR ALL OF US. BUT AS AS A
REGULATORY BODY I THINK IT'S
OUR DUTY TO HAVE SOME MINIMUM
STANDARDS IN PLACE. IN THE
SHELTERS. HI I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- THE CANDOR AND AS
SOMEONE WHO IS WHO HAS TO
RESCUE DOGS MYSELF I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE- THE
NEED TO FOR ANIMAL SAFETY AND
TO ENSURE- THE LEVEL OF CARE
FOR OUR FOR OUR PETS- MY- MY
JOB MY GENERAL CONCERN IS JUST
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF.
MAYBE A REGION THAT DOESN'T
HAVE ENOUGH VETERINARIANS OR
THIS OR THAT THAT. THE
POTENTIAL OF THE POSSIBLE AND
THESE NEW REGULATIONS BEING TOO
RESTRICTIVE OR TOO COSTLY THAT
MAY END UP. THE FOURTEENTH AIR
SHELTERS TO EITHER- CLOSER TO
REDUCE- THE RIPPING OF REDUCE
ACCESS. TO TO THE COMMUNITY SO
I GUESS IF YOU COULD JUST
CLARIFY- I HEARD THE BEGINNING
AND THAT THERE'S SOME ROOM FOR
IMPORTANT ADDITIONAL.
CLARIFICATION WHAT IS THE
PROCESS MOVING FORWARD AND
WHERE WOULD- ANY POTENTIAL
REVISIONS OR ADDITIONAL INPUT
BE ADDED OR INCLUDED OR
PROVIDED. THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
WELL I MEAN IN REGARDS TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES I
DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND THAT
DEFINITELY ISN'T. THAT'S YOUR
YOUR POINT IS ONLY ONE EXAMPLE
OF AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF
RESCUERS START OFF WITH GOOD
INTENTIONS BUT SOME OF THEM
INTO SITUATIONS WHERE X. ANIMAL
HOARDING. AND THERE ARE
DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS- SO
EFFECTIVELY REMOVE ALL
STANDARDS. EVEN THOUGH SOME.
RIGHT RESTORED WITH THE BEST
INTENTION SOMETIMES THEY TURN
INTO. DEPLORABLE SITUATIONS OF.
ANIMAL HOARDING AND ANALYTICS-
IF THE ON THE POSSIBLE OF WHICH
WORK ON. IS UTILIZING
REGISTERED BUT CHECK. ZERO-
HELLO ESTABLISHED PROTOCOLS
BECAUSE HAVE BEEN MADE BY A
VETERINARY THAT PERHAPS IS NOT
THERE FOR TIME BLACK CHECKS ON
THE FIRST. THEY ONCE A WEEK OR
ONCE A UP COUPLE OF WEEKS- THE
PROTOCOL IS THAT'S AND FOLLOWED
THE- THINK LIKE THAT THERE'S
PLENTY OF WERE THE STANDARDS
CAN BE MADE. MORE TO ABOUT TWO
AREAS THAT HAVE LESS RESOURCES.
SAYS ON LET ME JUST MAKE I AYE
SIR DON'T- THE DISPUTE NEED
FOR. SOME TYPE THE MINIMUM.
CERTAINLY I MY CRANKING ANIMALS
AND BIG FOR THE- TO PROVIDE A
HIGH LEVEL. FOR ANIMALS IN MY
CAN. I GUESS I IN TERMS OF
SINCE I HEARD FROM THE FOR
SPEAKER- THAT THEY THAT THE
PROPOSED REGULAR HAVE A BEEN
SEEN YET SO IS THERE A- I GUESS
THAT'S MY QUESTION IS THERE CAN
STILL TO REFINE AND HONE IN ON
A LOT OF THE- MAYBE THESE
CONCERNS NOW. ESPECIALLY AS WE
GATHER NEW INFORMATION- LOOK
WE'RE IN A RECESSION- A
COUNTIES AND CITIES- ARE HAVE
BUDGET CONSTRAINTS AND SILVER
POSING COSTLY- THE POTENTIALLY
COSTLY REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT
YOU KNOW. THE CITY SHELTER A
COUNTY SHELTER NOW HOSTAGE TO-
TO RECONCILE THAT'S MY CONCERN
IS THERE A WAY TO US RIGHT NOW
TO. STILL SHAPE. THIS- THIS
PROCESS. YEAH SO I'LL JUMP IN
REAL. AND SO A COUPLE THINGS.
WITH THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
REGULAR IN THE CLAIM THESE ARE
YOU ARE IT MORE COST. AND WILL
HAVE AN QUOTE. WHATEVER CON ARE
ON OR AN FUNDS. I'M THOSE ARE
ARE AND THEN FOR EXISTING LAW
BECAUSE STATUTE STEM CELL. ARE
CLEAR THAT IT YOU PRACTICE
VETERINARY THEY TO BE BY. AND I
THINK THAT THE- REALIZE AND
WHEN FROM PUBLIC ON THE SEQUEL.
IS THAT THE- STATE ARE ALREADY
REALLY DID FOR SAID WITH AS A
THAT'S WHY THE BOARD SPENT
ABOUT FIVE YEAR. TRY TO FIGURE
WAYS TO LOWER AND READ. THE
BURDEN ON THE SHOULDERS TO
COMPLY. AS FAR AS TIME FRAME
THOUGH THOSE. I AS A
CONTROLLING YOU KNOW THE MAKING
IS NOW A QUICKLY. I AND THERE'S
AMPLE TO THE- TO PROVIDE HOME
COM. AND SO THE BIGGEST PORTION
THAT IS ONE IT GOES THROUGH THE
INITIAL YOU STAGING YES. IT'LL
HAVE A FORTY FIVE PUBLIC PERIOD
WHERE THE WILL. COLLECT ALL ALL
COMMENTS FROM THE- WILL BE ABLE
TO YOU ALSO. REQUESTED IN NEED
BE WILL COLLECT CALL. AND IT
WAS TO THE BOARD AND THE BOARD
WILL DECIDE WHETHER NINETY TO
AND THEN THE RIGHT. OR IF THEY
WANT TO. PROVIDE SOME RESPONSES
TO ALL THE COMMENTS. AND WILL
BE DONE THROUGH THE MEETINGS
AND- SO IT'S UNCOMMON US IN THE
MAKING. TO NOT ONLY HAVE A
FORTY FIVE DAY PUBLIC PERIOD AT
THE BOARD FEELS THERE'S MY-
THAT ARE NEED. FOR THE PROCESS.
WHEN THERE'S A FOR AS WELL SO
TO KNOW THAT FIVE DAY PER
COMMENT IN COULD BE A FIFTEEN
DAY BOB TAX. COLLECTOR. THERE
IS SO THE BOARD HAS APPROVED
THE REGULATIONS RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE ON MY- TEAM ARE WORKING
ON. PUTTING TOGETHER THE
INITIAL STATEMENT OF REASONS
FOR IT. WILL RING YOU WHAT DO
YOU CA. STILL THE INFANCY
STAGES OF THAT YES THE BOARD
HAS APPROVED THE INITIAL
LANGUAGE BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE FINAL. I
APPRECIATE THEM AND- COURSE-
WE'RE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
LOCAL SHELTERS IN AND OUR LOCAL
ANIMALS AND SO IF. THERE'S A
WAY TO FOR A STAKEHOLDERS
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INPUT AND
CONTINUE TO REFINE THIS I
CERTAINLY WOULD APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
SENATOR HER TADO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS THE FIRST ONE- DEALS
WITH THE D. E. C. I WANTED TO
JUST GET MORE BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON- IT TO WHAT
EXTENT THAT IT BACK TO US.
ABUSE ISSUE EXIST WITHIN WITHIN
THE PRACTICE ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- AND THEN ALSO
HAVE SOME OTHER QUESTIONS
REGARDING CAN CONTINUE IN
EDUCATION AND SCHOOL APPROVAL
PARTICULARLY- I KNOW THERE'S
KIND OF BEEN A SHIFT AND
BETTER. EDUCATION TOWARDS A ONE
HEALTH APPROACH IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION THAT THE BOARD IS
HAVING AROUND THIS CONCEPT.
AND- BEING BACK THAT MORE MORE
IT'S BEEN SEEN VAX- BETTER PLAY
A KEY ROLE IN IN PREVENTING THE
FUTURE PANDEMICS- CAN YOU TELL
ME A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT.
SO TO BE ANSWERED BOTH
QUESTIONS FIRST YOU ASK
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE DC AND
THE BEST A DIVERSION AND
EVALUATION COMMITTEE AND WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT OVER THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO SUFFER HER INTO OUR
DIVERSION PROGRAM. AND WE DO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S A REALLY
CRITICAL PROGRAM FOR THOSE WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
HEALTHCARE PROFESSION I THINK
ONE THING THAT. THAT MAKES IT
STAND APART FROM OTHER HEALING
ARTS PROFESSIONS IS THAT MODERN%
AREA AND I HAVE THE ABILITY TO
WRITE THE PRESCRIPTIONS AND
THEY MOST OF THEM DISPENSED
RIGHT FROM THEIR SITES AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES EASY ACCESS. I'M
RIGHT THERE AND SO IF THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND CHALLENGES THEN IT'S REALLY
EASY FOR THEM TO. TO YOU ACCESS
THOSE MEDICATIONS AND SO WE
FEEL THAT IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY IS A VERY COSTLY
PROGRAM FOR THE BOARD AS WELL
AND SO WE WOULD LIKE TO DO SOME
OUTREACH AT. EIGHTEEN TO
ENCOURAGE MORE PARTICIPANTS IN
THIS VALUABLE PROGRAM BUT WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW AND
AFFORD IT AND SO WE ARE LOOKING
AT WHAT OTHER BOARDS ARE DOING
THAT HAVE DIVERSION PROGRAMS
THAT USE MAXIMUS THE WE TRY TO
A ARE ALIGNING WITH HOW THEY
ARE RECRUITING CLASS FOR THAT
AS WELL. I'M IN I'M. SORRY CAN
YOU REPEAT YOUR SECOND QUESTION.
YES YES THE SECOND. AB SO
CROSSING REALLY ACROSS THE
WORLD THERE'S- YOU KNOW GIVEN
WHAT THE PANDEMIC- THERE'S A
LAW OF COMMERCE AROUND. NEW AND
EMERGING INFECTIOUS DISEASES
MORE FREQUENTLY ARE GOING FROM
ANIMALS TO. HUMANS AND SO I-
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE ROLE THE VETS CAN
PLAY. I IN IN IN THOSE- AND
PREVENTING THE IN PREVENTING
THE FUTURE PANDEMICS WHAT. ARE
THERE ANY DISCUSSIONS- IN TERMS
OF- THE EDUCATION- IT OR
OVERALL IN REGARDS TO THIS-
BOTTLE. AND I CAN PROBABLY
ANSWER THAT QUESTION- THAT
QUESTION REALLY GOES TO WERE
FINALLY GETTING THE RESPECT WE
DESERVE. BECAUSE IN DROP OF
VETERINARY SCHOOL INTO OUR
PRACTICES- WE ARE ARE ALL AWARE
THAT IN THAT PROFESSION IS
AWARE OF THE POTENTIAL FOR
SOMEONE OVER DISEASES DISEASES
THAT CAN BE PASSED FROM ANIMALS
TO HUMANS- AND SO FORTH- I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE ONE OF THE-
DUTIES THAT I HAVE AS A
PRACTICING VETERINARIAN. IS
THAT I AM ACCREDITED BY THE
USDA US DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE IN PARTICULAR IS
READING INTERNATIONAL HOUSE OF
DIFFICULT'S- SUBJECT BECAUSE
FORECASTS ARE GOING OUT. OF THE
COUNTRY- WITH THE PURPOSE OF
MAKING THAT THESE PETS ARE. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES. THAT MIGHT POSE A
RISK. THE PUBLIC IN OTHER- WHEN
WE FILL OUT THESE FORMS-
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN
CONSIDERED TO BE A TREMENDOUS
NUISANCE BY THE CLIENT THE
OWNER OF THE PACK. THEY DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY YOU HAVE
TO FILL OUT THESE FORMS AND
COMPLY WITH REGULATIONS-
BECAUSE IT IT HAD. THEY JUST
DIDN'T GET IT JUST SON WASN'T
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
VETERINARIAN TO MAKE MONEY-
WHICH WASN'T IT WAS IMPORTANT
BOND. INVENTION OF THE SPREAD
OF DISEASES BOB FROM. NOW WHAT
IS HAPPENING ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
BUT ONE THING IT DID BRING TO
LIGHT. UP TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
IS THAT THESE DISEASES JOBS
AXED A VETERINARIANS DO PLAY A
VITAL ROLE IN HELPING NOT ONLY.
STOP. THE SPREAD OF DISEASE BUT
BEING. IN FIRST LIVE CHECK THEM
OF WHEN THEY APPEAR. IN EVERY
WHERE THEY SHOULDN'T BE. SO THE
BOARD. DECISION AS THE
REGULATORY BODY. PROBABLY
HASN'T SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED
THAT CONCERN BUT IT'S N ISSUE
THAT IS TOP VERY WELL IN THE
VETERINARY SCHOOLS- AND FORMER
PRACTICES SO- WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
HAPPEN ON- FRONTLINE OF.
STANDING THIS COUNTRY AGAINST
INFECTIOUS DISEASES THERE'S SO
MANY THINGS THAT OCCUR THAT ARE
NOT KNOWN TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT-
HOW THIS COUNTRY IS. A VERY
DISEASE FROM COMING TO OUR
SHORES AND HOW GREAT THE STATE.
IS SO IT'S JFF AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND- I'M AND WE'RE WE'RE
ON AT. THANK YOU FOR THAT ARE
ANSWER I THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS ON DISEASE THAT BE INTO
THE STATE FROM YOU KNOW OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD BUT- I GUESS
MY CONCERN IS ABOUT ALSO HOW DO
WE ADDRESS. THE DISEASES THAT
THAT ARE OCCURRING HERE WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND I
REPRESENT A VERY RURAL AND
AGRICULTURAL REGION AND THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE MY-
CONCERN STEMS FROM- AND IN
ADDITION I ALSO HAVE SOME- YOU
MENTIONED RURAL AREAS AND-
THERE'S BEEN KIND OF A NEED TO
LOWER STANDARDS TO DEAL WITH
SOME OF THE ISSUES. ARE
PARTICULARLY I'M INTERESTED
AROUND- IT WHAT WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IN TERMS OF A PRESCRIBING-
ANY TYPE OF MEDICATION TO
ANIMALS- BUT SPECIFICALLY
ANYTHING THAT. YOUR LIVESTOCK
OR ANYTHING OF THAT SORT AND
HORMONES. YEAH A LOT OF THE- A
LARGE PART OF THE LICENSING
POPULATION- ARE SMALL ANIMAL
VETERINARIANS VETERINARIANS
DEAL WITH DOGS AND CATS- BACK
THERE ARE VETERINARIANS TO DEAL
WITH- LIKE GENERAL'S- FROM
PRODUCTION CHICKENS COWS AND SO
FORTH- THOSE- THOSE GUYS ARE
REALLY REALLY ON THE FOREFRONT
OF INSPECTING. PRODUCTS
INSPECTING FACILITIES MAKING
SURE THAT I DISEASES DON'T
BREAK OUT- ONE OF THE MORE
RECENT CHALLENGES HERE YOUR
BACK LINE THAT SPECIFIC AREA
VETERINARY MEDICINE. HAS BEEN
THE OVER USE OF ANTIBIOTICS
AND- WHAT IS ABOUT TO. MAYBE
CHIU YEARS AGO OUR- AT-
DIRECTION OF GOVERNOR BROWN OF
THE ACT- PART OF OUR CONTINUING
EDUCATION NOW INCLUDES. AT
LEAST OUR CONTINUED EDUCATION
ON THE JUDICIOUS USE OF
ANTIMICROBIALS SO THAT THESE
ANIMATICS AREN'T USED. TOO MUCH
SO AS TO LEAD TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF DRUG RESISTANT
STRAINS OF. FACTIONS SIMPLEX
FRACTIONS. AND- BACK ALSO
INCLUDE FOOD- THANK THAT ARE
PUT INTO THE FOOD OUT OF
LIVESTOCK. WITH THE INTENTION
OF PREVENTING DISEASE BY I WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO BE MINDFUL THAT-
THINGS CAN DO HARM IF NOT USED
PROPERLY. SO IT MY HAT'S OFF TO
YOU YEAH. I AM A SMALL ANIMAL
PRACTITIONER BUT MY HAT'S OFF
DEFINITELY TO THE VETERINARIANS
AND RPGS WORKING FOR DHARMA
PRODUCTIONS BECAUSE THEY THEY
REALLY TRULY ARE AT THE VERY
FRONT OF DISEASE PREVENTION IN
OUR STATE AND OUR COUNTRY. AND
MY LAST QUESTION- WHAT THEY
HAVE TWO MORE QUESTIONS THE
FIRST ONE IS- IN TERMS OF THE
INCREASE IN FEES DO YOU SEE ANY
IMPACT ON- ON FOOD. THE COST OF
FOOD AND THE SECOND. QUESTION
THAT I HAVE IS- WHAT ARE WHAT
ARE THE MOST COMMON TYPES OF
COMPLAINTS THAT THE BOARD
RECEIVES AND WHAT IS THE FOR
DOING TO ADDRESS THEM. BOARD
MEMBER I DON'T I DON'T.
CONFIDENTIAL SHOULD BE TO
REDUCE COMPLETE PROCESS SO
ALTERNATIVE JESSICA. STERN SO
WHEN YOU COMES THE MOST COMMON
COMPLAINTS THAT WE GET I'M ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE REALLY
HAVE HAD REALIZES THAT 75% OF
THE COMPLAINTS THAT WE RECEIVED
ARE ALLEGING NEGLIGENCE
INCOMPETENCE UNPROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT AND OFTEN THE IT
UNFORTUNATELY AND HAS RESULTED
IN ANIMALS WHO HAVE HAVE PASSED
AWAY. I'M AND SO A LOT OF THESE
COMPLAINTS ARE EXTREMELY
COMPLEX BECAUSE WHEN YOU YOU
DEAL WITH I'M AN ANIMAL HAS
ALREADY- HAVE PASSED. AWAY AND
SO THERE'S A LOT OF- A MOTIONS
THAT ARE THAT ARE TIED TO THE-
AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT YOU HAVE
TIME. TO SAY MULTIPLE
VETERINARIANS THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN THE CARE OF THAT
ANIMAL AND SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MULTIPLE RESPONDENTS WERE
TALKING ABOUT MULTIPLE METAL
MEDICAL RECORDS AND THAT ARE
INVOLVED AND SO THERE THERE
ARE. A LOT HIGHER LEVEL OF
COMPLEXITY THAT TAKES A LOT OF
TIME FOR INVESTIGATIONS I AND
SO A LOT OF THEM. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE OVERALL GRAND SCHEME OF
THINGS THE BOARD AND ONLY TAKES
A PLAN AND IN A LOT SMALLER
PERCENTAGES OF IT BECAUSE
AFTER. I'M A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION THAT WE
INCOMPLETE- I'M I'LL OFTENTIMES
IT HASN'T RESULTED IN IN
DISCIPLINARY MATTERS I'M AND
THE VETERINARIANS ARE MEETING
THE STAND UP HERE FOR THE MOST
USES- BUT BUT IT IS AN
UNFORTUNATE THAT. THAT THE
MAJORITY OF HIS THAT WE ARE
RECEIVING. ARE RELATED TO THE
STANDARD OF CARE PROVIDED. AND
THE FIRST PART OF YOUR QUESTION
WAS IS RAISING THESE WAS GOING
TO RESULT IN HIGHER PRICES FOR.
FOOD I DON'T THINK I'VE HEARD
THAT OPERATED REPORT. THAT SAYS
THAT WHAT. IT CONSEQUENCES. I
HAVE NOT EITHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY WHEN JACQUI IRWIN-
THANK YOU I'M SORRY I WAS A
COUPLE OF MINUTES LATE AND SO
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU ADDRESS IT
BUT COULD YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THIS. CONFLICT BETWEEN
THE- OF VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND SHELTERS ON IT
TELEHEALTH AND WHAT IS A REALLY
GOOD I'D LIKE TO HEAR A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE VALUE OF
TELEHEALTH IT SEEMS SORT OF ODD
ONE ANIMALS REALLY. CAN'T
COMMUNICATE THAT IT SEEMS THAT
IT WOULD BE REALLY OF LIMITED-
VALUE. SO I CAN TALK ABOUT IT-
AS A CONSUMER BUT I THINK MARK
IS A BET SHE'D PROBABLY TALK
ABOUT IT. AT THE BEGINNING-
FROM A VETERINARY PERSPECTIVE.
I AM TELEHEALTH IS. I FIRST
pTHERE DEFINITELY IS SOME
INSTANCES WHERE TELEHEALTH
WOULD BE- CAN BE USED
APPROPRIATELY AND THOSE ARE
PROBABLY SITUATIONS WHERE
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED- WHAT WE CALL OF
THE CPR. A. P. SHE
COLLABORATION CHIP WHEREAS AS
AS A PRACTICING- I AM VERY
FAMILIAR WITH MY PATIENTS AND
THEIR CONDITIONS AND- ONCE IN A
WHILE. YOU KNOW- MY CLIENT WILL
CALL UP AND SAY TO SEVEN UP
THAT AGAIN AND I COULD SEE.
DASH FOR THIS IN THE NINE. WHAT
CONDITION DASH HAS BEEN
RECONNECTED JUST TO KERR TREAT
OR- ADD NEW ONES I THINK. IN
THOSE IT'S PROBABLY. BLACKS
IT'S ALSO ONE OF THOSE WERE
IT'S A LITTLE- DANGERS TO
COMPARE BUT BY THE G. AND
THAT'S- BECAUSE YOU YEMEN LAST
AND TALIBAN DEFINITELY IS.
BECOMING VERY POPULAR. AND THE
BIGGER WHY AND WHERE FOR THEM
IS THAT PATIENTS CAN TALK ASIAN
SKIN SOME OF SIMPLE. WHAT
FEELING AND HOW LIKE WE ON. IS
OWNERS INTEREST. OF WHAT THAT
THE STEEL OR EXPERIENCE. I'LL
GIVE YOU A GOOD OF WHY
TELEMEDICINE. REALLY FIT WELL
WITH PROFESSION- RECENTLY A
FRIEND OF MY CALLED UP TRICKS
HIS- FRUSTRATE. WITH BACK BEING
ABLE TO GETS ADVICE FROM BETTER.
HE OWNS SOME OF MOLLA AND HE
TOOK THE CHARGER PARK. LAST
WEEK AT A COUPLE OF DAYSLATER
THE MOSTAR TO CALL. AND JOHN HE
AS SOON YOU KNOW HIS CHEER
PICKED SOMETHING FROM THE DOG
PARK LIKE GENERAL HOSPITAL JUST
ONE IS THE IN EVERY. DESCRIBE
SOME AND. FOR WHEN I HIM TELL
THIS THE FIRST THING THAT I WAS
THAT HE TO CHOOSE. AND LITTLE
DOG LIKE SHE- SOMETIMES CAN BE
TO. HEART DISEASE OR THE BE
PRONE TO. AND COMICAL IT. LIKE
AMERITRADE IT AND NOW BRING
PIPE. AND- THOSE ALL MEMBERS IN
A- SO ACT THAT THE JOB TO TALK
PART A COUPLE DAYS AGO. MAYBE
JUST A QUITE STEP. AND THE- NOT
THIS IS A BE. PRODUCTS USED
ANOTHER. FOR THE WAY WE TELL
THE OFTENTIMES IS BY NO TO
THEIR STATUS TO JUST- DEALING
WITH HER HAIR TO GET A SEE IF
THERE'S- SENSITIVITY THAT ARE
SMILING. THOSE ARE THINGS I CAN
DO- OVER THE TELEPHONE- EVERY
**** AB ONE DAY I'LL BE ABLE
TO. BECOME A WHOLE IMAGE THE
DOCTOR AND START. I CAN TELL
THAT- DID YOU LOG TELL ME THAT
ABOUT COST OF HEALTH. A COFFEE.
I HAVEN'T HEART. SO THAT'S-
DOES ALWAYS WORK AND WITH OUR
PROFESSION SO- WE'RE NOT.
COMPLETE OPPOSE TO COME
WHATSOEVER. BUT IT NEEDS TO BE.
OR ELSE HARM CAN BE DONE TO THE
CONSUMER. WELL THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY MAKE SENSE TO ME SO
COULD YOU. THE SHELTERS ON WHAT
WHAT WOULD THEY BE USING TELL
FOR. VISIT IT'S LIKE THEY WERE
LIKE TAKE. ACCESS. THIS JUST
SHOWS OUR COMMUNITY. DOES WANTS
TO YOU KNOW CHALLENGE TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO AND I HAPPENED MOVIE
THAT THE REASON YOU'RE THIS
THEY JUST MIGHT BE A TO SEE
MORE. IF THE CAN DO WHAT OVER
THE- OR OVER J. ONE THEN. TO
HAVE THOSE PATIENTS COMING THE
CLINIC TO SEE THE- AND THERE
THERE IS THAT- YOU KNOW IT'S
BETTER THAN NOTHING AND- AGAIN
GOING BACK TO. THAT FIRST
EXAMINATION ZERO TO REALLY
LISTEN TO THE PACK G. OF THE
CAT JUST SMELL PACKED THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT JUST CAN'T BE
ACCOMPLISHED OVER THE PHONE.
AND EVEN THOUGH IT MAY BE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE MARC SENSIBILITY MAY
BE ABLE TO SEE MORE BLACK THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN. IT
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO I
DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE THAT YOU
CAN CHOOSE. A MINIMUM STANDARD
OF CARE ON A BRAND NEW PATIENTS
ARE WITHOUT SEEING IT FIRST.
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- THEN
PERHAPS MY QUESTION IS- BETTER
DIRECTED TO THE CHAIRS OF OUR
COMMUNITY- REVIEWING THE I WANT
TO RETURN TO THE FEE ISSUE VERY
QUICKLY AND I'M NOTICING THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FEES HAVE
INCREASED SUBSTANTIALLY 30% IN
ATTORNEYS SERVICES AND 71%
INCREASE IN. LEGAL SERVICES AND
THAT WOULD APPEAR TO PERHAPS
IMPACT ON MANY OF OUR- BOARDS
UNDER I. D. C. A. R. MAY WE ASK
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO COME IN
AT SOME POINT IN TIME AND GIVE
US. SOME SORT OF AN OVERVIEW OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THEIR
DEPARTMENT THAT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SIGNIFICANT FEE
INCREASES THAT WILL BE PASSED
ON OF COURSE TO A NUMBER OF OUR
OF OUR OUR OVERSIGHT BOARDS IT
WAS SOME INTERESTING YOU KNOW
BREEZES BEEN A PROBLEM SINCE I
WAS NINE BEIN P. BACK AND
TWENTY I THINK WHEN I FIRST GOT
HERE SCANDIA IF NOT PERFECTED
YET I ASSUME ARE STILL WORKING
THROUGH IT BUT- THIS IS A-
SPECIFIC. SIGNIFICANT JUMP IN
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THIS
BOARD IS TELLING US- REGARDING
THE SUSTAINABILITY OF THEIR
CURRENT OF FUNDED THEY'RE
LOOKING AT OF FEE INCREASES
THAT ARE GOING TO HIT US AND
TWENTY THREE IS IT TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE SO AND WE'D BE
LOOKING OUT YOU KNOW SO ANOTHER
JUMP. THAT SUB. ON OUR- ON OUR
VETERINARIANS IN PERHAPS MY
OTHER. OF OUR OUR BOARD AND
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF THAT I
THINK IS PRETTY CRITICAL. RIGHT
AFTER ON EITHER HAIR TO
RESPOND IF WE MIGHT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO AT LEAST HAVE A
REPORT FROM THEM AS TO THE
REASON WE'VE SEEN THIS KIND OF
FEE INCREASE- THAT IS.
TRANSFERRED TO YOU KNOW THE
INDIVIDUAL BOARDS. EVENT
INFORMATION AS YOU AS YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MULTIPLE
OPPORTUNITIES AS WE HAVE OF
SIXTEEN BOARDS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS THIS YEAR A
WITH A NUMBER OF- COSTS AND
INCREASE AND- COST MEASURES
THAT ARE DRIVING THE FEE
INCREASES SPECIFICALLY AROUND
MULTIPLE BOARDS AND THAT'S A-
CONTINUING ISSUE THAT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL BE HEARING. AS WE
ARE PRESENTED WITH A NUMBER THE
BOARDS THAT WILL BEGIN COMING
BEFORE US- AS WE BEGIN- THIS
CALENDAR YEAR TO OBEY CERTAINLY
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
TAKE A LOOK AT AND ENGAGE WITH
THE APPROPRIATE STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THIS. UNDER AS
HOLISTICALLY AS WELL AS AND
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
SENATE ROTH AT. WELL YOU KNOW
AS A PRANK FORMER PRACTICING
ATTORNEY I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO
HAVE HAD. A SITUATION WHERE I
COULD IMPOSE A 30% FEE INCREASE
ON MY CLIENTS. AND NOT HAVE THE
CLIENTS BE IN A POSITION TO
COMPLAIN. SO I DO THINK THAT
IT'S A IT IS CLEARLY
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE AN INQUIRY
I FULLY INTEND TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO ASK SOME QUESTIONS. I
DON'T COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT CAN. THAT SITUATION CAN
HAPPEN WITHOUT ANY-
CONVERSATION IN ADVANCE. SO
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WITH THE
WITH OF COURSE THE CONCURRENCE
OF BY. CHURCH LOW- WE'LL FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. ON THAT POINT. I THANK
YOU HI AND FINALLY WHAT
REGARDING THE COMMENTS THAT
DOCTOR NUNEZ MADE EARLIER ABOUT
RESPECT I WANT YOU TO KNOW MY
DOCTOR FRIENDS TELL ME THAT
IT'S HARDER TO BECOME- DOCTOR
OF VETERINARY MEDICINE IT DOWN
THE USUAL PRACTICE OF MEDICINE
SO IT. SKEWS ME DOCTOR BROWN
BUT- I'VE HEARD THAT A NUMBER
OF TIMES SO THAT YOU HAVE A
GREAT RESPECT FROM ALL OF US.
ANIMAL LOVERS ARE NOT. THANK
pSENATOR BATES ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AT THIS
TIME BEFORE WE GO INTO
WITNESSES- JUST WANT TO ALSO-
YEAH I JUST WANT TO ALSO MAKE A
ON- REMARK ED TO ECHO SOME OF
THE CONCERNS OF. ALSO BY A
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY BILL THIS IS
A AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBER DAVID CHIU- AND HAD THAT
HE HAS HEARD ALSO FROM ITS
CONSTITUENCIES TO- REFERENCE
THE DESIRE TO BROADEN
PERSPECTIVE TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
CARE FOR OWNED AND SHELTER PETS
AS WELL SO. I KNOW THAT THIS IS
THE ONGOING CONVERSATION OF
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
YOUR ROTH. THANK YOU A THANK
YOU CARILLO- LET ME RETURN TO
THE QUESTION IS- THEY WERE
POSED BY MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
ASSEMBLY REGARDING. A RURAL
SHELTERS- AND THE REGULATIONS.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF THESE
RURAL SHELTERS AT LEAST IN PART
CONTENT THEY NEED THE ABILITY
TO PERFORM. WHAT THEY DESCRIBE
AS LOW RISK ANIMAL CARE WITHOUT
VETERINARIAN OVERSIGHT SUCH AS
VACCINATIONS- AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT
SUBJECT. IS ENCOMPASSED IN
THESE REGULATIONS THAT WERE
REFERENCED EARLIER IS THAT
CORRECT. ANYONE. YES IN THE
REGULATIONS- THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING BACKS OBVIOUSLY
VACCINATIONS- PARASITE CONTROL-
ARE IMPORTANT IN SHELTERS AND
THIS- THE REGULATIONS WOULD
ALLOW FOR A VETERINARIAN TO
WRITE UP- PROTOCOLS AND FOR
SHELTER STAFF TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES- USING UTILIZING THOSE
PROTOCOLS RIGHT NOW STE ALL THE
SHELTERS- THAT ADMINISTER
VACCINES AND ALL OF THAT-
REGARDLESS IF THEY DON'T DO ANY
SPAY AND NEUTER BUT THEY DO
VACCINES WHICH IS CRITICAL AND
PARASITE THEY ARE UNDER THE
CURRENT- MINIMUM STANDARDS OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE FOR
FACILITIES- WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS RELAX THOSE THOSE
STANDARDS FOR THOSE SHELTERS
THAT HAVE A DIFFICULTY WITH
HAVING A VETERINARIAN ON SITE.
FIVE AND. IN THE RURAL AREAS
CETERA. ONE MAKE SURE A BIG IT
CLEARS SO THE MINUTE STAY
CURRENTLY REQUIRE. THAT A
VETERINARIAN BE ON SITE IN
ORDER FOR THAT ACTIVITY TO
OCCUR. I DO NOT- JESSICA PLEASE
CORRECT ME BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THEY REQUIRE THE
VETERINARIAN TO BE ON SITE.
VETERINARY THE NEW MINIMUMS FOR
SHELTER MEDICINE IS THAT A
VETERINARIAN ESTABLISHES THE
PROTOCOLS RESULT FROM ACCIDENTS
YEAH- ONCE THOSE PARTICLES BEEN
ESTABLISHED NO NAY MAYBE POSTED
ON THE WALL THE PRESENT IN A
BINDER SOME PLACE THAT- THAT
SHELTER STAFF GEN MINISTER
THOSE VACCINATIONS. AND THAT'S
WHAT I READ ARE GOING TO ALLOW.
THAT TO CURB WITH THAT IN AND
HAVING TO THERE OKAY LET ME GET
TO MY POINT ONE OF MY- COULD
CAN. IS THE SPEED OR LACK SPEED
BY WHICH WE ALL OF US. REDUCE
REGULATIONS IN THE STATE. FROM
START TO FINISH AND THE
MATERIAL THAT WAS PROVIDED TO
US INDICATES THAT THESE
PARTICULAR REGULATIONS MAYBE
I'M WRONG. WERE UNOFFICIALLY
ADOPTED OR AUTHORIZED ONE OF
THE OTHER. BY THE BOARD IN
APRIL OF- TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND THE PROCESS OF FEW MINUTES
AGO IS DESCRIBED AS BEING IN
ITS INFANCY AND SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO THESE
PARTICULAR REGULATIONS HAVING
TO DO WITH RURAL SHELTERS IS
WHEN WERE THE REGULATIONS
INITIALLY PROMULGATED. APRIL
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS THAT
FINE. AND WHY IS IT TAKING SO
LONG SINCE WE'RE NOW IN. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. D. THE
BOARD APPROVED THE REGULATIONS
AND I BELIEVE IN AUGUST OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IT WAS
SHORTLY AFTER I STARTED WHEN I
STARTED IN JULY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND WHEN THEY APPROVE
THE FINAL I AND I THINK WHAT
WHAT UNFORTUNATELY HAPPENED
DURING THAT TIME IS THAT WE
WERE GOING OVER A PERIOD F
TRANSITION LESS STAFF AS WELL
AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT WE ALSO
HAD. A LOT OF REGULATIONS THAT
WERE ALREADY IN QUEUE BEFORE
ABOUT TWENTY ONE TWENTY WILL
MAKING PACKAGES AND A GOOD
CHUNK OF THEM HAD ALREADY BEEN
I'M STARTED IN THE REVIEW
PROCESS AND SO THIS ONE AND I
AM I HAVE ONE POLICY ANALYSTS
YOU'LL HELP MOVE ALL THESE
PACKAGES THROUGH. AND SO THAT
PLUS DANCE IS DEVOTED TO THE
ALL OF THE REGULATIONS THAT
WERE ALREADY IN THE QUEUE AND
SO WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DEAL
I'M DEVELOP TRYING TO THAT THE
SHELTER REGULATIONS NEARLY
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT WERE. ALREADY
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS. ONE
OF THE THINGS I'M GOING TO BE A-
OF. BOARDS TO DO FROM PURSE- IT
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
REGULATORY PROCESS AND SEE HOW
WE CAN STREAMLINED AND
EXPEDITED. AND THE OTHER THING
I'M GOING TO BE ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT SO IT MIGHT.
MOVE THOE WHO WERE ASSOCIATED
WITH BOARDS TO START DOING THIS-
IS TO START KEEPING A- BUT AT A
TIME LOG. THE RECORD. FROM THE
INCEPTION OF THE REGULATION TO
THE FINAL ADOPTION. EXPLAINING
DELAYS IN THE PROCESS MEASURED
AGAINST YOUR TIME STANDARDS
WHICH I HOPE YOU HAVE FOR THE
ADOPTION OF REGULATIONS BECAUSE
I WANT TO START HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SPECIFICALLY
WHAT THE DELAYS ARE AND WHAT WE
CAN DO TO HELP YOU AS BOARDS
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
ATTEMPTING TO DO A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB. A MOVE THESE
REGULATIONS ALONG WITH A LITTLE
MORE- SPEED- AND EFFICIENCY I
DO APPRECIATE WHAT YOU DO I DO
UNDERSTAND. HAVING BEEN
REMINDED JUST THE OTHER DAY
THAT OF THE REASON YOU DO
REGULATIONS IS BECAUSE WE
PASSED BILLS THAT TURNED INTO
STATUTES THAT NEED TO BE
INTERPRETED AND- I AM COGNISANT
OF THAT BUT I ALSO THINK THAT.
AS WE MOVE OUR PRACTICE ALONG
HERE AND TRY TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT I THINK THE BOARDS IN
THE UNDER THE DC A NEED TO DO
SO AS WELL SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. SO ONE OF. SOMEWHAT
RELATED NOTE HAVING TO DO WITH
ENFORCEMENT YOU KNOW IT'S COME
TO MY ATTENTION AND LOOKING AT
VARIOUS BOARDS. IN THIS NEW JOB
THAT I HAVE THE- MOST IF NOT
ALL BOARDS OR ENFORCE IT
EXPERIENCING DELAYS IN THE
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. AND THAT
YOURS IS ONE OF THOSE AND I'M
I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN. TALK
TO ME ABOUT. THE NATURE OF THE
DELAYS IN THE ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS AND- BASED ON YOUR
EXPERIENCE- WHICH DELAYS APPEAR
TO BE WITHIN THE CONTROL OF THE
BOARD AND WHICH DELAYS APPEAR.
TO BE OUTSIDE OF THE CONTROL OF
THE BOARD. SURE I JUST WANTED
TO GO BACK TO YEAR YOUR NEWS
COMMENTS ABOUT THEM WERE MAKING
PROCESS AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS- AND THE CONCERNS
I THINK THAT MANY OF US I'M
FROM THE CORPORATE SEPTEMBER
SECOND HAVE THE SIMILAR
CONCERNS BUT WHAT I CAN'T
STAND. SINCE THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE NEW DIRECTORY DCA I KNOW
I'M ARE WE MAKING PACKAGES HAVE
SEEN SEEN TO BE MOVING AT
QUICKER. AND I KNOW THAT THE
RULE MAKING PROCESS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHE'S REALLY
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING SITE I
KNOW THAT ALL OF US AT THE
BOARD AND I DO SEE A WERE
DEFINITELY WILLING TO YOU. I'M
EVALUATE THE PROCESS AND
STREAMLINED WHEREVER POSSIBLE.
WHEN IT COMES TO ENFORCEMENT I
THINK THERE ISN'T A NUMBER OF
THINGS AND THEN I FOUND THAT
HAD CREATED SUCH A LONG
PROCESSING TIME AND WE'VE WE'VE
TAKEN A LOT OF MEASURES AND TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESSES. I'M ONE
OF THE BIG THINGS THAT THAT I
DID WHEN I FIRST STARTED IS AND
WHEN I EVALUATED WHAT WAS
OCCURRING IN OUR ENFORCEMENT
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM. PLAN LET
ME BACK UP IS THAT WE WERE
GETTING ROUGHLY TWELVE HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS A YEAR WE HAD FOR IT
FOR A COMPLETE LIST TWO OF
WHICH WERE HANDLING THE ENTIRE
INVESTED YOU KNOW HE SLOW. I'M
AND THEN THAT AND THOSE WERE
OUR LOWER LEVEL ANALYSTS THEY
WERE SELF SERVICE ANALYST HE HE
I'M- MORE AT THE HIGHER LEVEL
ANALYSTS THE EPA'S THEY WERE
HANDLING THE DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS LEADING WITH THE
DISPLAY KEY PHOTO SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS. I'M LISTENING ROUGHLY
FORTY HE SAYS HERE THAT THAT
WERE THEY WERE HANDLING
DISCIPLINE WHEN THE TWO STAFF
SERVICES DALLAS WERE IN CHARGE
OF DOING- ALL OF THE
INVESTIGATIVE CASELOAD. AND SO
THAT WAS. JUST A OF. GARY AND
MATT SO. AND SO WE DID IS WE
DIDN'T. UP ALL OF CASES AMONG
OF THE- WE INCREASE THE CLASS
OF THE- MAKE THEM S. AND A-
YEAH. AND I'M AND WE- A LOT OF
TRINA ON HOW TO YOU. THE KEY
FROM TO FINISH. ANOTHER THING
WE REALLY. SAW WE- WAS ON
RELIANCE ON. AND ARE. SUFFERS I
IT WAS ONE PRACTICE THE PAST.
THAT MOST IRAQIS GO DIVISION
AND THEN A MESSAGE. HE ALSO GO
OUT FOR AND WHEN WE USED TO BE
AND BY. I'M OCT. THEY WERE USED
FOR SCENES THAT WE- I'M AT THIS
POINT. OUR NOT NOT. SO I'M
WE'RE USING TO MY TO GO OUT AND
GET I RECORD WHEN WE CAN USE
OUR AND- TO DO THAT. WE ARE
USING THE ONLINE TO. AND GET A
CLUE RECORD AND ARREST RECORDS
FROM ARREST AGENCIES WHEN IT
COMES PHOENIX. OTHER THINGS MY
STAFF IS ABLE DEAL I'M AND SO
WE WHEN YOU LOOK AT AT AT DMI
IT TAKES A VERY LONG TIME AND
IT'S ALSO VERY VERY EXPENSIVE.
TO DEAL I'M ONE THING I THINK
THAT IS WORTH NOTING THAT. I
YES THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT THE
INCREASE FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE BUT ONE THING
FREE DENIES THERE'S A CONSTANT
INCREASE. EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND
WE'RE UP TO PAYING ATTY ACTUALS
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN WAS THREE
HUNDRED TWO DOLLARS PER HOUR
AND THE KEY SAYS FOR DMI. AND
AS A LESS COMPLEX HE'S GOING TO
BE A MINIMUM OF TWENTY HOURS. I
IN SAID THAT THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT COST THERE WAS ONE
YEAR I BELIEVE IT WAS SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WE SPENT THREE
QUARTERS OF. A MILLION DOLLARS
ON DELIGHT CLASS. BUT I THINK
THAT WE WERE UNDER THE UTILIZED
A LOT IS THERE EXISTS TOOL
EVERY. ARE INSPECTOR. THERE
KEALAKEHE THE OF THE- EXPERTISE
NEEDED I'M IS- IN A STILL. THEY
KNOW WHAT TO LOOK FOR A MEDICAL
RECORDS AND SO WHAT WE REALLY
DID AS AS WE TRANSITIONED OUR
RELIANCE ON USING BOTH DIVISION
INVESTIGATION AND INSPECTORS.
DIDN'T JEAN INCREASING OUR USE
ON OUR ON OUR INSPECTORS IN OUR
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS. ANOTHER
THING THAT WE CHANGES I'M NOT
ONLY WERE USING DFI ANR
INSPECTORS IN IN MULTIPLE
PIECES- BUT WE ARE ALSO USING
MULTIPLE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS. ON OUR CASES THAT
INVOLVED STAND UP HERE ISSUES
AND LIKE I SAID IN THE
BEGINNING 35% OF OUR CASES ARE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS. IN THE
PROCESS WAS THAT WE HAD OUR AND
ALL OF OUR CASES WERE ALWAYS
REVIEWED BY ASSESSMENT EXPERTS
EVEN PIECES BURKE. I'M
REGARDING THINGS THAT WERE NOT
NECESSARILY SEND THE CARES OF
CONVICTION HE SAYS. AND THOSE
CASES DON'T NECESSARILY NEED AN
EXPERT TO APPLYING BECAUSE THE
MERE FACT THAT THERE'S A
CONVICTION IS ENOUGH TO
INVESTIGATE BUT WE DON'T NEED
THE EXPERTISE. OF THE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT. I'M SO IT GO FOR
I ARE HOUSE. WE TO MOVE THEM AT
THE TIME IN THE AND THEY WOULD
DO. YOU KNOW THEIR WRITE UP A
REPORT AND THEN IF SOMETHING I
THE BILL. WAS AGREED YOU LEVEL
THE SUPPLY THAT IT WAS BEEN SO
YOU CAN OUT TO ANOTHER SUCH
MATTER AT. THAT SOME EXPERT NEW
ALL OF NEED FOR. EITHER OWN
OPINION WELL AND THAT WAY IN.
THE A OF TIME AND MONEY. ON A
CASE. I WE IN SO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS. AMERICANS CASES
WHEN. THAT HOW DOES THE PLAN
I'M WE ALSO HAD MULTIPLE PEOPLE
AT THE TIME WHO WERE TOUCHING
THOSE CASES. I MULTIPLE STAFF
PEOPLE IN SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS WE
HAD CASES WHERE WE HAD- YOU CAN
HAVE UP TO. YOU TO SUCH AN
EXPERT FROM PORTSMOUTH AND I WE
CAN HAVE AS INSPECTOR THAT DID
THE INITIAL INSPECTION AND
INNOCENT DOCTOR LEAD INSPECTOR
WHEN IT COMES TO COMPLAINT
SOMEWHERE RT AT FORCED SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS IS. ESSENTIALLY
WE HAD MULTIPLE STAFF WERE
INVOLVED. I'M AND WE HAD.
INVOLVED AS WELL SO THAT'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ONE SPECIFIC CASE
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS WHEN THOSE
CASES GOING HERE IN. ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE SUBPOENAED TO
TESTIFY IT WAS NOT COMMON THAT
IN THOSE CASES WE CAN HAVE A
HEARING THAT'S TWO TO THREE
WEEKS WANT. AND WE DURING THOSE
DAYS EVERY SINGLE DAY WERE
PAYING PART WITNESSES OKAY FOR
THE L. J. RIPPING FOR THE COURT
REPORT FOR PAYING FOR THE DAY.
AND NOT THAT CAPTURED CLUSTER.
HIS CLASSICAL STOPS AND AS UP
INTO THEY'VE- HEARING. TO BE
THE PERSON ON THAT KEY IS THE
R. X. ONE EXPERT WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT HAVING JUST ONE ONE
STAFF MEMBER INVOLVED IN THAT
CASE I SAID THAT'S ALSO GOING
TO STREAMLINE A LOT OF THE
PROCESS THIS ANOTHER THING THAT
WE REALLY WORKED ON WITH END UP
THEN- DETERMINE GENERAL'S
OFFICE IS MORE COMMUNICATION UP
FRONT. I'M AND ALSO AT THE SME
TIME OUR STAFF DOING MORE WORK
UP FRONT IN THE PAST WHAT WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IS THAT WE WENT
ON WE GOT A CASE WE WILL TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE CASE AND ASK
THEM FOR MEDICAL RECORDS WE
DIDN'T TELL THEM WHAT THE
ALLEGATIONS WERE AND ASKING FOR
A RESPONSE AT THE TIME WHAT
HAPPENED IS THAT WE ARE GETTING
THE MEDICAL RECORDS FROM THEM
AND WE WERE GETTING THE
INFORMATION FROM THE
COMPLAINTS. THAT WOULD GO OUT
TO THE SUCH MEASURE EXPRESSED
FOR REVIEW AND THEN WE GATHER
ALL THAT INFORMATION AND SEND
IT OUT TO THE TWENTY GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND SAY THAT WE WANTED
TO FILE AN ACCUSATION. YOU GO
AHEAD AND COLLECT THE
MEDICATION. AND THE MITIGATION
IN. AN THE SERBS WERE. TO THE-
AND- A MEDICARE FACTORS THAT
THE PERSON HAS DONE. I'M TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE-
VIOLATIONS ON RECORD THAT. I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY I'M SORRY JIM
YESTERDAY- CONCLUDE YOUR A
RESPONSE AS I KNOW THAT
CHAIRMAN ACT HAS A QUESTIONS SO
WE CAN BE TIMELY WITH OUR NEXT
BOARD MAYBE I CAN. MAYBE I CAN
HELP ONE. I'D LIKE TO SEE SOME
DETAIL MAYBE FROM THE BOARD TO
STAFF AND- ENSURE LOW YOU CAN
INCLUDE ME IF YOU LIKE. ON WHAT
THESE PROCESS CHANGES ARE THAT
YOU EITHER ARE PROPOSING OR OF
IMPLEMENTED MY FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IS TIRES I ASSUME BUT
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
PERFORMANCE METRICS. ON THIS
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS MUCH LIKE
THE DCA IS IMPLEMENTED WITH
RESPECT TO REGULATIONS IN OTHER
WORDS RIGHT PROCESSING
TIMELINES GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
SO I'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT THOSE
PERFORMANCE METRICS ARE I
DIDN'T SEE THEM IN THE STAFF
REPORT. AND I'D LIKE TO KNOW IF
YOU TRACK THE DELAYS BEYOND
YOUR PERFORMANCE METRICS AND
TRACK THE REASONS FOR THE
DELAY. AND. MEASURE THOSE
AGAINST YOUR METRICS. ONE OKAY
SO THAT'S THE END FOR I'D LIKE
HAVE AN MICHAEL. IS THESE
VARIOUS PROCESS- IMPROVEMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE MENTIONED AND
THAT YOU HAVE IMPLEMENTED. HAVE
YOU QUANTIFIED IT WHETHER OR
NOT THOSE IMPROVEMENTS HAVE
INCREASED. YOUR PROCESSING TIME
OR OR KEPT AT THE SAME OR
DECREASED IT AND IF SO. WHAT'S
THE ANSWER. SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ALL OF THAT IN WRITING
FOR YOU I'M AND THEN SHORT
ANSWER FOR THAT IS IT'S GOING
TO BE SOME TIME BEFORE WE SEE
THE ACTUAL OVERALL IMPROVEMENTS
BECAUSE MY STAFF IS REALLY
FOCUSING ON CASES THAT ARE
OVER. AT FOUR YEARS OLD AND
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE HE SAYS
HAVE ALREADY GONE THROUGH ALL
OF THESE PROCESSES THAT HAVE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT CHANGING
AND SO WE ARE WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH THE BACKLOG RIGHT NOW.
BUT I'M MORE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ALL OF THAT THE NECESSARY DATA
TO SHOW. INCREMENTAL THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE HAPPENING
AND THEN ALSO THE COST SAVINGS
OVERALL. OKAY LET ME MOVE
QUICKLY TO COST RECOVERY
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WITH RESPECT
TO. DCA BOARDS- STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS A SEEM TO BE A FACT OF
LIFE IF NOT NOW IN THE FUTURE.
SO WITH RESPECT. TO COST
RECOVERY- ARE YOU ABLE FULLY
RECOVER YOUR ENFORCEMENT COSTS
FROM THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
DISCIPLINED. THAT'S THE
QUESTION AND LET ME BREAK IT
DOWN WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFICITY. THERE OBVIOUSLY A
TOTAL ENFORCEMENT EXPENSES THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH A VARIETY
OF CASES BUT THERE ARE COSTS
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED. WITH CASES
WHERE COST RECOVERY IS POSSIBLE.
IN THOSE CASES WERE COST
RECOVERY IS POSSIBLE WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF YOUR ENFORCEMENT
COSTS DO YOU RECOVER. ON THE
AVERAGE. SO I DON'T HAVE THAT
PERCENTAGE- I MEAN BUT I CAN
I'M HAPPY TO RUN RIGHT AFTER
THIS HEARING I'M BUT I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT THAT THE COST
RECOVERY ON THE ON THE TURN
THAT IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER
THAT THAT WAS POSSIBLE THE
DISCIPLINE ALSO INCLUDES I'M
THOSE WHO HAVE SURRENDERED OR
HAD REVOKED LICENSES. AND WHILE
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT IT'S LIKELY
THE ONLY WE ONLY WILL SEE THOSE
COSTS WITH A PETITION FOR
REINSTATEMENT AND SO THAT'S IT
THAT'S IT SINCE YOU WERE IN
PART BETWEEN THAT WE ACTUALLY
RECOUP THOSE COSTS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THE ACTUAL
PERCENTAGE IN THAT ANALYSIS FOR
YOU. WELL I WOULD LIKE SEE THAT
AND MISTER. ONE FINAL- THE
SUBJECT OF ANIMAL PHYSICAL
REHABILITATION. WAS DISCUSSED
IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER APPEARS
TO BE AN ISSUE. OF ANIMAL
PHYSICAL REHABILITATION BY
LICENSED PHYSICAL THERAPIST AS
OPPOSED TO. OF VETERINARIANS
AND MY QUESTION IS DOES THE
BOARD WANT THE AUTHORITY TO
ALLOW. LICENSED PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
UNDER VETERINARY SUPERVISION TO
PERFORM. THAT TYPE OF SERVICE
TO THE OUR ANIMAL POPULATION.
YEAH I CAN I CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I MEAN SHORT ANSWER IS
YES THE LICENSE. THEIR PAST-
CAN'T PERFORM PHYSICAL THERAPY
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF A
VETERINARIAN IN THE CURRENT
REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE
FOLLOWS. I THOUGHT THERE WAS
SOME ISSUE THAT THE BOARD'S
CLAIM THAT THE BOARD DIDN'T
HAVE AUTHORITY TO. PERMIT THAT
AND THEN THERE WAS A BILL IN
THE BOARD OPPOSED THE BILL OF
LIFE. HAVE I FORGOTTEN MY
LEGISLATIVE HISTORY. YEAH THE
CONTROVERSY WAS THAT- INITIALLY
THE PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD IS
APPOINTED REGULATES- PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS IN THEIR PRACTICE
ACT- THEY ONLY TALK ABOUT
PRACTICING PHYSICAL THERAPY ON
HUMANS- NO ONE IN THEIR
PRACTICE ACT THE TALK ABOUT
THEM PRACTICES ON ANIMALS- OUR
PRACTICE ACT- IT WAS JUST GOT
THERE IT WAS DEFINED AS THE
PRACTICE OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE. AND ASKED THE
PRACTICES THAT IT NEVER MET
THAT IN A MEDICINE THAT NEEDS
TO BE PERFORMED BY
VETERINARIANS- IT COULD ALSO BE
PERFORMED BY OUR REACHES UNDER-
LEVEL OF SUPERVISION BY THE
VETERINARIANS AND VETERINARY
ASSISTANCE UNDER THE LEVEL OF
SUPERVISION. VETERINARIANS-
WHAT WAS- WHAT NEEDED TO BE TO
OUR PRIME ARE WAS- TO A- JUST
COMPARE. TO PRACTICE- FINAL- SO
THAT IT WOULD BE IN OUR
PRACTICE ACT BUT THE BIG AREA
OF CONTENTION WAS WHAT LEVEL OF
SUPERVISION DURING THESE
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS NEED TO
OPERATE UNDER- THEY- ONE SIDE
BELIEVES THAT THE- ARE ONE STEP
THE NEED FOR PHYSICAL THERAPY
WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE
VETERINARIAN JESSICA SERVICE
DOES NOT HAVE TO PRACTICE UNDER
ANY LEVEL OF SUPERVISION ON THE
VETERINARIAN AND ALSO VERY
CONTENTION WAS- TODAY TO
PRACTICES ACT. UP PREMISE
COMMITTEE AREA LIKE AN INNER
PEACE OR SOMETHING. WELL I'M
WILL CLEAR OF THIS BUT THE JUST
TO REFRESH RECOLLECTIONS THE
BACKGROUNDER. INDICATES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ATTEMPTED TO
ENACT THE CHANGE THROUGH AB
THIRTY THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WHICH WOULD HAVE ALLOWED UNDER
SPECIFIED CONDITIONS A LICENSED
PHYSICAL THERAPIST UNDER
VETERINARIAN SUPERVISION.
THAT'S CENTERED SERVICE CENTER
TO PROVIDE- PHYSICAL
REHABILITATION SERVICES TO AN
ANIMAL PATIENT THE BILL WAS
HELD APPROPRIATIONS AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY BUT WAS OPPOSED BY THE
BOARD AND THAT'S THE BASIS FOR
MY QUESTION WE CAN REVISIT THIS
BUT- I THINK IT'S PROBABLY A
SUBJECT THAT NEEDS TO BE-
FURTHER DISCUSS. THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER OFTEN IT'S AS
A- AND OBSERVATION TO IRIS
STILL UNDERSTAND YOU ALSO CARE
SUB FOR IN THE SENATE TO IN
WHICH- DID D. D. CA DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER PRESS REGULATIONS.
WREG'S UNITS I WAS UP FOR
RENEWAL IN CONSIDERATION AS
WELL TOO SO I THINK THAT WERE
HEARING AS WE ARE TACKLING SOME
OF THESE ISSUES ARE SOME
REOCCURRING THEMES AND- HE BE
PRUDENT FOR. A DCA AND OUR
COMMITTEE STAFFS ALSO. HAVE
DIALOGUE ON SOME OF THESE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SO HAVING SAID THAT
CONCLUDING QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WILL GO TO. PUBLIC COMMENT I
CAN SEE THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE DIALED
IN AND JUST AS A REMINDER WE
PROVIDE A NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES IF YOU COULD KINDLY
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO. NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES IF YOU PREFER
WE'D LIKE TO KEEP THEM AS
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME PUBLIC COMMENT
MAY ALSO BE CONCLUDED. AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE COMMITTEE SO
WE'LL GO TO THE OPERATOR
OPERATOR PLEASE FEEL FREE TO.
TO OPEN UP THE LINE AND PRIOR
JUST BEFORE WE DO THAT ON THE
S. IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
VIRGO KEEP ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE CHAMBERS AT THIS TIME- SO
AGAIN MEMBERS OF. THE PUBLIC
WHO WISH TO SPEAK OF FEEL FREE
TO DO SO IN THE CURRENTLY IN
THE CHAMBERS AND THEN WILL GO
TO. INDIVIDUALS MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO HAVE DIALED. IN
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU LIKE
INSTRUCTIONS NOW- DID JUST ONE
MOMENT IF YOU COULD IF YOU
COULD PLEASE WAIT WE WERE JUST
THAT CAN TURNING ON THE
MICROPHONE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
TO JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. OKAY
WELL MOVED WELL AS WE AS WE GET
THAT- I GIVE THAT ADDRESS WILL
GO BACK TO A SERVER. HERE WE GO.%
WELCOME THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW YES. A CHAIR ROTH CHAIR
LOW EIGHT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES. MY NAME IS SOLOMON
STEW I REPRESENT THE LEVY IN
THE SHOP THE FOR BETTER
PROTECTION. I CAME HERE TO
REQUEST THAT THIS COMMITTEE
MAKE IT A REQUIREMENT. TO
DISPLAY A FICTIONAL FORTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE POINT FIVE OF THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
ALSO KNOWN AS LEVI'S LITTLE OR
LEASES LOW FOR VETERINARY
PHARMACY I'D VETERINARY CLINICS
AND HOSPITALS. BECAUSE THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD IS NOT ENFORCING THESE
CONSUMER PROTECTION LAW. IN THE
VETERINARY BOARD IS NOT A BOWL
OF THE LITTLE. EVE THESE LAW IS
NOT DISPLAYED THEIR OWNERS AND
THEIR AGENTS ARE NOT AWARE THAT
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE OFFERED
THE OPTION OF RECEIVING THE
CONSULTATION IMPAIR SON OR
ELECTRONICALLY. MEANING BY
EMAIL THE X. ZOOM
VIDEOCONFERENCE BREEN THING OR
ANY MEANS THAT INVOLVES
ELECTRONIC PROCEDURES. GIVE
THESE LAWYERS NOT THESE. PET
OWNERS AND THEIR AGENTS ARE NOT
AWARE THAT THEY CAN REQUEST
DOCUMENTATION TO READ ABOUT THE
MEDICATIONS YOU SOMETHING VERY
SIMPLE SOMETIMES YOU WANT TO
READ. SOMETHING ABOUT THE
MEDICATION TO ME OF THE LAW IS
NOT DISPLAYED GOOD OWNERS CAN
NOT. RE A- IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE INDUSTRY VETERINARY
MEDICINE IT'S ALSO ABOUT WE THE
CONSUMERS IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE CDMA AND THEIR LOGS THEY
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND
MEDICAL SCIENCE HAS CHANGED IN
CONSUMERS SHOULD KNOW TO NOT BE
KEPT IN THE DARK ANY LONGER IN
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
HAPPENING IS THAT EVERY TIME
BEING JACK THE YOUNG PEOPLE YOU
ALREADY. CONVENIENCE THEY NEVER
TELL THE PET OWNER OR THE AGENT
OF THE OWN THEIR THAT THE SOME
PEOPLE I ALREADY. FACE FOR
SIXTY FIVE BASE IN THE BODY OF
THE BET. IN DURING BOTH SIXTY
FIVE DAYS THE ASSEMBLY
LIABILITY CAN CAUSE ADVERSE
EFFECTS. IN THE BOTTLE IN THERE
IN THE OR THE AGENT OF THE
OWNER HAS THE RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT TYPE OF MEDICATION YOU
THESE. SO THERE OUT THE OF
CHOICE. AND THEY NEED TO
EXPLAIN IN REGARDS TO
CONVENIENCE. THAT YOU A
MEDICATION THAT THE HIVE
SPECIAL ISSUES WHEN THE BATH
HALF KEEP ME THIS FEES AND THEY
KNOW VERY WELL AND YET THEY
DON'T EXPLAIN. TO CONSUMERS AT
THIS MOMENT THERE IS NOT AN
ONLINE PETITION. APPROACHING
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SIGNATURES
ABOUT THIS PROBLEM WITH
CONVENIENT IN THE PETITIONS. TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. A I JUST WANT
TO FEEL MY THAT THESE. YOU WILL
OR WHAT FOR ENACTED THANKS TO
THE SCHOOL MEDIAN THANKS TO
THESE OF HEARINGS IT WAS
ENACTED AFTER I TESTIFIED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
SENATOR HILL WHO MIGHT WANT TO-
NUMBER FOUR HE'S DEEP
CONVICTION TO PROTECT PEOPLE
SHE AUTHORED THE BILL WITH. A
FAMILY MEMBER LOW SO PLEASE
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM OF
DISPLAYING THESE LITTLE FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL MAY OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE GALLERY IN
THE CHAMBERS C. NUMBER MOVE
THEN TO INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DIALED AN OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN UP AND JUST A
REMINDER NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. YOU MAY WITHDRAW YOUR
COMMENTED ANYTIME BY REPEATING
THE ONE ZERO COMMAND. IF YOU'RE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT TO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS MOMENT. AND THE FIRST
COMMENT IS FROM NINE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
SHE MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS CALLED LONDON ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. I DON'T LIKE TO
JUST PICK UP ON ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN THAT SENATOR ROBERTS WAS
DISCUSSING. RELATIVE TO ANIMAL
REHABILITATION ANIMAL FISCAL
THERAPY. JUST TO CLARIFY- THIS
WHOLE ISSUE WAS TAGGED LAST
SUNSETREVIEW HEARING BY THIS
COMMITTEE. AND AT THE DIRECTION
THE COMMITTEE A TASK FORCE WAS
CREATED. TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE
THE TASK FORCE INCLUDED MEMBERS
FROM BETTER MEDICINE PHYSICAL
THERAPY- ACADEMIA. OTHER
INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS AND THEY
RECOMMENDED THAT- PT'S IN FACT
BE ALLOWED PROVIDE ANIMAL
PHYSICAL REHABILITATION UNDER
THE DEGREE OF SUPERVISION
DETERMINED BY THE VETERINARIAN-
THAT WITH THE STANDARD THAT
WE'RE VERY COMFORTABLE WITH.
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS ARE
PROVIDING THIS KIND OF CARE IN
OTHER STATES AS WELL. THE
VETERAN MEDICAL BOARDS IN NORD
THAT RECOMMENDATION AND INSTEAD
APPROVED A STATE AND A KIND OF
BIFURCATED THE ISSUE BASICALLY
WHAT THEY DID IS THEY SAID THAT
THAT AMBER WAS OKAY FOR A LARGE
ANIMALS BUT NOT FOR SMALL
ANIMALS. ARE BOUGHT ON THAT IS
THAT THIS APPEARS TO BE REALLY
A MEASURE OF CONTROL- THIS
UNNECESSARY FOR VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH THE VETERANS
DECIDING THE LEVEL OF
SUPERVISION. I DON'T ASK ME TO
BASIS PER RELATIONSHIP AND WHAT
THEIR COMFORT LEVEL CONTAINING
THE P. T. WITHIN THE WORKING
WITH INTRIGUING ANIMALS THE
GOAL HERE REALLY IS GET THE
ANIMALS MOVEMENT BACK TO THE
BEST POSSIBLE CONDITIONS- IN IN
THE- CARE AND SUPPORT OF
ANIMALS. WE THINK WE'RE AT A
PERIOD NOW BASED ON THE BOARD'S
DECISION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER STEPPING IN TO
DETERMINE THIS ONCE AND FOR
ALL. IN REALLY SELECT THE
STANDARD THAT MAKES THE MOST
SENSE AND THAT IS INDEED
ALLOWING THE BATTERY TO PICK
LEVEL SUPERVISION THEY BELIEVE
IS NECESSARY FOR THE ANIMAL AND
WORKING WITH A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST. WHO HAS THE
CREDENTIALS ARE COMFORTABLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN. THE NEXT
COMMENT FROM THE LINE TWENTY
ONE YOUR LONG IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TRACY RIGHT WITH THE
WORLD COUNTY RED. OF I JUST TO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY VICE CHAIR
FONG ON THE REGULATIONS RELATED
SERVICES ALLOWED IN ANIMAL
SHELTERS. WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ESPECIALLY FOR RURAL PARTS OF
THE STATE THAT STRUGGLE TO
HAVE- AN ADEQUATE NUMBER OF
PROFESSIONALS HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT CAN TREAT-
THESE ANIMALS IN SHELTER AND
SHELTER LOCATIONS- THAT THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS TO. MEET
THAT PROTOCOLS- TO GET JUST A
SIMPLE VACCINATIONS OR
PROPHYLACTIC TREATMENTS ARE ARE
FAR MORE THAN WHAT SOME OF
THESE AREAS CAN- CAN MEET AND
SO WE REALLY- APPRECIATE- BYE.
BYE CHAIR FONG- COMMENTS AND-
AND MEMBER FONG- MEMBER I'M
SORRY NUMBER ROCK COMMENTS AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO AN EMPLOYER
THE- COMMITTEE AND THE BOARD TO
PLEASE TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
CONCERNS BEFORE MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TIME IT IS
FOR THE LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS LISA STARTED WITH-
FOUNDER AND CEO OF SOUTH SOUTH
AND THAT IS THE REHAB THERAPY
CENTER IN THE SILICON VALLEY- I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT SCOUTS
OUT IS THE SECOND OLDEST
VETERINARY REHABILITATION
THERAPY CENTER IN CALIFORNIA WE
OPENED SIXTEEN YEARS AGO THIS
MAY. AND WE HAVE BEEN
OPERATING- SENT THEM UNDER THE
PREMISE OF HAVING A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST FOR HUMANS. OF WORK
UNDER THE INDIRECT SUPERVISION
OF OUR VETERINARIANS- WE CAME
TO THAT MODEL BECAUSE THEIR
BUSINESS PARTNERS MY BUSINESS
PARTNERS WERE LICENSED
VETERINARIANS. AND I DECIDED
THAT. BBM DID NOT HAVE TO FISH
KNOWLEDGE TRAINING TO PERFORM
THOSE SERVICES AND THAT IS MY
OPINION MY BUSINESS PARTNER
STILL HOLD TODAY- COMPLETE
OPENS GAPS UP THE STREET MORE
THAN FIVE THOUSAND DOGS CATS
AND OTHER COMPANION ANIMALS AND
WE HAVE NEVER TO MY KNOWLEDGE
RECEIVED A COMPLAINT. ABOUT HER
MOM. I THINK THIS REGULATION
WILL PREVENT A FINANCIAL BURDEN
TO MY PRACTICE WE CANNOT AFFORD
TO PAY A VETERINARIAN TO BE ON
SITE AT ALL TIMES THAT'S ALL
THERE IS TO IT. WE DO OPERATE
UNDER HAVING A VETERINARIAN TO
AN INITIAL EXAM AND INITIAL
EVALUATION WITH ALL OF OUR
PATIENTS. IN LEAGUE WITH A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST WHO HEADS UP
OUR PROGRAM. I SUPPORT THE IDEA
OF ALLOWING. THE A TO PROVIDE
VETERINARIANS THAT ANY REHAB
FACILITY TO MAKE A DECISION
WHETHER TO ALLOW THE TIKI TO
OPERATE. UNDER INDIRECT OR
DIRECT SUPERVISION OF THE
TICKET OF THE DVM. BUT I'M NOT
HAPPY AT ALL WITH THE WAY THIS
WHOLE ISSUE'S BEEN HANDLED BY
THE MET THAT MEDICAL BOARD. I
DON'T THINK THEY'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO THE STAKEHOLDERS
LIKE OURSELVES I HAVE MADE
MYSELF AVAILABLE MANY TIMES-
TO- TALK WITH THEM AND HAVE
THEM SEE HOW THIS WORKS. I
THINK THEY'RE AND WILLINGNESS
TO COLLABORATE WITH US HAS.
BASICALLY MEANT THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
STEP IN AND SOLVE THIS ISSUE.
I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS FOR SOMEBODY TO COME UP
WITH REGULATIONS WE'VE DONE THE
BEST WE COULD AND I THINK WE
HAVE AN EXCELLENT MODEL WITH AN
EXCELLENT KATIE. AND I WOULD
ALSO ADD THAT I THINK ONE THING
THAT YOU SHOULD CONSIDER IS
HAVING A P. T. WHO WORKS UNDER
INDIRECT SUPERVISION P. FIFTY
BE CERTIFIED BY ONE THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH WE HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND JUST ARE A- JIM.
OF THE- A- IN IF YOU'RE MAY OF
THE WHO. IS UP AS THAT IS OUR
PREVIOUS BEEN STAY. PLEASE ONLY
INDICATE YOUR NAME AND PET'S.
ON THE TOPIC THANK YOU. THE
NEXT ACCOUNT MINUS NUMBER FORTY
THREE LINE FORTY THREE YEAR
OPEN. MY NAME IS BRIGITTE
LACOMBE AND SPEAKING TODAY- THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE AND
WAREHOUSE. ARE YOU CAN
ESTABLISH A REPRESENT
VETERINARY WORKERS HEALTH. I
REMEMBER LIKE HER SON SUPPORT
FOR ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE ON
THE VMB THE GENDER TODAY WHICH
RECOMMENDS THAT THE VETTING
MEDICAL BOARD BEGIN COLLECT
DATA I'M SURE AND OWNERSHIP. OF
PRACTICES. ARE YOU. PROPOSAL
FOR THREE READ- FIRST I YOU'RE
ALL. CORPORATE OR OF VETERINARY
HAS GROWN ACTUALLY IN THE PAST
YOU GUYS. TODAY- OVER 10% THE
VETERINARY. OUR OWN BY
CORPORATE PLAYERS. THE CHINA
SHOW THEM BY LARA MULTI COME
LIKE MARS. AND INDUSTRY EXPERTS
ANTICIPATE FLUORIDE OVER TO
FIVE BY TWENTY TWENTY. WE
BELIEVE THE RISE IN CORPORATE
OF THAT HEARING. COULD HAVE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON GQ STATION
AND VERY WORKERS. HOW THERE ARE
DO YOU COULD BE WRONG AS THEIR
CURRENTLY A DECLINE OF BIG DATA
ON ISSUE. THE ONLY WAY CAN
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT HI OR NOT
OF RISING AND- IS THAT WE HAVE
THE DATA TO. TRêN OVER TIME.
I'VE BEEN THERE IS YEAH IN THE
DATA THE BMB IS YOUR TO. AND
JUST CONNECTING DATA COLLECTION
HAD ARE THE UNDER IN AND CHAD.
TO REMEDY THAT WE ARE BACK THAT
THE BOARD THREE GET CURRENT TO
COLLECT PROCESS EACH YOU
INCLUDED ON. OWNERS OF PRACTICE.
IN ENSURING COMPLAIN AT TO BE
LIKE TO CORPORATE OWNERSHIP OF
APPROACH PRACTICE. WE THAT
IMPROVING THE BECAUSE AND THEY
COMPONENT SHOULD BECAUSE ACCESS
TO A FOUR. SPACE VETERINARY
HOSPITAL AND WE YOUR CAN. ON
THAT IMPORTANT ISSUE. THE NEXT
GOVERNMENT IS FROM LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN TO NUMBER THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
GOOD MORNING IN A- DOCTOR ARE.
DROP SPRINGS TO CHANGE AND
THERAPY NOW THE OF THE ANIMAL
REHABILITATION TASK I SPEAKING
REPRESENTS EVERYONE CHASE ISSUE
WHICH IS ADDRESS THE ROOT. ON
PAGE. THIRTY THIRTY. PURPORTED
TO COMPLETE THE SEARCH SERVER
NOW POLITICAL PURPOSES FORCE IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE FUNDING
RECKONING DAY OF THE FOR YOUR
LIPS BY WHY THAT BOARDS NOT
FINING AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE TASK FORCE. THERE SHOULD BE
COMMITTEE. FOR MAKING HAVE
FORTY OF THE WORK APPEARED TO
BE GOING CONGRESS AND THE PUT
FOLKS. AND STAKEHOLDER GOT WILL
HIM IT RECEIVED THAT FORTY.
AFTER. REPRESENTED BY PATRIOTS
HAVE FORCE HAS THREE ALL NEED.
POLITICAL THE VERY STAKEHOLDER.
ON THE TRANSPORT. TASK FORCE
FOR IT'S GOING TO CONNECTIONS
TO THE MEDICAL IN THESE WORKING.
PROFESSIONAL PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDERS. THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE TASK
FORCE THAT THEY DIDN'T FIND
ADDED TO SUPPORT. THE OVERSIGHT
ROLE OF THIS COMMITTEE CAN
POLICE AT THE OF THAT FOR.
THERE'S AN OLD WOMAN FOR
SPECIAL IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
REQUIRE. WORKING SHIFT TO HELP
SUPPORT WITH PROVIDE. EFFECTS
SHE AND EFFICIENT FOR. WITHOUT
OVERBURDENING GREG TO WORK WITH.
IT IS NOT IT'S OTHER JURORS TO.
UNANSWERED LEGAL REGULAR.
LIMITS THAT THE CPI BETWEEN
PAIR IN THE CORNER USE THE
PROFESSIONALS MAKING OR CON
WITHIN THEIR NARRATIVE. SO
INCREASE THE COST FOR OWNERS
THE FOURTEENTH THE PASSION
YEARS EVENING EVERYBODY HAS
BEEN ABLE TO THIRTY. THERE'S
ALWAYS A- HISTORICALLY THEY
COULD NOT STEP IN. WORDS THAT
CHANGE HANDS AND MAKES A STAR
HAVE BOTH SAID. THE NEXT COMEDY
IS FROM THE LINE NUMBER FORTY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LOW
CHAIRMAN ROBIN MEMBERS I AM
CRISTINA TO KARL LOBBYIST FOR
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION CDMA
SUPPORTS THE CONTINUATION OF
THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD IN
STATUTES. AS WE'VE INDICATED IN
OUR LETTER CDMA IS CONCERNED
ABOUT SEVERAL SUBSTANTIAL FEE
INCREASES INCLUDING THOSE THAT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTING A REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIANS AND OUR
GRADUATING STUDENTS WELL SEE
THEM HE WANTS THE BOARD TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND HAVE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO SUCCEED.
WE ALSO WANT TO SEE A POT FULL
SPENDING PLAN AND AN END TO
THESE INCREASES FOR THE TIME
BEING. ALSO CDMA IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO ANY ATTEMPT TO MAKE
THE TELEMEDICINE WAIVER
PERMANENT WHICH WOULD CREATE AN
UNSAFE NEW STANDARD WHEREBY
VETERINARIANS WOULD BE EXPECTED
TO MAKE A VIDEO DIAGNOSIS FOR
NEW CLINICAL CONDITIONS. IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO ANIMAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY THAT FOR NEW CONDITIONS
THE ANIMAL BE SEEN IN PERSON
AND FINALLY WE WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK AND FOR INCLUDING
ITEM NINETEEN. PERTAINING TO
THE NEED FOR GREATER
COLLABORATION AND COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE BMB AND THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY ON ISSUES RELATED
TO VETERINARY MEDICINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THE NEXT COMMENT
IS FROM LINE NUMBER. TWENTY
FIVE. CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MELANIE I RUN AN ANIMAL
SHELTER IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA AND I SIT ON THE BOARD
OF THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION. ARE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SHELTERS ARE RUN BY DEDICATED
ANIMAL WELFARE PROFESSIONALS
UTILIZED MINIMAL RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS MAJOR ISSUES INCLUDING
KEEPING ANIMALS SAFE AND
PRACTICING HER HELP KNOWING WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO OUR
COMMUNITY TO KEEP THEIR PETS
THANKS. TO THE JOB THAT THERE
IS NO OVERSIGHT OF ANIMAL
SHELTERS IN CALIFORNIA IS
TOTALLY INCORRECT BE A
CALIFORNIA STATUTE NOT ONLY-
REQUIRING THAT SHELTERS EXCEPT
THAT ALSO OVERSEEING THE CARE
IN MANAGEMENT WITHIN THEIR
SHELTERS. WE ARE NOT RIGHT THAT
COULD BECOME QUARTERS UC DAVIS
PROVIDE EXPERT ADVICE TO
SHELTER THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES ON BASIC CARE ANIMAL
SHELTER AND YET THEY WERE NOT
INVOLVED IN THE ANIMAL SHELTER
AND CROSS. RIGHT CONTINUING TO
MOVE THESE REGULATIONS I WORK
WITH THE EXPERTS HAND TIED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ONLY IT'S NOT
ALLOWING FOR COLLABORATION AND
FORWARD MOVEMENT THAT BENEFIT
THE STATE ANIMAL IN FACT COUNTY
ANIMALS MAY SEEM DESPERATE
MARKET BUYER. REGARDING THIS
ISSUE AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THROUGHOUT THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS WE PROVIDE A COMMENT
WHEN A LOUDAND VULGAR COMMENTS
WERE DISREGARDED THE DMB IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS A SINGLE
ISSUE WITHOUT CONSIDERING ALL
ASPECTS OF THE DECISION IF
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO ALLOCATE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO ALLOW.
ME CALIFORNIA CODE REQUIRED IN
THE AND THE REGULATIONS GREAT
WE'LL CALL OUR OBJECTION BUT
WITHOUT THAT WE NEED TO BE
COLLABORATIVE TO ADDRESS ISSUES
I BELIEVE THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF POSSIBILITIES WHEN THE BNP
AND STAKEHOLDERS WORK TOGETHER
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS. PLEASE CALL
THESE REGULATIONS ENACTED BMB
TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH UC DAVIS
SHELTER MEDICINE TEAM HOW
ANIMALS AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE. A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
THANK YOU. THANKS KEVIN REPLY
NINETEEN. MY NAME IS JOE PARKER
AND I'M NOT OF THE ANIMAL WELL
IF RECORD THE K. ANIMALS
BROWDER'S. WE RESPECT REQUEST
THAT THE MATT BOARD THE SHELTER
RIGHT AND ALLOW FOR MORE STATE
CALL AND BY TO CREATE A THAT
WILL TO THE BACK CARE KERR OF
SHELTER PETS IN ALIGNMENT WITH
RESOURCES. WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE FORTY BIG PERIOD IF
IT'S A TO ADDRESS THE MAGNITUDE
OF CHANGE THAT NEED TO BE MADE
CREATE REGULATIONS THAT MAKE
SENSE FOR SHELTERS THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM IS THAT THESE
REGULATIONS REQUIRE SHELTERS TO
ATTAIN A VETERINARY PROMISED
PERMIT TO CARRY OUT THEIR
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT MANDATED
DUTIES AND PROVIDE EVEN THE
MOST BASIC CARE AND 25% OF
SHELTER FACILITIES IN OUR STATE
ARE SIMPLY UNABLE TO OBTAIN
ONE. WITHOUT A PERMANENT THE
VMB CONTENDS THAT SHELTERS ARE
BREAKING THE LAW SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TRAIN STAFF TO
ADMINISTER THE VACCINES AND
FLEA TREATMENTS AVAILABLE TO
THE AVERAGE CITIZEN OVER THE
COUNTER ANY FEED STORE THEIR
STATING THAT ACCORDING TO THE
NEW REGULATIONS THIS CAN BE
DONE ACCORDING TO VETERINARY
PROTOCOLS BY SHELTER STAFF BUT
WHAT THEY'RE NOT MAKING CLEAR
THAT THAT THIS DEPENDS UPON A
VETERINARIAN TO PUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE. TO OBTAIN A PERMIT
PERMIT FOR THE SHELTER TO BEGIN
WITH THE SHELTERS CANNOT FIND A
VETERINARIAN TO DO THIS THEIR
LACK OF THE ABILITY TO
EUTHANIZE ANIMALS BUT NOT
VACCINATE. THEM TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF DISEASE. THE
REGULATIONS AS PRESENTED WILL
BE CHOI DEVON. IF TO A BETTER
OF. FOR EVEN THE MOST BASIC
CARE KEITH BECAUSE- OF. HUNT OF
NO OF THE- IN ORDER TO THE
STATE IT'S- REQUIREMENTS. AND
UPWARDS OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR TO EMPLOY VETERINARIAN
ASSUMING THEY'RE EVEN ABLE TO
FIND THEM. THESE REQUIREMENTS
CONSTITUTE SIGNIFICANT UNFUNDED
MANDATES ON LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES. FINDING A
SOLUTION TO THIS MATTER IS
IMPERATIVE AND ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF THE ANIMALS AND PEOPLE WE
SERVE. WE ASK THAT YOU HOLD THE
BOARD ACCOUNTABLE TO WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
MATTER TO MAKE SOME. CHANGES
NEEDED TO ENSURE THE ANIMAL
SHELTERS STATEWIDE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COMPLY. THANKS SO
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THE NEXT IS FOR LINE FOR EIGHT
LINE OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS DR
AT THE AND I BEEN IN CALIFORNIA
LICENSE NERI. SENIOR I'M ALL
THE NUMBER OF THE CAR THAT
MEDICAL THIRTY. AND I AM
CALLING INTO THE PATH TO BMD
EIGHT ONE FIVE FIVE. ON ANIMAL
REHABILITATION AND THE
VETERINARIAN AND ANIMAL OWNER
MYSELF I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
OPTION FOR PHYSICAL THERAPY IN
MANY PARTS OF CALIFORNIA ARE
VERY LIMITED. I DROVE OVER A
HUNDRED MILES ONE WAY TO TAKE
MY OWN DOG TO RECEIVE PHYSICAL
THERAPY FROM AN EXCELLENT AND
VERY FIELD PHYSICAL THERAPIST.
THE THERE. ARE NOT ONLY WELL.
AND ALL OF BUT THEY OPERA HELLO.
OUTSIDE OF FROM. IN FIELD THAT
NOTE THAT NAY THANK NOTES. WITH
THAT MIGHT I WOULD TRAINED IN
AT ALL YEAH PHYSICAL THERAPY
AND I'VE BEEN ABLE TO CALL.
WITH HAVE PROVIDED EXPERTISE
AND- FAR BEYOND WHAT NO
VETERINARIANS ARE TRYING TO DO.
I BELIEVE THE VETERINARIAN AND
THEN- OWNER CAN BE GIVEN SOME
TWENTY AS TO WHAT LEVEL OF.
THAT IT CAN. GIVE ANIMALS AND
OWNERS MOST. AND BETTER TO CARE.
VETERINARIAN HAVE A CHOI TO
WHAT LED OF. THEY LIKE. TO FOR.
WE ALLOW SINCE THERAPY TO WORK
ON HUMAN WITH NO AND PRESIDENT.
SO TO LIMIT AND EVEN MORE ON
THE CARE AND ESPECIALLY IF THEY
ARE FOR. IN AND UP. LIFE
ANIMALS WELFARE PLAN SEEMS TO
ME THAT IT WOULD PROVIDE BETTER.
FOR THE THAT ARE CONSIDERED
LIKE THE FROM PEOPLE. OWNERS
VETERINARIANS ONE THESE ARE.
THERE WERE REQUIRE. TO SOMEONE
PHYSICAL THERAPY WILL ENSURE
PROP PIECE SELECTION AND- FOR
THE- WHILE WORKING WITH PEOPLE
THERAPIST I THOUGHT ANYTHING.
FLIGHT PUT IN DANGER. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEES INCLUDE A RESOLUTION
IN THE DMV SUNSET BILL AB ONE
FIVE THREE FIVE. THAT WILL
INCLUDE QUALIFIED INAPPROPRIATE
LIKE ANIMAL PHYSICAL THERAPY AS
LAWFUL PROVIDERS THE PANEL
RECAP SERVICES. ALLOW THEM TO
WORK UNDER THE DIRECT OR
INDIRECT SUPERVISION OF A
VETERINARIAN AND ANIMAL
PHYSICAL REHABILITATION
PREGNANT THAT IS REGISTERED
WITH THE BOARD. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. CONSIDERATION ON THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER. THE NEXT CAR
FROM LINE NUMBER SO. HELLO MY
NAME IS SCHUMER RPG. I ONE OF
THE ONLY OF AN INDEPENDENT FIVE
DR VETERINARY PRACTICE SERVING
MENLO PARK ATHERTON AND REDWOOD
CITY WHAT FORTY EMPLOYEE. I WAS
THE LAST OF THE BMPS RBT. WHEN
IT WAS DISSOLVED IN TWENTY
ELEVEN WHICH LEGISLATION THAT
ADDED THE ONE AND ONLY RPG TO
THE PORT. I TESTIFY AT THE
LASSEN SAID HEARING ABOUT THIS
SEVERE SHORTCOMINGS AT THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD
REGARDING RPG REGULATIONS AND
ENFORCEMENT SINCE THE OR BTC
WAS DISARMED. I AM PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT THERE'S BEEN GOOD
RESPONSE FROM THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD TO YOUR MANDATE
THAT THEY FULFILL THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO REGULATE
RPG MATTERS. THE NEW EXECUTIVE
OFFICER HAS BEEN OUTSTANDING
AND HELPING THE BOARD ACHIEVE
THESE GOALS. THE ARMY KEEP
FACES MANY CHALLENGES STILL. AS
THE PMI PANDEMIC AS INCREASED
ADOPTIONS THANKFULLY REDUCING
SHELTER POPULATION IT HAS
INCREASED THE BURDENS ON
HOSPITALS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC WITH CONSISTENT HIGH
QUALITY CARE. RPGS ARE CRITICAL
TO ACHIEVING THAT. THE US LABOR
STATISTICS HAVE PROJECTED 20%
GROWTH OF RPGS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THE PANDEMIC HAS
REVEALED MANY STRESSES THAT
MAKE FINDING AND RETAINING RPG
WAS VERY DIFFICULT IN
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE SEEN FIRST
HAND HOW THE REGULATIONS AND
LEGISLATION AROUND RPG'S
ATTACKS THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION AND TRAINING ON THE
VETERINARY STAFF ON THE
FRONTEND. AND BURNED OUT AND
CAREER CHANGE ON THE BACK AND.
EXCESSIVE FEES AND THE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIERRA. JUNGLE
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM LINE
THIRTY FIVE. CARILLO AND CHAIR
ROSS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LEE HELLER
I'M A LONGTIME ANIMAL WELFARE
ADVOCATE I'M ALSO A FORMER
PUBLIC MEMBER OF THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD AND I SERVED ON
THE ANIMAL REHABILITATION TASK
FORCE. AND I WANT TO ECHO WHAT
SEVERAL PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AND
SAID ABOUT THE FAILURE OF THE
SUNSET REVIEW DOCUMENTS. TO
PROPERLY COVER WHAT HAPPENED
REGARDING THAT ISSUE WHICH IS
THAT DOCTOR NOUNI AS AN ONLINE
SERVED ON THAT BOARD- AND THAT
THAT TASK FORCE. ENDORSED
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE THEN
INCLUDED IN LEGISLATION BUT
WHEN IT WENT TO THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD ONLY DOCTOR KNOWN
AS AN ONLINE VOTED IN FAVOR OF
THE TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS
THE REST OF THE BOARD REJECTED
THOSE TASK FORCE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND CONTINUE TO
PURSUE A REGULATORY APPROACH.
DOES NOT REFLECT BEST PRACTICES
FOR ENSURING THAT ANIMALS GET
PROPER PHYSICAL THERAPY OPTIONS
IN CALIFORNIA SO I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL LISTEN TO WHAT THESE
OTHER CALLERS CAN SAID ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE TASK FORCE AND
LOOK FOR A LEGISLATIVE REMEDY
SINCE THE VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD SEEMS UNABLE TO LISTEN TO
THE LEGISLATURE OR TASK FORCE.
I'M ALSO A LONGTIME ANIMAL
WELFARE ACTIVISTS ON SHELTER
MEDICINE ISSUES AND I WANT TO
ECHO WHAT JILL PARKER AND
OTHERS ABSTAINED AND ASK YOU TO
INSIST THAT THE BOARD GO BACK
TO GENUINE STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENED SO FAR
DOES NOT REFLECT WHAT IS NEEDED
FOR SHELTERS. TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLY THANK YOU. THE NEXT COME
IS FROM THREE SIX. HI MORNING
MY NAME IS HILARY CONAN CAN I
HAVE BEEN A PRACTICING
VETERINARIAN AND MEMBER OF THE
CDMA PURPORTING YOURS I'M ALSO
AN ACUPUNCTURIST IN PRACTICE
INTEGRATIVE VETERINARY MEDICINE
SO EIGHTEEN MANY ANIMALS EACH
WEEK WITH MOBILITY CONCERNS AND
OR ORTHOPEDIC PAIN. I FEEL VERY
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO REFER
TO A PHYSICAL THERAPIST IN MY
AREA. I KNOW IT'S HIGHLY
SKILLED AND EXTREMELY CAUTIOUS
IN ENSURING SHE IS TREATING MY
ANIMAL PATIENTS APPROPRIATELY
AND IN LINE WITH MY DIAGNOSIS
IN ORDER. SHE DID NOT REQUIRE
MY DIRECT SUPERVISION OR WITH
MY PATIENTS BENEFIT FROM HER
BEING DIRECTLY SUPERVISED BY
MYSELF. OR ANY OTHER
VETERINARIAN THAT WOULD NOT
SIMPLY TRAINED AND WE HAVE. I
AM PROUD TO BE A THAT. BUT I
WORRY THAT THE PUBLIC GENERAL
RESPECT IN HIGH REGARD FOR OUR
PROFESSION IS AT RISK IF THEY
PERCEIVE THAT WE ARE LIMITING
THEIR OPTIONS FOR QUALIFIED
CARE. MY NUMBER OF THE CDMA
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
DISAPPOINTED BY THEIR HANDLING
OF THIS ISSUE. HAS BEEN
MISLEADING INFORMATION SENT OUT
TO MEMBERS AND THERE SEEMS TO
BE A GENERAL UNWILLINGNESS TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY PROFESSION. AND EMBRACE
A MORE UNIFIED APPROACH TO
ANIMAL HEALTH CARE. I HAVE
EIGHT I SHOULD SAY I HAVE MANY
COLLEAGUES NEAR AND FAR. IT
FEELS SIMILAR TO THE WAY I DO.
IT BUT FOR WHATEVER REASON ARE
UNABLE TO BE HERE TODAY. WE
BELIEVE THE CONSERVATIVE THINK
TANK PROPERLY QUALIFIED ANIMAL
PHYSICAL THERAPY SHOULD BE
DIRECTLY SUPERVISED BY THAT.
EVEN KNOWS ABOUT THAT HAVE A
SPECIAL INTEREST IN REHAB DID
NOT POSSESS THE KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS THAT EXTENSIVE TRAINING.
AND YEARS OF HIGH LEVEL
PRACTICE BRING TO A LICENSED
PHYSICAL THERAPIST. ONE MORE
BRIEF POINT I'D LIKE TO MAKE.
I'VE HEARD SOME PEOPLE ARGUE
THAT WE CANNOT APPLY THE SAME
HUMAN MODEL TO ANIMALS BECAUSE-
ANIMALS CAN'T VERBALIZE THEIR
PAIN THIS IS ABSOLUTELY NOT
TRUE. THE QUALIFIED ANIMAL
PHYSICAL THERAPIST I HAVE
ENCOUNTERED ARE EXTREMELY
SKILLED IN PICKING UP ON THE
SAME CLUES THAT ARE NEARING
VIEWS TO INTERPRET DISCOMFORT
IN AN ANIMAL. ANIMAL
COMMUNICATION BEHAVIOR AND
IDENTIFICATION OF PAIN ARE ALL
INCLUDED IN THE CREEK EDUCATION
PROGRAM FOR QUALIFIED ANIMAL
PHYSICAL THERAPY AT. MAYBE EVEN
MORE SO THAN IN. A TYPICAL DVM
CURRICULUM. I ECHO. THE COMMENT.
MANY OTHERS SPEAK. INCLUDING DR
MARTIN GREENBERG. I
RESPECTFULLY. TO BE A- AND
SENATE JOINT COMMITTEE. A
RESOLUTION BE IN THE SUNSET
BILL. THAT WOULD INCLUDE
QUALIFIED LICENSED ANIMAL
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AND LOCAL
PROVIDERS OF ANIMAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND ALLOW THEM. OKAY
THE NEXT TIME IT IS APPLYING
FORTY ONE. GOOD MORNING LOW
ROCK. I'M KEVIN AND I'M
PRESSING ISSUE SIXTEEN AND ARE
TURNING ISN'T PREVIOUS COMMENTS
WHICH HIGHLIGHT A REALLY
DANGEROUS SITUATION TRAMMELL
ONE IT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
WELL MEANING RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS DISPENSARY STAFF IN
CANNABIS ADVERTISING MAY WELL
BE THE ONLY THING GUIDING TED
OWNERS. AND REALLY THE ONLY
PEOPLE ABLE TO PROPERLY
DIAGNOSE AND RECOMMEND
ARCHITECTURE AREA. AN EXAMPLE
OF MY OWN CAT SORRY- CONDITIONS
CAN'T AND COULD EASILY BE
MISDIAGNOSED. YOUR RECREATION
USE THAT FOR ANIMAL AND CANADA
BASEMENT. IF IT IS MEDICINE AND
I BELIEVE IT IS. SHOULD ONLY BE
AVAILABLE WITH THE
VETERINARIAN'S RECOMMENDATION
AND SHOULD ONLY BE AVAILABLE IN
THE MEDICAL CANNABIS DISPENSARY
WITHOUT GETTING THE WHITE WE'RE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO PUT
THE TOOTHPASTE BACK IN THE
TUBE. AND ACTIVELY GOING TO
OPEN THE FLOODGATES HE GERRY
SPARKLE IN DANGEROUS PRODUCT
WITH NO SKILLED MEDICAL
OVERSIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE ABILITY. TO COMMENT AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. THE
NEXT COMMENT IS FROM THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY. HI GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN LOW AND CHAIRMAN ROTH
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES
MY NAME IS STEVEN RAGS AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE ASPCA- ASPCA
HARD TO ADD- ONE OF THE TOP
HERE POLITICAL KEEPING. PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND ONE OF THE WAYS
DOWN- WE TRIED TO DO THAT IS
INSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS AND
HOUSEHOLDS THAT HAVE COMPANION
ANIMALS HAVE ACCESS TO
VETERINARY CARE. THE REALITY IS
IN CALIFORNIA IN ADDITION
JUPITER- THAT MERRY MEDICINE IN
RURAL AREAS AND MANY OF OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES FOLKS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT HERE IN
MADISON- COULD COMPLETE DESERT
SQUARE FOLKS HAVE YOU- DRIVE
LONG DISTANCES OR IN MANY CASES
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE VEHICLE.
ACCESS TRANSIT AND OFTENTIMES
GREENS THAT DOES NOT ALLOW.
ANIMALS ON- VEHICLE SO- WE
BELIEVE THAT- YOU THE BOARD
REALLY NEED TO EXPLORE OPTIONS
FOR ACCESS TO THAT CARE THEY'VE
ALREADY INITIATED DEATH IN PART
BY I'M LOOKING AT THE TEMPORARY
WAIVERS FOR TELEMEDICINE AND WE
APPLAUD THEM FOR PASSING THOSE
AND- HOPE THAT WE CAN MAKE
THOSE PERMANENTLY THINK THAT
THAT IS ONE STEP. IN CREATING A
MORE ACCESS TO THAT NEW CHAIR
WE DON'T THINK THAT- BEING LOW
INCOME MEANS THAT YOU YOU BOB
YOUR COMPANION ANIMAL ANY LOOK
ANY LESS THAN SOMEONE WITH MORE
MEANS AND PEOPLE WANT TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR ANIMALS- BUT
OFTEN TIMES JUST DON'T HAVE. ON
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO TO HELP-
SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE- AT THE
BOARD TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
WAYS TO CREATE MORE ACCESS AND-
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THE NEXT COMMENT
IS FROM MY FORTY SEVEN. OUR.
FIVE FORTY SO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE NEW COMEDIES FROM LINE NOT.
THIRTY YOUR. NINE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY OR
COMMENTS. THERE ARE I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THAT THAT I WASN'T MISSING
SOMETHING OKAY WILL RELEASE
NINE THIRTY EIGHT AND I'M GOING
OPEN LINE FORTY TWO LINE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS KELLY VOICE AND
I AM A CALIFORNIA LICENSED
PHYSICAL THERAPIST A CERTIFIED
EQUINE REHABILITATION
THERAPISTS. AND I AM ALSO A
REGISTERED VETERINARY
TECHNICIAN. I HAVE A HISTORY OF
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN THE
VETERINARY FIELD TWENTY FIVE IN
HUMAN REHABILITATION AND TWELVE
IN THE COMBINED WORLD. THE
CURRICULUM TO OBTAIN A DEGREE
IN PHYSICAL THERAPY IS HEAVILY
BASED ON MUSCULOSKELETAL
ANATOMY AND PHYSIOLOGY. AND
INCLUDES EXTENSIVE EDUCATION ON
CRITICAL THINKING ATTACKING
PAIN INVERTIBLE AND NONVERBAL
PATIENT. MANUAL PALPATION AND
AFFECTING THE JOINT MOBILITY
AND NOT THE LINK MENTION IN
VERBAL AND NONVERBAL. PATIENT
AND USING CRITICAL THINKING
SKILLS TO FORMULATE A TREATMENT
PLAN BASED ON THE OUTCOME OF
THE ASSESSMENT. THE CURRICULUM
FOR AN RPG CAMPAIGNS AND NONE
OF THAT. THERE ARE OTHER ARGUED
HE'S ACTIVE IN THIS ISSUE WHO
CONTEND THAT TEACHERS SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO WORK UNDER DIRECT
SUPERVISION. OTHER
VETERINARIANS. AT ALL TIMES
TRYING TO JUSTIFY THE QUALIFIED
WHAT HE'S LACK THE KNOWLEDGE TO
RECOGNIZE PAIN IN ANIMALS AND
DO NOT HAVE THE IDEAL ABILITY
TO IDENTIFY RED FLAGS THAT
WOULD NECESSITATE. THE ANIMAL
BEING SEEN BY A VETERINARIAN.
BEING PASSED BOTH A PT AND R.
D. T. I CAN STATUS JUST. FALSE
THE RACE. COURSEWORK OVER TO GO
STANDARD AND I THINK. CURRENTLY
FOR. RE HAD ANY U. S. OR T. T.
ALREADY IN. PAYING RECOGNIZE
AND RED FLAG I CAN THINK. TO
ENSURE SAFETY OF THE ANIMAL
PATIENTS I FEAR THAT SOME R. B.
T. AT THE STATIONS AN
INDIVIDUAL. ARE YOU GOING TO
FOLLOW AMERICANS FOR THE SAKE
OF COMPACT OKAY FROM. TURN
RATHER THAN BEING MINDFUL OF
THE GREATER GOOD THAT WOULD
COME FROM UNIFYING ARE HERE. SO
MORE ANIMALS GET THE CARE THEY
NEED. I ECHO THE MANY COMMENTS
BEFORE ME REQUESTING THAT THE
JOINT MANY ISSUES THERE ARE
STORED AND THIS. EXTENSION BILL
AND INCLUDE RESOLUTION LANGUAGE
WEEKS THE STATE. HAVE FORCE
LANGUAGE AT IT RELATES TO. P.
WORK ON ANIMAL I WANTED. TO
NEARLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND KEEP. IN THIS MATTER. FOR
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM THE
LINE FORTY FOR. HELLO MY NAME
IS A NEW MONEY HIS- A
REGISTERED VETERINARY
TECHNICIAN IN CALIFORNIA AND
I'M ON OF THE CAL. REGISTERED
TECHNICIAN FOR- I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO ARE CONTINUED WITH THE-
CAL SHE AND SHE WAS STARTING TO
THINK ABOUT THE EIGHT PROGRAM.
WE DEFINITELY WANTED TO ASK
THAT YOU WOULD READ BUT
PROBABLY AS IT HAS NOW BROUGHT
IN. THE REVENUE THAT PENSIONS.
AND COULD CARVING MORE STAFF-
STOCKTON EFFORT AND THEY HAD-
WE ORIGINALLY HAD A- ALLOWING
ON MY PERSON TO OBTAIN. AND
CONTROLLED DRUG- GIVING AND WE
DON'T. THE STOCK BANNED BY THAT
THAT STATEMENT- WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PUT SECOND PARTY T.
ON THE YOUR MEDIC BOARD- I WE
LOOK AT THE RATIO OF RECKLESS.
OF HOW ONLY ONE RPG THE BOARD-
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABOUT- 30%
OF THE BUT ON THE BORDER FOR
THE ONLY ABOUT 20% SO ADDING
THAT SECOND RDG WOULD. HELP TO
THAT REPRESENT RATIO ISSUE. AND
THEN FINALLY- NO AFTER THAT I
WANT TO ASK IS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE ASK THE MUCH MCCARTNEY
BADGES FOR ALL THE YEAR HAVE
WITH A COUPLE SIMILAR TO.
YOU'RE IN YOU ARE NOT A FOR
THAT QUIET SHE AND I DON'T WHO
ARE SPEAKING TO AND WHAT THEY
HAVE. A WE DON'T HAVE- THAT THE
PUBLIC IS NOT LARGELY AWAY OF
THE DEATH BETWEEN NEXT IN THE
ARMY. ALL MENTAL HEALTH TO
AVOID ME. FIRST OF KNOWLEDGE OR
COMPETENCE WHEN THEY ARE IN
STAFF THE HOT ACTUALLY NOW
DURING COULD BE TIME WE ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE PEOPLE IN THE
BUILDING- IT WOULD BE VERY HELP
AND I THAT. I ALSO WANTED TO
ADD THAT I DO MUCH BE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO. ON THE- IN AS
ALWAYS THE BATTERY BOARD.
EXTENDED THAT OPPORTUNITY AS
WELL IT IS MUCH. THANK OU. FOR
THAT COMMENT IS FROM THE LINE.
THIRTEEN HELLO MY NAME IS
CALLED BURKE- LONG TIME CANADA
ADVOCATE AND I'M INTO. THE
ELEPHANT BACKGROUND PAPER ISSUE
NUMBERS- APPARENTLY THIS IS
GOING TO BE COMING TO THE BOARD
AGAIN. WITH NEW RELIGIOUS WILL
IN. WITH AB. THREE EIGHTY FIVE-
AB THREE EIGHTY FOUR CHAIN THE
VET MEDICAL PRACTICE ACT TO DO
DISP ARE FOR. CANNABIS ITCHY
THE DEATH OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS
CONCENTRATED AT ALL PRODUCTS
UNDER NOT PERSON TO INCLUDE
PRODUCTS INTENDED TO BE USED
FOR ANIMAL CONSUMPTION. THAT'S
IT- ALEXANDER WAS ADVOCATE I
JUST IT SEEMS ODD FOR ME TO BE
REQUESTING MORE RESTRICTIONS
BUT FOR THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE ANIMALS I THINK IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT THIS SAID- AND- I. REQUEST
SOME AMENDMENTS. THE THE
ABILITY TO RECOMMEND NEEDS TO
BE AUTHORIZED BY MARK PERSON.
NOT JUST A CHANGE IN THE-
VETERINARY PRACTICES ACT.
DELEGITIMIZE THE RECOMMENDATION.
VETERINARIANS DESPERATELY WANT
AND NEED THE ABILITY AND THE
AUTHORITY TO RECOMMEND- FOR
ANIMALS CANNABIS IS MEDICINE
PENSION REQUIRE A
VETERINARIAN'S RECOMMENDATION-
A MANUFACTURER'S ADVERTISING OR
RETAIL SALES PERSON VICE.
CANNABIS IS NOT A PANACEA AND A
VETERAN VETERINARIAN IS THE
ONLY PERSON THAT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DIAGNOSE AND RECOMMEND THE
TREATMENT OF ANY TIME- THIS
BILL ALSO SOUNDS LIKE IT'S
PROMOTING CANNABIS AT ADULT IN
15210% OF AN ANIMAL FOOD. THERE
IS NO MENTION OF REFORMISTS
ANIMALS AND HOW THEY SHOULD BE
TREATED ALLOWING PERFORMANCE
ORGANIZATIONS. TO ESTABLISH
THEIR OWN CRITERIA. RESEARCH IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED THERE IS NO
MENTION OF DESIGNATING ANIMALS
AS PATIENTS CONSEQUENTLY
ELIGIBLE FOR PORTION OF THE
MUCH NEEDED MEDICAL RESEARCH
MONIES THAT ARE STATUTORILY
ALLOWED IN PROVIDENCE SIXTY
FOUR. THEY PUT A CAMERA AT THE
END THING THAT THE REGULATORY
AGENCY IS FREE TO DO WHAT THEY
LIKE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AUTHORITIES LEGAL TEAM- THEIR
VENDORS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE YOU'RE TWO MINUTES IS UP.
THE NEW MEXICO IT IS FROM LINE
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING- ONE
OF THE CHAIR- CHAIRS LOW AND
BROUGHT IN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEES HI MY NAME IS G. THE
ERRORS AND I REPRESENT THE
ANIMAL PHYSICAL THERAPY
COALITION. THE EQUITY IF THE
COALITION- REPRESENTING
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
VETERINARIANS RPGS AND
CONSUMERS AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING TO ESTABLISH
COMMONSENSE ANIMAL TO SCHOOL
CRAPPIE POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA
FOR NUMBER OF YEARS. A GREAT
HOPE OF THE COMMITTEES FOR THE
SUNSET REVIEW HEARING ABOUT HER
MEDICAL BOARD AND WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR ROTH ASKING THEM ABOUT
THIS ISSUE MAYBE IDENTIFY
OURSELVES WITH- CARLA BINS
STATEMENTS BEFORE. AND THE
NUMBER OF- THE NUMBER OF. RIGHT
NOW. AND AS SOON. AND- OUR AND
THOSE LOVE TO ON THIS ISSUE
ALREADY ARE PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN ISSUE NUMBER
FIFTEEN RELATING TO ANIMAL
PHYSICAL REHABILITATION. OR
PHYSICAL THERAPY THE ISSUE OF
ANIMAL PHYSICAL REHABILITATION
NEEDS A LEGISLATIVE FIX. HIM BY
PROBLEM BOB PROMULGATING ITS
REGULATIONS THE CURRENT
REGULATION IS PROPOSING THE
BORDERS ATTEMPTING TO
ESTABLISHING UNIQUE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE. SOLELY FOR
VETERINARIANS THAT IS NOT
SPECIFICALLY DESCRIBED OR
DEFINED UNDER THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL PRACTICE ACT.
FURTHERMORE THE BOARD
REGULATION DOES NOT RECOGNIZE
LICENSED PHYSICAL THERAPIST
WITH ADVANCED EDUCATION AND
TRAINING CRISCO AND ANIMAL
PHYSICAL THERAPY. EVERY
INVOLVED INCLUDING THE BOARD
AGREED THAT TO RECOGNIZE
QUALIFY QUALIFIED LICENSED
PHYSICAL THERAPIST WITH
ADVANCED TRAINING ON ANIMALS
REQUIRES LEGISLATION. SO WE- TO
THE COMMITTEES TO INCLUDE A
LEGISLATIVE FIX TO ALLOW
QUALIFIED PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
TO PRACTICE ON ANIMALS
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A CRISIS FOR
MORE DISCUSSION AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH YOU ON
A COOPERATIVE SOLUTION ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WHAT THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
THE LINE TWENTY EIGHT. HEY- MY
NAME IS FUELING SOCIAL IN THE
FROM NOT MISTAKEN I'M THE FIRST
OUR CONSUMER OF ANIMAL PHYSICAL
THERAPY SERVICES. TO CALL AND-
AT FIRST WHEN I JUST SAY IN
ORDER TO NOT REPEAT ANYTHING- I
HAVE TO THOROUGHLY AGREE WITH
WHAT DR HILARY CONDIT DR
GREENBERG THE HELLER
CALIBRATION MR ERRORS JUST NOW
SAID- I AM I FEEL UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED TO WEIGH AND I'VE HAD
FOUR DOGS OVER SIXTEEN YEARS
THAT HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
PHYSICAL THERAPY SERVICES THAT-
DISABILITIES AROUND CALIFORNIA-
I THINK THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE.
SOME MISREPRESENTATION OF OUR
WHAT HAPPENS IS THERE IS AN OF
VETERINARIANS PRESENT TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN WITH ANIMALS AS A
SERVICES- MY ANIMAL PHYSICAL
THERAPIST WHO WORKS EVEN IF THE
THAT MARION IS NOT PRESENT THEY
WORK EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
VETERINARIAN DAY OBTAINED THE
RECORDS FROM THE ANIMAL HEAD OF
TIME THEY PROVIDE REGULAR
PROGRESS REPORTS. MY
VETERINARIAN OFTEN KNOWS JUST.
AS MUCH AS AS MUCH AS I DO
HAVING BEEN IN THE ROOM AFTER
SESSIONS WITH MY TAX- AT A
LITTLE- ANECDOTE I THINK ABOUT
HUMAN TO HAVE HIP SURGERY AND I
THINK ABOUT. IF IT BECAME
DIFFICULT OR UNAFFORDABLE FOR
THEM TO GO TO PHYSICAL THERAPY
AFTERWARDS I DON'T KNOW WHY
ANYBODY WOULD WANT TO INTERFERE
WITH HER INCREASE THE PRICE- OR
PUT UP BARRIERS TO PET OWNERS
GETTING. CARE FOR THEIR ANIMALS
THAT WILL IMPROVE THEIR QUALITY
OF LIFE AS LONG AS IT'S DONE IN
A RESPONSIBLE FASHION SO- I
AGREE WITH THE OTHER CALLERS
TIME I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST
RESOLUTION LANGUAGE AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE STAKEHOLDERS
TASK FORCE. BE INCLUDED IN AB
ONE FIVE THREE FIVE- AND I JUST
I REALLY ENCOURAGE THE BOARD TO
LISTEN TO WITH THE DEPTH OF
EXPERIENCE AND- THAT JUST WITH
THE MULTITUDE OF STORIES OUT
THERE AND IT MIGHT BE HARD FOR
A LOT OF CONSUMERS TO CALL IN
BECAUSE IT WAIT ON HOLD YOUR-
NOSE NOT YOUR FIRST PARTY. BUT
I TAKE IT FOR ME AND- AN EXPERT
CONSUMER AND- THERE'S REALLY IN
TO HAVE CUT ALLOW. HAVE ACT R.
P. TO CHECK GET THEIR PATHS
YEAH GET THE CARE THAT ISN'T.
THAT IS PART OF THE PICTURE OF
THEIR HEALTH WELLNESS IT
DOESN'T. A TO BE. FRONT AND
CENTER AND THEY THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. FOR THE
NEXT COMMENT IS FOR LINE TO
FOUR. GOOD MORNING NAME IS
BRANDY CANCEL UP THE SAMPLE AT
WHICH OPERATES BOTH THE NOW
SHELTER IN TWO LARGEST
HOSPITALS IN THIS. WITH TO
ISSUE FOUR SHELTER. WE ASK THAT
DMV WOULD DROP REGULATE AND CAN
TO WORK THE STEAK TO REACH A
BETTER. BUT THE FACT THAT I TO
ONE DATA WHICH SHALL MANY THE
AUTHORS ON THE ISSUE AT THAT
POINT IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER
ONLY QUESTION IN PARTICULAR.
THE I. O. W. USED INVOLVEMENT
IN THIS ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
TELEMEDICINE I WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT IT IS NOT OUR CONTENTION
AT THE SHELTER THAT
TELEMEDICINE IS CRITICAL BETTER
THAN NOTHING. RATHER WE THINK
THAT IS ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE IN
MANY CIRCUMSTANCES TO USE
TELEMEDICINE TO EXPAND IMPROVE
VETERINARY CARE IN OUR STATE
PARTICULARLY AMONG LOWER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS. I THOUGHT
COMMUNITY AND WORKING FAMILIES.
LIKE IN HUMAN MEDICINE WE TRUST.
PUT TO DETERMINE BY THE TELE.
IS A- AND WHAT IT IS NOT THE TO
OF LIKE SAMPLE THAT DR NEW
NETSCAPE EARLIER THAN INSTANCE
IN WHICH IT IS NOT WARRANTED.
BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
APPROPRIATE USES RADIOLOGY
PATHOLOGY PSYCHOLOGY CARDIOLOGY
BEHAVIOR ONCOLOGY AND END OF
LIFE HOSPICE CARE. AND WHILE IT
IS TRUE THAT ANIMAL CANNOT
COMMUNICATE NEITHER CAN YOUNG
HUMAN AND YET ONE MIGHT HUMAN
SON WAS AS YOUNG AS THREE
MONTHS OLD I WAS ABLE TO
CONTACT HIS POSITION VIA
TELEMEDICINE TO DETERMINE IF
CARE. THE NOTION THAT I CANNOT
DO THE SAME FOR MY CAT AND
INCONGRUOUS WITH THE GREAT
LEVEL OF TRUST THAT WE PLACE IN
OUR LIFE IS VERY. PROFESSIONAL
THAT OUR STATE THANK YOU. THE
COMMENT IS LINE FIFTY TWO. I
CAN MORNING MISTER CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR KAREN LAYING ON DOCTORS
CAL ANIMALS AND THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER DID A GREAT JOB ON
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN RELATIVE
TO THE REGULATION- AND ASKING
THAT THE COMMITTEE JOINED
TOGETHER REALLY PARKING SO THAT
NETWORK TO PULL BACK THE
REGULATIONS AND WE OPEN THEM AT
THE STAKEHOLDER LEVEL AND
ACTUALLY CORPORATION- COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY THE SHELTERS
THEY DID WRITE SOMETHING LIKE
SEVEN MOTHER EARTH I'M
THROUGHOUT THE NDC PROCESS.
IDENTIFYING THE ISSUE ABOUT
OVER THE COUNTER MEDICATION I
WANNA THAT'S NOT PRESENT AND IT
WAS NEVER DEALT WITH AND THIS
IS NOT A NEW ISSUE TO THE
EXTENT THAT REVIEW PROCESS
EITHER IT'S BEEN IN PREVIOUS
FUNDS THAT REPORTTHE THING
THAT IS NW NOW THOUGH IS THE
DRAFT REGULATIONS AND WHEN THEY
ARE ADOPTED AND IMPLEMENTED.
YOU ARE JUST YOU'RE JUST
PUTTING YOURSELF THERE'S A NOT
A REALLY TOUGH SPOT THERE ARE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE WITHOUT A
SINGLE VETERINARIAN PRACTICING
AND THEN ZERO LICENSEES THAT IF
THE PERFECTLY THE COUNTY OF
ALPINE BUT THEY ARE STILL
OBLIGATED TO DELIVER ANIMAL
CARE AND CONTROL OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
OPTION TO. GET A PRIVATE
CONNECT AND FURTHERMORE AS THE
COMMITTEE HEARD TODAY THAT
SHELTERS WITHOUT VETERINARIANS
CAN STILL GET THE PROTOCOLS FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE OVER
THE COUNTER MEDICATION THE-
THAT THE KEY THERE WHICH YOU
CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF IS THAT
THEY FIRST MUST HAVE A PROMISED
PERMITS TO GET THOSE PROTOCOLS
YOU CAN'T GET THE PROMISED
PERMITS UNTIL YOU HAVE A PLAN
F. WHICH MEANS BUILDING
ASSEMBLY AT LEAST A SMALL
VETERINARIAN OFFICE. AT THE
SHELTER THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE
DONE THAT THE SMALL EXERCISE TO
PUT FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT COST
ONE COUNTY ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND NOT IF THEY CAN GET
BETTER DURING THE COLD WORK AT
THEM THAT THEY CAN GET THE
PROTOCOLS FROM THE THAT NETWORK
FROM PARK I. AND THAT THE
ALLIES UNTIL THEY HAVE A PER
ABOUT PROTOCOL IN FOR YOU GOT
EARLY DOESN'T WORK AND COUNTY
TENS OF MILLION OF DOLLARS SO I
YOU TO PLEASE. PRACTICE THAT.
THE POLICY OF THE LEGISLATURE
10% THANK YOU. THE NEXT TIME IT
IS ON THE LINE FIFTY THREE.
THIS MORNING MY NAME IS DR
JENNY MILL I'M CALLING TO DRESS
THE CURRENT REGULATIONS
REGARDING ANIMAL
REHABILITATION. I'VE BEEN A
LICENSED PHYSICAL THERAPIST IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS
AND A CERTIFIED CANINE
REHABILITATION THERAPISTS FOR
OVER ELEVEN. I ALSO HOLD AN
ANIMAL CRITICAL THERAPY LICENSE
IN NEVADA AND I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE ANIMAL TO THE
GOT THERE PEACEABLE INTEREST
GROUP OF THE PTA. MY ROLE TODAY
IS NOT TELLING THE DIFFICULTIES
THAT I FACED WITH THE CURRENT
PROPOSED REGULATION TO PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS I ANIMAL REHAB. BUT
INSTEAD I'LL PROVIDE YOU WITH
SOME. PERSPECTIVE ON FROM
POLLUTION. THE PHYSICAL THERAPY
IN VETERINARY VOICE CAME
TOGETHER AND IT A GREEN CONCERT
AT THE- EXPERIENCE IN LIFE AND
REQUIRE. HE HE'S- ALL THE WORK
AND INDIRECT SUPERVISION WITH A
BETTER VERSE. SIMILAR OUR
PRACTICE AND HUMAN ANNA. STEP
MODEL IT PREVENT SUCCESSFUL AND
PREFERRED BY VETERINARY COMPETE
AWAY. I WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE
COMMUNITY THEME WITHIN A TEN
THAT AND PROVIDE CLUB CARE FOR
PATIENTS WITHOUT RISK. AND THIS
EXPENSES OF THE DIRECT Mà.
CALIFORNIA WOULD BENEFIT FROM
ADOPTING THIS MODEL ALLOW
APPROPRIATELY CERTIFIED
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS TO ADD
THEIR EXPERTISE AND CLINICAL
SKILLS TO THE FIELD OF ANIMAL
REHABILITATION. THE WEIGHTLESS
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
ARE NOW OVER TWO MONTHS LONG
TRIP CUT NEEDING BRAIN. EVEN
THOUGH WE MORE CLINICS THAT
MOST AREAS I HAPPENED TO BE IN
THE INCLUDE RESOLUTION LANGUAGE
TO REFLECT THE STAKEHOLDERS
TASK FORCE LANGUAGE. AS IT
RELATES TO QUALIFY PC'S WORKING
WITH ANIMAL TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE SENSE THAT EXTENSION BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THE NEXT COMMENT
IS FROM FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS DOCTOR LEE STEVENS AND
I'M A SUPERVISING VETERINARIAN
FIRST OUT HOW. IT'S A PLACE
THAT DOES TO THE GOAL
REHABILITATION ON ANIMALS AND
I'VE BEEN THERE FOR THIRTEEN
PLUS YEARS I THINK QUALIFY P.
T. SHOULD BE ABLE TO WORK ON
ANIMALS SO THAT THEY CAN WORK
UNDER INDIRECT SUPERVISION OF A
VETERINARIAN. THE PROCESS WAS
VERY FRUSTRATING WHEN I WENT
BEFORE THE B. AND B. AND I FELT
THAT THE COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC WORKS TOTALLY IGNORED
FOR EXAMPLE A MORE OF THE
PUBLIC OPPOSED THE LANGUAGE AND
YET THE REGULATION IN THE
OPINION WAS ALREADY WRITTEN
BEFORE THE HEARING AND THEN IT
WAS VOTED ON IN THE SAME
MEETING WITHOUT ANY CHANGES. I
THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED BE A LEGISLATION
ADDITIONALLY HOW MOTIVATING
HEARING WHO CARRIED THE PREMISE
PERMITTED BY THE LEVEL OF
SUPERVISION. FOR THE P. T. THEY
WORK WITH. THE CONSUMER CHOICES
LIMITED. AND THE PUBLIC HAS.
THAT TO QUALIFIED- I. HOW ABOUT
OF HAVING A TRAIN P. T. WHO'S
MADE A CHOICE TO WORK WITH
ANIMALS- AND YOU'VE BEEN.
FREQUENTLY FROM THERE TO. IN A-
OF. THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY
COVERED IN VETERINARY
EDUCATION. TEACHER TRAINED ON
HANDS ON. MANUAL CARE AND I
HAVE PERSONALLY SEEN THE
IMPROVED OUTCOMES FOR THE
PATIENTS THAT COME TO US FOR A
SECOND OPINION. AFTER YOU KNOW
BEING ELSEWHERE. AT UC DAVIS
pRELATING TO SPORTS MEDICINE
KINESIOLOGY OR BIO MECHANICS
IT. IN THE VETERINARY
CURRICULUM AND MODALITIES LIKE
JOINT MOBILIZATIONS AREN'T EVEN
HOT. AND YET VETERINARIANS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO DICTATE
WHAT THE- TREATMENT PLAN SHOULD
BE. AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TRAINING TO DO THAT.
ADDITIONALLY ACCORDING TO THE
YOU CAN BE THAT BAD WEBSITE
THERE ARE NO FOURTH YEAR
STUDENT ROTATIONS LISTED FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF ANIMAL.
PHYSICAL REHABILITATION. AND
THE ACCOUNT DEPARTMENT ITSELF
IS RUN BY A- COLD. CREDENTIALED
PHYSICAL THERAPIST WITH
EXTENSIVE HUMAN AND ANIMAL
EXPERIENCE. FINALLY HAVE PEACE
HE IS NO THEY CAN'T MAKE
DIAGNOSES IN HUMAN MEDICINE.
AND THE TEACHINGS THAT I'VE
WORKED WITH TO WORK WITH
ANIMALS NO DESK. AND WILL
REFERRAL WHEN THERE'S AN ISSUE.
IF THERE'S A CASE FELT BILL
SEND THE CASE BACK TO THE
VETERINARIAN OR SAID. SUGGESTED
THEY GO TO SEE A SPECIALIST. OR
IN OUR CASE THAT WORK THEY CALL
ME I'M ONLY A TEXT AWAY. TO
TEETH WERE DOING PHYSICAL REHAB
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CONSCIENTIOUS AND BITUIN THAT
PRACTICES HERE THAT. THE NEXT.
COMMENT IS FROM LINE FIFTY ONE.
CARILLO CAROL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY COMMON. MY NAME IS
DR CHRIS REID I'M A DOCTOR
THERAPY. AND CARACOL POINT THAT
THE THEIR BEAT THE ASIAN
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
ONLY THINK THIS WILL HAVE FOR
THEIR WORK. AND IT'S GOING
COMMITTEE FOR THE INCLUSION OF
ITEM FIFTEEN RELATED TO THE
PROVISION OF ANIMAL PHYSICAL
REHABILITATION SERVICES BY
PHYSICAL THERAPIST. I ECHO THE
COMMENTS AND SUPPORT EXPRESSED
BY OTHERS FOR THE INCLUSION THE
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION AND ALLOW
THE ETERINARIAN. TO DETERMINE
THE LEVEL OF SUPERVISION
REQUIRED RIPARIAN ANIL PATIENT.
PHYSICAL THERAPIST FOR CARE
THANK YOU. IN THE NEXT COUPLE
IS FROM. THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO MY
NAME IS JUANITA SMITH AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND I AM OPPOSED TO THE
REGULATIONS OF THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD- I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT
I'VE WORKED IN APPREHENSION DOG
AND TO. SEARCH AND RESCUE DOGS-
AND GETS A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND I HAD DEPLOYED- MY
DOG ON THE MONEY IF YOU DON'T
MIND LIKE HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
IN SEARCH FOR THE MACHINE AND-
WE WERE ABLE TO GET. A
VETERINARIAN TO WORK WITH US AS
WELL AS THE- QUALIFIED
REGISTERED PHYSICAL THERAPIST.
AND THE DOGS AT WORK AT MONASH
SETO MUD SLIDE WERE GIVEN A
PHYSICAL THERAPY BASED UPON THE
DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION. AND WE
CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE WAS AT
LEAST A 90% IMPROVEMENT THE
NEXT DAY OF THESE WORKING DOGS
THESE DOGS ARE WORKING THE
NIGHT THAT WAS CHEST DEEP FOR
HUMANS. AND THE DOGS WHO DOES
PHYSICALLY EXHAUSTED AND SORE-
THE NEXT DAY AFTER RECEIVING
PHYSICAL THERAPY ARE THEIR
PERFORMANCE IMPROVED- I HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
VETERINARY BOARD. SPECIFICALLY
IT WILL REDUCE ACCESS TO I NEED
TO RE HAVE BEEN. WE HAVE REHAB
SERVICES FOR THE WORKING DOG TO
SERVE OUR STATE MON FORTUNATELY
KQ. AND- THE REGULATIONS
SPECIFICALLY DO NOT MEET THE
STATED OBJECTIVE OF PROTECTING
THE CONSUMERS BECAUSE THEY FAIL
TO REQUIRE ANY EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR. AN RV HE-
THERE TODAY PRACTICE IN A
SPECIALTY THAT THEY ARE NOT
TAUGHT AS PART OF THEIR COOL
CORRECTLY ON. CANNOT FEEL
PRESSURE IF THEY'RE BEING
PROTECTED FROM BAD ACTORS IN
THE INDUSTRY IF COMPETENCY
STANDARDS ARE NOT SET- I ANNA.
DISSATISFIED WITH HOW THE
VETERINARYWORK HAS HANDLED
THIS I'VE TRIED TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM VERY INCLINED TO
VERY I JUST FELT LIKE MY
CONCERN TEAM OUR REGULAR. AND
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
POINT. NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND I LINE FORTY
SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN AND WE
HEAR YOU OKAY HI MY NAME IS
NANCY ERLICH RBT AS I'VE BEEN
LICENSE SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN R. V. T.
ACTIVITIES FOR A VERY LONG TIME
I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOYS RBT
COMMITTEE FROM NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND
CHAIR FOR NINETY NINE NINETY
TWO THOUSAND ONE. AND I'M
CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA RBTH
SOCIAIS HAITIANS REGULATORY
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE I ONG
INVOLVEMENT WITH RBC ISSUES
GIVE ME A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON
THE CURRENT SITUATION THE FIRST
AND MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
RBC'S RIGHT NOW WITH THE
ENORMOUS FEE INCREASE PLACE ON
R. V. T. THE APPLICATION AND
LICENSE FEES OR RATES FROM A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS.
THAT'S UNCONSCIONABLE HUNDRED
AND 75% INCREASE ON EACH THE
THREE OF THESE PLANS TO LOWER
THE RBC LICENSE PLATE NO TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
NEXT YEAR WELL WELCOME STILL
RATED THE SUBSTANTIALLY WE FEEL
IT IS UNREASONABLE TO EXPECT A
RELATIVELY LOW PAID RBT
PROFESSION TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE TYPE THING. ONE OF
THE MOTIVATION FOR ELIMINATING
THE RETURN THE CALIFORNIA ARMY
TEAMS AND SEVERAL YEARS AGO WAS
TO ELIMINATE THE TWO HUNDRED
DOLLAR EXAM FEE SO THAT RBT
APPLICANTS WOULD BE ABLE TO
AFFORD GETTING LIFE AND RAISING
THE FEES IS NEGATED THAT REMEDY
AND WE STILL HERE THE NEW
GRADUATION DECLINED TO GET LIKE
FIFTY TO SIXTY. ONE OF THE
REASONS GIVEN BY THE VMB FOR
RAISING RBT PIECES THE INCREASE
IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
HOWEVER SINCE I REPEAT MAKE UP
JUST ZERO POINT 001% OF
DISCIPLINARY CASES IT'S NOT
REASONABLE TO EXPECT RB DIESEL
UNDERWRITE THE COST. OF
DISAPPOINTING OTHER LICENSEES.
WE ALSO UNDER THAT SOME OF
STATES NOT RELY ENTIRE ON LIFE.
HE'S TO THE THEIR BOARD. HAS
THE PUBLIC BETTER FROM. BEING
LIKE. WE RECOMMEND THE LEAD. TO
ALL. WAYS OF SUPPORTING
LICENSING BOARD. SO THAT
RELATIVELY LOW PAID LIFE HE'S
LIKE RV KEYS. DO NOT HAVE TO
CARRY SUCH A LARGE FINANCIAL
BURDEN. NEXT TO IT AT THE
LEGISLATURE TO POCKET THE
SECOND R. V. P. ON THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD. WE
REALIZE THAT GIVING UP THE RBC
FOUR ONE RB DION THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD AT THE MEASURE
THE INFLUENCE OF RBT ISSUES.
HAVING ONLY ONE RBT ON THE
BOARD ALSO MEANS THAT WHEN THAT
PERSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
THERE IS. TWO MINUTES THANK YOU.
CONNECT COMMENT IS FROM LINE.
SIXTY ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
KRISTEN TAYLOR AND I'M A
REGISTERED VETERINARY
TECHNICIAN IN CALIFORNIA AND I
AM ALSO A VETERINARY TECHNICIAN
BHANSALI'S AND ACCESSIBLE
REHABILITATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM HERE
LIKE- ARGUED HE ABOUT THE FEE
INCREASE AND HOW UNCOMFORTABLE
THAT IS FOR OUR V. PEAS IN
CALIFORNIA THE HOBBIT REYES TO
THE DOCTORS FOR A BACK MOM AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE RECTIFIED AND
INTERACT WITH OTHER- ISSUE.
ALSO SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT
BEEN LOOK THAT IS DEEPER TITLE
PROTECTION FOR REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIANS THAT
CALIFORNIA THERE IS ZERO
ENFORCEMENT FOR IT OR ANY
DISCIPLINARY ACTION INVOLVED I
BELIEVE THAT THE THIRTEEN AT
POLICY WAS IN PLACE TO
DETERMINE THAT FROM HAPPENING
THIS WOULD HELP INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF RDPC. IN CALIFORNIA
AND IS CURRENTLY IMPROPER USE
OF OUR TERM ENTITLED.
ADDITIONALLY I SUPPORT THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD VISION
FOR THE ANIMAL PHYSICAL
REHABILITATION AS A R. D. T.
AND CALIFORNIA I HAVE GREAT
CONCERNS OVER RVP. INFRINGEMENT
ON TAP. ACTUALLY SUCH THING AS
KATHLEEN AND THE ENERGY. WHICH
IS SOMETHING THE CAN ALL HAPPEN
INSTEAD REVIEW. ADDITIONAL RBP
ARE REQUIRED TO. WITH A
VETERINARIAN WITH A WITH A
VETERINARY CLIENT PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP AND HOW IS IT
GOING TO BE ADDRESSED. SURE THE
CRITICAL THERAPIST WITH
TRAINING AND PHYSICAL
REHABILITATION OF THE SEPARATE
CRIME AND WITHOUT A BETTER
NAZARIAN SEEN THE PATIENT I
THOUGHT HI. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NEXT COM IS FRONTLINE.
THANK YOU- COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
QUESTIONS NOTHING ON A
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK BEFORE THE DURING
COMMITTEES FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN
THE CMB WAS UNDERGOING
EXTENSIVE REVIEW IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SADLY I'M HERE AGAIN
TESTIFIED THE FOURTEENTH YOU
NEED CONCERNING CONTACT AS IT
RELATES TO HOW THE ANNUAL
PHYSICAL THERAPY.
REHABILITATION ISSUE HAS BEEN
HANDLED MY NAME IS TURNOUT
LISTEN I'VE BEEN A LICENSED PT
IN THE STATE FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS I'LL HOLD A CERTIFICATION
AND TRAINING REHABILITATION
FROM THE CANINE REHAB INSTITUTE
AND I'M A CLINICAL INSTRUCTOR
FOR PTC. DVM RPGS. ACTOR THE
SPECS SPECIALTY NICHE OF PANAMA
REHAB. I'M ALSO A FAN MEMBER
AND CURRENT PRESIDENT OF BOTH
THE CAL SYSTEM OF ANIMAL.
THERAPIST AND ANIMAL CRITICAL
THERAPY COALITION- AT THE MANY
OF MY COMMENTS AND- WERE
ALREADY SPOKEN BY MANY OF THE
PRIVATE ABOUT THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS. SO IN THE INTEREST OF
SAVING TIME I WILL JUST ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THOSE MADE BY
SCOUT HOUSE- LISA STARK. AND
THOSE ALSO- BY DR GREENSON
SUCKERS CONUS AND GREENSBURG.
AND THE OTHERS THAT ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THEM ARCANE
POSITION. WHERE ALL AGREED EVEN
IF THE BOARD IS THAT THE ONLY
SOLUTION THAT CAN FULLY ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND PROVIDE. FOR
QUALIFIED TEACHERS TO PERFORM
ANIMAL PHYSICAL THERAPY IS TO
MAKE A STATUTORY CHANGE BY THE
LEGISLATURE. JUST AS OUR
NEIGHBORING STATES AND
SUCCESSFULLY DONE MANY YEARS
AGO. UNFORTUNATELY THE BOARD
HAS IGNORED ALL STAKEHOLDERS ON
THIS ISSUE AND CREATED THEIR
OWN BIASED NARRATIVE. YES THEY
PROVIDED THE REQUIRED TIME TO
SPEAK. BUT THEY FAIL THE FAIRLY
COLLABORATE WITH ANYONE TO
FIGHT FOR THAT THE QUESTION AT
LEAST THAT IS THE PERCEPTION.
ACCOUNTABILITY NEEDS TO MATTER.
FOR THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF
PET IN SERVICE AND WORKING
ANIMALS IN NEED A PT SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ANIMAL PHYSICAL
THERAPIST IN THE ANIMAL
PHYSICAL THERAPY COALITION
ASKED THE COMMITTEES TO INCLUDE
THE PHONE SEX. TO INCLUDE IN
THE SUNSET EXTENSION BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IMPLEMENT. THE
TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATION. THE
NEXT COMMENT IS FROM SIX FOUR.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR- TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR A PICKING A CALM
MY NAME IS DR GARY RICHTER I AM
A VETERINARIAN. AND I AM A CO
FOUNDER OF THE VETERINARY
CANADA SOCIETY A NONPROFIT
WHOSE MISSION IT IS TO EDUCATE
VETERINARIANS PET OWNERS AND
INDUSTRY ABOUT THE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS FOR ANIMALS. I WANNA
TALK TODAY VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR WHICH
ADDRESSES WHICH WHICH ADDRESSES
ONE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FACING
CALIFORNIA VETERINARIANS AND
PET OWNERS THIS BILL WOULD
PRINT- THE BILL WOULD PREVENT
THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD.
FROM DISCIPLINING A
VETERINARIAN FOR RECOMMENDING
CANNABIS AND THIS IS A HUGE
BENEFIT FOR THE VETERINARY
COMMUNITY AND THAT BETTER
HEARINGS WOULD BE PERMITTED TO
HAVE. CRITICAL CONSULTATIONS
WITH OUR CLIENTS ABOUT PATIENT
CARE. IN ADDITION BY LIFTING
THIS PROHIBITION THE VETERINARY
PROFESSION WILL BE INCENTIVIZED
TO BECOME EDUCATED ABOUT THE
USE OF CANNABIS RAMBLES WHICH
IN TURN OF COURSE BENEFITS
PETS. AND PET OWNERS. THE BILL
HOWEVER IS DEEPLY FLAWED.
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR FAILED
TO AMEND MY CURSOR WHICH WOULD
ALLOW FOR A TRUE RECOMMENDATION
BY VETERINARIANS IN THE SAME
WAY TO POSITIONS HAVE BEEN
DOING SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX
AND REALLY. ALL THING THAT AB
THREE FOUR DOES IS PER DAY AT
THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD
FROM DISAPPOINTING
VETERINARIANS TO RECOMMEND
CANNABIS FOR THEIR PATIENTS.
FURTHERMORE THE BILL MAKES NO
MENTION OF REQUIRING MEDICAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS LABELS FOR
ANIMALS TO BE SOLD TO MEDICAL
DISPENSARIES ONLY. THIS IS THIS
THIS SHOULD BE A COMMONSENSE
NECESSITY THERE'S NO SUCH THING
AS RECREATIONAL CANNABIS FOR
ANIMALS. BY NOT AMENDING THE
CURSOR AND ALLOWING MEDICAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS TO BE SOLD
ALL ITS TO BE SOLD TO
RECREATIONAL DISPENSARY. EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY FOUR EFFECTIVE
MOVING THE GATE A GREAT DEAL OF
THE VALUE OF VETERINARIANS
BEING ABLE TO RECOMMEND.
BECAUSE ANYONE OFF THE STREET
WILL BE ABLE TO BUY A PRODUCT
LABELED FOR ANIMALS AND
MINISTERED TO THEIR PETS WITH
NO VETERINARY GUIDANCE. RECALL
OUT REGARDING DOSING- EVEN IF
CANNABIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
MEDICATION FOR THAT PATIENT.
THE WHOLE POINT OF
VETERINARIANS INSISTING ON
BEING ABLE TO RECOMMEND IS TO
PROTECT PATIENTS FROM
ACCIDENTAL HARM TO THE
INAPPROPRIATE ADMINISTRATION OF
THIS OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS. SO
LET ME JUST BE CLEAR THAT THE
ONLY REASON WHY ANYBODY WOULD
WANT MEDICAL CANNABIS FOR
ANIMALS AND RECREATIONAL
DISPENSARIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE PROBLEM A MEASURE TO
YOUR TEAMMATES ARE CONCLUDED.
AN OPERATOR WILL JUST LEAVE
ROOM FOR ONE ADDITIONAL CALLER
SO THAT WE CAN GET ON TO THE
NEXT. SUNSET OVERSIGHT HEARING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS POINT.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. I WANT TO THANK-
THE BOARD AND ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
FOR SPENDING YOUR VALUABLE TIME
SPECIFICALLY TO THE BOARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE
MUCH OF THIS IS ALL VOLUNTARY.
AND WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PUTTING YOUR HARD WORK INTO
THIS AND- CHAR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COLLABORATE WITH
YOU AT THE STAFF LEVEL. EVEN
VERY ACCESSIBLE AND WE LOOK FOR
TO THE CONTINUE OPPORTUNITY AS
WE'VE HAD THEY'LL CALL CLOSE TO
TWO AND A HALF HOURS OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND DIALOGUE. AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE HOPE TO FURTHER
THESE DISCUSSIONS AS WELL IN
COLLABORATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WELL NOW THEN TRANSITION
INTO. THE BORDER OF PSYCHOLOGY
JUST AS A REMINDER ASK THE
BOARD TO LIMIT THEIR OPENING
REMARKS TO THREE MINUTES AND OF
COURSE IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
AS WE'VE EVER HEARD FROM A
PREVIOUS BOARD WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE FULL
PARTICIPATION FROM OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I JUST GIVEN
THAT I'LL JUST SHARE WITH YOU
THAT THERE IS A TIME CONSTRAINT
TO THE BEST EXTENT POSSIBLE YOU
CAN BE PRECISE YOUR COMMENTS.
FOR THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY
JOINING US TODAY AS PRIMARY
WITNESSES OURS SAY RUN THROUGH
FOR PRESIDENT. EVEN PHILLIPS
BOARD MEMBER AND INTERNET SOREK
BOARD. EXECUTIVE. OFFICER
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRS IN OUR ROOM AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS SAVE ON
BILL. AND I'M JOINED TODAY- BY
THE PERSONS THAT SHERMAN LOW
JUST MENTIONED- BUT WE ARE ALSO
JOINED BY OUR SENIOR STAFF JOHN
BURKE STEPHANIE CHUNG
INTERESTING CLASS VEHICLE. I'M
ATTENDING AS WELL. A DOCTOR
PHILLIPS WE BEGAN OUR PRESS OUR
BRIEF PRESENTATION. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UGH GOOD MORNING
I'M DOCTOR STEPHEN PHILLIPS.
SINCE THE LAST SUNSET REVIEW
THE BORDERS ACCOMPLISH THE
FOLLOWING. FIRST IS PROMULGATED
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
LAST SUNSET BILL. INCLUDING
AMENDING PROVISIONS FOR
TELEHEALTH. CONTINUING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
ESTABLISHING A RETIRED STATUS.
NUMBER TWO. ON THE POOREST
PARTS OF LEGISLATION THAT
REQUIRED APPLICANTS FOR
LICENSURE AND CARAMELIZATION
SEES TO PROVIDE PROOF OF
TRAINING OR EDUCATION. IN
SUICIDE RISK ASSESSMENT AND
INTERVENTION. NUMBER THREE THE
BORDER SPONSORED LEGISLATION
UPDATE ECHO WRITTEN PUBLICATION
TO EDUCATE CONSUMERS OF
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL BEHAVIOR
OR CONTACT FROM THEIR
THERAPISTS AND WHAT ACTION THEY
CAN TAKE. NUMBER FOUR THE BOARD
COMPLETED SUCCESSFUL TWO YEAR
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN
CALIFORNIA CAN'T. CAMPAIGN
EXCUSE ME THE MORE DEVELOPED A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FOUNDATION CREATING ROUTINE
FEATURES AND OUR QUARTERLY
NEWSLETTER PUBLISHING ANSWERS
FROM BOTH THE FUND AND HOW TO
CONTRIBUTE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS.
ANNUAL PRESENTATIONS OF THE
HEALTH OF THE FUND AND
ULTIMATELY WE ADVOCATED TO
SUPPORT AN INCREASE RENEWAL FEE
TO ADD FUNDS TO THE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM. THEREBY
INCREASING ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH IN UNDERSERVED AREAS. A
NUMBER FIVE THE BOARD
SPEARHEADED STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
GETTING INPUT ON MAJOR CHANGES
JUST TO STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY PATHWAYS LICENSURE.
NUMBER SIX WE SPEARHEADED A
CHILD CUSTODY STAKEHOLDER CHILD
CUSTODY STAKEHOLDER MEETING ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY ONE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. IN
ATTENDANCE FOR THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES OR ITS
STAFF DCH EXECUTIVE OFFICE- AND
LEGAL AFFAIRS DIVISION THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL FAMILY LAW THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
DECEMBER COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS AND THE CENTER
FOR JUDICIAL EXCELLENCE. ALL TO
HIGHLIGHT AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT
IN THE CHILD CUSTODY PROCESS.
AND NUMBER SEVEN WE LAUNCHED A
PAPER LATE IN THE SHOULD HAVE
TO USE POSTCARDS FOR PURPOSES
OF RENEWAL NO COURAGE
APPLICATION RENEWALS ONLINE. TO
REDUCE FOR ITS CARBON FOOTPRINT.
NEWER ISSUES IDENTIFIED IN
BEING PASSED IN THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING. IT'S NOT CATHOLIC
REFORM DEGREE EVALUATION
REMOVING BARRIERS TO LICENSURE
AND REALISING PROGRAM
EFFICIENCIES CLARIFYING THE
TEMPORARY PRACTICE PROVISION
CREATING A MECHANISM FOR THOSE
WISHING TO REAPPLY FOR ACTIVE
STATUS AFTER NON DISCIPLINARY
SURRENDER OF THE LICENSE.
DELEGATING POLICIES SUCH AS AN
EXTENSION REQUEST FOR GAINING A
SUPERVISED PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING SUPERVISED
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE OF
LICENSURE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
FOR PRIVACY A PROPERTY
INFORMATION EXPEDIENCY IN
DECISION MAKING BENEFITING THE
REQUEST OR- AND FINALLY
CREATING A MECHANISM TO ADD
ADDITIONAL WAIVER AUTHORITY TO
THE BOARD HE'S IN THE CLEAR
NUMBER. I'M SUMMARY WE- MIGHT
AND CAN. WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE AS WELL
TO THE COMMITTEE STOCKTON
HELPING US FOCUS THE IN
INFORMATION PERTINENT TO YOUR
DELIBERATIONS. WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT US IN OUR EFFORTS TO
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY.
BACK SUPER PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL GO TO
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL BEGIN WITH
SENATOR OFF. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ALL KEEP THIS BRIEF I
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS IN SEPARATE
AREAS. OF THE FIRST HAS TO DO
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONER EDUCATION FUND AND
MY QUESTION IS HOW EGGS HOW IS
THAT SPECIFICALLY HAS A FUN
WORKING IN TERMS OF. INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF- INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF MENTAL HEALTH.
PROVIDERS IN OUR UNDERSERVED
AREAS. AND HOW CAN WE HELP I
WILL TELL YOU THAT THIS IS AN
AREA THAT I KNOW. SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN ME IN BEING
CONCERNED ABOUT- SO HOW'S THAT
OF FUN WORKING AND WHAT CAN WE
DO TO IMPROVE. YES MISTER.
GENERADO AND THE- LAWS OF THE
ACTING GHOSTED BINDING POSTS
MORE ON THAT FRONT AS WELL.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I WOULD
HAVE TO GET BCK ON THE ACTUAL
NUMBERS THAT HAVE- TO INCREASE
FROM THE INCREASE IN THE FEE AS
FAR AS THE NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS
GOES- WE TYPICALLY GET A
PRESENTATION FROM THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FOUNDATION TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THE- FUND IS WORKING AND HOW
MANY RECIPIENTS ARE RECEIVING-
THOSE LOAN REPAYMENT OF FUNDS.
THERE IS ALSO ACCESS TO THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE FUND-
WHICH CODES TO LICENSEES ABOVE
THE BORDER BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
AS WELL AS THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY SO THERE ARE AS
SEPARATE FUNDS THAT- LICENSEES
CAN ACCESS. LOAN REPAYMENT
PURPOSES. WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE I WOULD
APPRECIATE SOME ADDITIONAL-
DETAILED INFORMATION OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS BEEN A PROBLEM UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY IN THE INLAND
PARTS OF THE STATE BUT NOT
RESTRICTED TO THOSE AREAS FOR A
LONG TIME IT IS AS I AS YOU
KNOW. PARTICULARLY ACUTE NOW
WITH THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC POST IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND OUTSIDE OF OUR SCHOOLS SO
THE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
WOULD BE HELPFUL AND I'D LIKE
TO WHEN YOU WENT WHEN YOU
INCLUDE THAT. PLEASE ALSO
INCLUDE THE AREAS WHERE WE CAN
HELP YOU- HELP ALL THE REST OF
US- WITH RESPECT TO- MEDIC
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS IN OUR
UNDERSERVED AREAS QUESTION
NUMBER TWO DIFFERENT TO
DIFFERENT SUBJECT AREA. HAS TO
DO WITH RESEARCH
PSYCHOANALYST'S AND THE
QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS DOES
THE BOARD LEAVE IT SHOULD
OVERSEE. THE REGISTRATION OF
THE THIS CLASSIFICATION
RESEARCH- PSYCHOANALYST'S- WHO
ARE CURRENTLY IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING REGISTERED BY THE
AND REGISTERED WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD. I CAN RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION- JUST GIVEN ROTH.
MISTER PSYCHOANALYSIS HAVE BEEN
UNDER THE MEDICAL BOARD
ASSEMBLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES-
HISTORICALLY PSYCHOANALYSTS
WERE INDIVIDUALS WITH MEDICAL
DEGREES- AND THEN THEY WERE
SANTEE TRUST LITIGATION AND THE
AREA OPENED UP TO. ADDITIONAL
TYPES OF PRACTICE HERE'S-
PEOPLE GOING INTO
PSYCHOANALYSIS NOW ARE
TYPICALLY NOT PSYCHIATRISTS-
MOSTLY CATERS TO NOT PRACTICE
EVEN PSYCHOTHERAPY LUDLUM
PSYCHOANALYSIS- I BELIEVE. THE
MOBILE LOGICAL PLACE TO PUT TO
RECYCLE HOURS WITH THE BOARD
ITSELF IS NOT ACTUALLY HAS NOT
ACTIVELY CONSIDERED IT DID COME
UP IN THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SUNSET REVIEW- WE WERE NOT
DELEGATE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THIS RESEARCH CYCLE ANALYST AT
THAT TIME- WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN
TO CONSIDERING RESEARCH CYCLE
BOSS. BEING MOVED OR BOARD-
GIVEN THAT THERE MAY BE MORE
WITH OUR AREA OF EXPERTISE AND
IN FACT MOST OF THEM- TEACH AT-
RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES TO THAN
THAT. WELL IN THEORY AND TO
REGULATION THEY BE DOING READ
AND PUBLICATION IN ADDITION TO
CLINICAL PRACTICE IN THE
CLINICAL PRACTICES MUST BE
RESTRICTED TO ABOUT. A THIRD OF
THEIR TIME. CHAU TYPICALLY
THEIR- SUPERVISION. AND THEY'RE
DOING PUBLISHING AND THE AREA
OF SUBPRIME ALICE'S- TWO WEEKS
NOT. MEDICALLY RELATED. BUT AS
I SAY THE BOARD'S TAKING NO
FORMAL POSITION ON- TAKE UP
RESEARCH. AS OF THE LEGISLATURE
HAS YET TO MAKE A DETERMINATION
THAT AREA JUST ONE MORE FOLLOW
UP BUT I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THIS WHICH IS WHY I'M ASKING
IT CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME IDEA-
IF THEY'RE NOT MEDICAL DOCTORS-
WHAT THE EDUCATE THE GENERAL
EDUCATION BACKGROUND IS OF THIS
POPULATION OF INDIVIDUALS.
THERE PEOPLE WOULD NON MENTAL
HEALTH AGREES WHICH IS WHY IT
BECOME RESEARCH PSYCHOANALYSTS
BECAUSE YOU'RE A FULL FLEDGED
PSYCHOANALYST YOU HAVE TO HAVE
EITHER APPLIED PSYCHOLOGY
MEDICAL RATE- REPLIED SOCIAL
WORK DEGREE AT THE I MEAN
ANYTHING RELATED. TO THE PLOT
MENTAL HEALTH AREA- SO
TYPICALLY IT MIGHT HAVE A PHD
AND SOMETHING LIKE COST FEE.
SOME CRITICISM HISTORY- A BIG
RUNS THE GAMUT- PUTS THE
TYPICAL BULLET DON'T COME OUT
OF A FORMAL EDUCATION AND
MENTAL HEALTH WHEN THEY COME
OUT OF. AN ACADEMIC DISCIPLINE
AND- IN FACT I GUESS. WE'RE
SORT OF BECOME CREATURES CHECK.
HOURS SO. IT IS A PRIMARY OF P.
DESERVES SMALL GROUP CYCLES CAL.
I THINK IT'S A BROWN FIFTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE VERY
INTERESTING THANK YOU A
MIXTURE. DAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW IN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COULD MEMBERS- SENATOR PANFILO
BY SENATOR ARTICULATED. THANK
YOU CHAIR- LOW AND CHIRAC- THE
FIRST OF ALL- APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION- I KNOW WHEN THE
QUESTIONS I NORMALLY ASK. OUR
CV MONITORING BUT I SEE THAT
THIS BOARD ACTUALLY DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE FIGURES ON A LOT OF
GREAT. HE GETTING THEIR
CONTINUING EDUCATION SO THAT
GREAT- I. DID HAVE A COUPLE
THINGS I WANT TO ASK ABOUT SO.
FIRST OF ALL I APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING IN TERMS
OF- IN TERMS OF BACKLOG
ENFORCEMENT SO FOR THEY
UNDERSTAND YOU USE BREEZE.
SECTOR SIX HOW MUCH MONEY DO
DOES THE BOARD OF THE QUALITY
SPENT ON GREASE MAINTENANCE I
CAN'T QUITE PARSE IT OUT FUND
EXPENDITURES- THE CHART. MISTER
OUR LAST FISCAL YEAR THE BOARD
SPENT A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON BREEZE
COSTS- COSTS HAVE VERY THROUGH
THE YEARS BASED ON THE AMOUNT
OF WORK INCLUDE GOING INTO THE
BREEZE PRODUCT- AND A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF RELEASES- THE VENDOR
CHANGES THE AMOUNT BASED ON THE
NEEDS OF THE PROGRAMS-
TYPICALLY PRO RAT IT WILL
SPREAD THOSE COSTS TO LARGER
PROGRAMS AND SMALLER PROGRAMS-
AND IT HAS NOT BEEN AN ISSUE
FOR OUR PASSWORD- THUS FAR.
APPRECIATE THAT- PERHAPS WE CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU SEE MORE
BROADLY ACROSS THE BOARD SO I
JUST AS THE VARIATION TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOR
VETERINARY AGAIN YOU MAY BE
USING IT DIFFERENTLY AND SO
FORTH WELL I THINK IT'S WORTH
NOTING HOW MUCH TOTAL MONEY
WE'RE SPENDING ON THIS PROGRAM
AND WHAT BENEFITS WERE GETTING
FROM IT AT THE OTHER QUESTION I
ACTUALLY HAD WAS- YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT- THAT ALSO
COME UP IS- CERTAINLY WE ALL
APPRECIATE HOW IMPORTANT MENTAL
HEALTH IS ESPECIALLY NOW WITH
KOBE- MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ARE A PARTICULAR
YOU KNOW SENSITIVE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE CLIENT. PATIENTS THAT
INTO TERMS OF THE POWER
DYNAMICS AND SO FORTH BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'VE HAD SOME
CHALLENGES- TRYING TO DRESS A
CERTAIN CONDUCT RELATED TO-
SOME OF THE LICENSEES CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT. AND WHAT WE NEED
TO TRY TO DO TO ADDRESS THAT.
YES I THINK I CAN SPEAK TO THAT
AND PROBABLY THE MOST. INVOLVED
IN THE ISUE- FOR THE LONGEST
PERIOD OF TIME- BASICALLY WE
FOUND THERE'S A CLASH OF SEXUAL
BEHAVIORS THAT DID NOT FALL
WITHIN SPECIFIC DEFINITIONS
THAT WE USE. FOR PURPOSES OF-
DISTINCT DISAPPOINTING PEOPLE
FOR SEXUAL BEHAVIOR. WAS CALLED
ACTUAL CONTACT HIS HOUSE TO
FIND IN INVOLVED IN THE
INTIMATE TOUCHING OF SPECIFIC
BODY PARTS. BUT AS TIME WENT ON
WE REALIZE FOR DISCIPLINARY
CASES THAT- THERE WERE OTHER
BEHAVIORS BEING GAUGED IN
WHETHER IT'S SIXTEEN WHETHER IT
IS SENDING PROVOCATIVE PICTURES
TO PATIENTS OR- EXCHANGING
INTIMATE NOTES WITH PATIENTS-
THE I MEAN IT COULD BE A- COULD
BE A WIDE VARIETY OF THINGS-FRANKLY UNDER OUR DEFINITION OF
SEXUAL CONTACT. A PRACTITIONER
COULD **** IN FRONT OF THEIR
CLIENT EXCUSE THE EXPRESSION
BUT THAT'S DIRECT TO ASIAN THEY
COULD GAIN SOME TRACTION ACTUAL
BEHAVIOR SOMETHING WEREN'T
TOUCHING THE PATIENT WOULD NOT
FALL UNDER SEXUAL CONTACT.
THURMOND IN ORDER TO DISCIPLINE
THEM WE WERE AT DISCIPLINING
THEM UNDER ANOTHER PART OF OUR-
ESTADUAL UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT
IN THE USUALLY GOT DISCIPLINED
AS ENCOUNTERED BY ELECTION. AND
DIDN'T RESULT IN REVOCATION IN
CASES WHERE REPLICATION SEEM TO
BE- ESSENTIAL SO WELL WITH YOUR
HELP CENTER PAN- WITH
COOPERATION THE COMMITTEES. BUT
WERE FASHIONING LEGISLATION
PRIOR LEGISLATION- DROPPED OUT
OF CONTENTION BECAUSE THE CODE
THAT CRISIS BUT- WE'VE
RECENTLY- FIND THE LEGISLATION
A PROPOSED LEGISLATION- LAID IT
TO REST OF THE WEEK SUBSUME- A
FAR LARGER NUMBER OF SEXUAL
BEHAVIORS WHICH WE THINK. BOTH
VIOLATION OF CLIENT TRUST IN A-
PLEADS- THE TRAIL OF THE
PROFESSION AND THE CLIENT- SO
THAT WE CAN BETTER- DISCIPLINE
IN THOSE CASES AND WHERE
NECESSARY ACHIEVE REPLICATION.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH I KNOW
THIS IS A CHALLENGE FOR THE
BOARD I KNOW IT'S SOMETHING
THAT- WHAT TRUE ALL OF US WORK
TOGETHER ON WE ALSO KNOW THAT
COURSE THERE'S A GREATER.
INCREASE OF PEOPLE NEEDING HELP
FROM MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND INCLUDING
CHILDREN AND WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT- WELL CERTAINLY A VAST
MAJORITY OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS OF COURSE ARE YOU
KNOW ACTED PROFESSIONALLY DOING
THE RIGHT THING- WE ALSO WANTED
SURELY PROTECTS- DOES. THAT
THE- THE DOES PATIENTS FROM
UNFORTUNATELY- VERY SMALL
NUMBER BUT STILL- WITH THE VERY
TRAUMATIC TO HAVE. THAT KIND OF
AND NO RELATIONSHIP AND HAVE
THE BOARD NOT BE ABLE TO TRUST
THAT SO THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTERED. YES SAN ROTH.
DOES A CENTIMETER FOLLOWED BY I
AS A AS A JOINT EFFORT BOTH ON
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE SIDE
TO FOLLOW UP ON WHAT WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE. FROM SACRAMENTO
SAID- I'M HOPING WE TAKE A LOOK
AT ALL OF THE BOARDS THAT HAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
PROFESSIONAL OR CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS- WITHIN THIS CASE
CLIENTS AND NOT JUST THIS ONE
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THE
PRACTICE ACTS IF THAT'S WHERE
IT NEEDS TO BE DEFINED
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT IN A WAY
THAT. IF PROVEN TO BE THE CASE
DISCIPLINE CAN BE TAKEN UP TO
AND INCLUDING LICENSE
REVOCATION WITHOUT HAVING THE
CONCERNED SIR THAT YOU AND THE
BOARD- HAVE EXPRESSED HERE SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOUR LOW END. AND MY COLLEAGUES
ON BOTH IN BOTH HOUSES TO MAKE
DURING THIS COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND BEYOND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. SENATE ARCHULETA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I'D
LIKE TO- FIRST OFFERED
KNOWLEDGE ALL ALL THE
THERAPISTS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
EVERYONE IN THE INDUSTRY FOR
THE WORK THEY'VE DONE AND- AND
RIGHT NOW WE ALL KNOW THE
PANDEMIC IT IS GOT OUR CHILDREN
UP AGAINST THE WALL WE'RE- TALK
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT GETTING THE KIDS.
BACK INTO SCHOOL WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE'LL BE LOOKING AT
VERY QUICKLY SO CONSEQUENTLY WE
FACE MENTAL ILLNESS IN THE
SCHOOLS IS THERE A PARTNERSHIP-
WITH YOUR INDUSTRY AND THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT- CAN GO
TO THE SCHOOLS CAN VOLUNTEER.
AND THAT MAY BE OPEN UP NEW
DOORS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AS
MY COLLEAGUE- HAS STATED HAS
GONE TO THE- THE RULE AREAS
AREAS OF THE INNER CITY WHERE
THEY CAN VOLUNTEER. IN THE
SCHOOLS TO ACTUALLY AUGMENTED
THE NUMBER OF PSYCHOLOGY THAT
MAYBE THEY'RE IN THE SCHOOL OR
THE LACK THEREOF. AND I THINK
WE FIND IT IN OUR SO MANY OF
OUR SCHOOLS- YOU MAY HAVE ONE
NURSE FOR FIVE GRAMMAR SCHOOLS
OR YOU KNOW ONLY ONE FOR- HIGH
SCHOOL WITH THREE THOUSAND
KIDS. BUT RIGHT NOW THAT MENTAL
HEALTH IS SUCH A AN ISSUE
THAT'S ON THE TABLE RIGHT NOW.
AND WHEN THE KIDS COME BACK
THEY'RE GOING TO HIT THAT WALL
IN WITHOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND-
INTERVENTION. AND THERAPIST
THAT CAN. YOU KNOW SPEAK TO
THESE KIDS ONE ON ONE I THINK
IT'S GOING TO TAKE EVEN LONGER
FOR THEM TO COME OUT OF THAT
SHELL. VOLUNTEER PROGRAM
PARTNERSHIP. THE SCHOOLS CAN
YOU ADDRESS THAT PLACE. I THINK
I'M PROBABLY BEST SITUATED AS A
PRACTITIONER TO ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION. UP OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
BEEN A MAJOR MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS HEY CAN YOU FROM TALKING
TO MY COLLEAGUES THAT MANY ARE
EXPERIENCING EXTREME BURNOUT-
THEY'VE BEEN FORCED TO TAKE A
MUCH HEAVIER CASELOADS AND THEY
HAD BEFORE IN SOME INSTANCES IN
TRYING TO MAKE REFERRALS IN
RECENT MONTHS. I'VE BEEN UNABLE
TO FIND PRACTITIONERS IT COULD
TAKE A REFERRAL BECAUSE THEY'RE
CANCELING SO HEAVY THAT THEY
COULDN'T IN GOOD CONSCIENCE
TAKE ON AN EDUCATIONAL KLEINER
CLIENTS- SO THERE'S A
HEALTHCARE THERE'S A CRISIS TO
SOME EXTENT WITHIN THE RANKS OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS IN
TERMS OF. WHAT'S BEING REQUIRED
OF US RIGHT NOW. LOOK TELL YOU
HOWEVER THAT- LICENSE
TECHNOLOGISTS TEND TO BE VERY
PRO ACTIVE IN THEIR VOLUNTEER
EFFORTS- IN TERMS OF REACHING
OUT TO VARIOUS COMMUNITIES-
SOME COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED.
POPULATION OF PSYCHOLOGISTS IS
COMING TO REPRESENTS- MORE OF
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE STATE
AS OPPOSED TO. PEOPLE THAT LOOK
LIKE ME- SO I THINK THERE ARE
CHANGES GOING ON IN PSYCHOLOGY
THAT ARE MAKING PSYCHOLOGY MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS. OF
AMERICA'S COMMUNITIES. THAT
BEING SAID WITHIN A SCHOOL
SETTING WHICH YOU. WE WERE
PERFECTLY FOCUSED ON THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE LABELED
PSYCHOLOGISTS BUT THEY ARE
MASTERS LEVEL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS WHO ARE LICENSED
BY THE BOARD BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCE. THERE ARE ALSO OFTEN
SOMETIMES LICENSE
PSYCHOLOGISTS- WITHIN THOSE
FACILITIES SO I THINK THERE'S
GOING TO BE HAVE TO BE A REAL
EMPHASIS ON. HELPING CHILDREN
TO OVERCOME. THE DRAMATIZATION
AND KIND OF THE- ISOLATION
THAT'S BEEN CREATED. DURING
THIS PERIOD OF TIME SO I THINK
WE'RE AS A PROFESSION
PSYCHOLOGISTS ARE FULLY
COGNIZANT OF THAT. BOARD IS
ATTEMPTED TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE WAYS THAT WE CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE BUT OBVIOUSLY WORK
ON A PROVIDER OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE DIRECTLY- SO WE'VE
GENERATED TAKEN VARIETY OF
INITIATIVES. THAT SUPPORT
WE'RE- GETTING MORE PEOPLE INTO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND TO
INCREASE SUICIDE ASSESSMENT AND
TRAINING- TO. DO ANYTHING
ENTERED SO THE GUY HOUSE CORP-
WHICH WHICH IN SOME TO SOME
EXTENT INTENDED TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THIS CRISIS. IN MENTAL
HEALTH IN THE STATE I THINK
WE'RE GONNA BE FEELING THE
EFFECTS OF IT FOR A VERY LONG
TIME. HELLO BY MAKE THIS YEAR-
THE OTHER THING THAT WOULD TOP
ISSUE HELP IS TO PROMOTE THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF THE STUDY- THAT
YOU ALL DO A TO GO TO THE
COLLEGES TO JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOLS
AND WORK YOUR WAY UP. TO GET
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE TO GIVE BACK
TO THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES BY
GOING ON TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES
AND MAYBE BECOME THAT LCSW THAT
CAN GO INTO A SCHOOL JOINT
OUTREACH PROGRAM TO PROMOTE
YOUR INDUSTRY AND THE NEED OF
SEX. IS A PSYCHIATRIST- IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THAT MEANS YOU'RE
NOT. SENATE ARGENT AFTER HAS.
HEY WE HAVE TO REACH AND-
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AS A PART
OF THE BOARD- OF THAT AFTER HAS
INCLUDED WORKING CLOSELY I'M IN
FACT WEEK WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO
ENDEMIC WE ACTUALLY HEALTH OUR
BOARD MEETINGS ON ON CAMPUSES
I'M SO FOR EXAMPLE ARE BAY AREA
MEETING WAS THAT THE RIGHT
INSTITUTE AT BERKELEY- SO THAT
WAS AN EXAMPLE OF US ENGAGED IN
SCHOOL JUST MOST RECENTLY I
KNOW AT LEAST TWO OF OUR BOARD
MEMBERS. HAVE PARTICIPATED- IN
SUBSTANCE IN THE STARS WOULD
YOU DESCRIBE IN TERMS OF
TALKING ABOUT THEIR WORK THEIR
PRACTICE- AND CONNECTING THE
DOTS ON. THE THEIR OWN CAREER
PATHWAYS IN THIS FIELD- ACCESS
AS DR PHILLIPS SAID I'M IS
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE SPORTING
CONTINUES TO- THE END OF THE
LANDS FOR WHICH WE ASK.
QUESTIONS WHEN STAFF AND ISSUES
COME BEFORE THE BOARD. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MISTER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER ARE TO LET
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS A
COMMENCEMENT THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS TIME. C. NUMBER GOING TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IRA I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE TWO CALLERS THAT
HAVE DIALED IN AND JUST AS A
REMINDER FEEL FREE TO CALL IN
THE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN THREE TWO SIX TWO FOUR
TWO. WE'LL TURN NOW TO THE
OPERATOR PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. A POST COMMENTS GOING TO
COME FROM LINE NUMBER EIGHT ONE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN GLORIA.
THANK YOU- HELLO CHAIRS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CALLING FOR
US WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US TO PARTICIPATE TODAY. SEPIA
AND LIKE TO THANK THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY STAFF AS WELL AS THE
CHAIRS AND BNP COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR ENGAGING US FOR FEEDBACK
DURING THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS. WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSIVENESS
TO OUR COMMENTS WE BELIEVE THE
NEW INDEPENDENT BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY IS IMPORTANT FOR
BOTH LICENSEES AND FOR THE
CONSUMERS OF PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES. WE THE CAN DO. OF THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY STATUTE AND
OFFERS FOR THE ENACTED BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
AND AS A REMINDER TO QUEUE UP
WITH A COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO
WE'RE GOING ADELINE NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN I'M THIRTY SEVEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHARON CHU
THANK YOU FOR TAKING MY CALL.
I'M CALLING IN REGARDS TO THE
OVERSIGHT OF CHILD PSYCHOLOGY
PRACTICES AND OF THE MOTHER
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
THOSE PRACTICES. I WAS JUST
MADE AWARE THE HEARING THIS
MORNING FOR PUBLIC TRUST MY
PRESENTATION IS NOT POLISHED
AND I DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC
DETAILED INFORMATION MY FINGER
TIPS. HOWEVER I FEEL COMPELLED
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
WHO ARE SUFFERING DUE TO
CERTAIN DANGEROUS MATHIS. BEING
PRACTICED IN THE NAME OF
PSYCHOLOGY. AND I AM WONDERING
ISN'T HELPFUL OR ETHICAL TO USE
TERROR KIDNAPPING FEAR AND
SHOCK FACTORS AS MEANS OF
CONVERSION THERAPY. MY CHILDREN
WHO ARE NOW ADULTS HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO TORTUROUS ACTIONS
IN THE NAME OF PSYCHOLOGY AND
MANY CHILDREN HAVE BEEN AND ARE
CONTINUING TO BE TORTURED BY
THE SAME TECHNIQUES. SOMETIMES
I UNDERSTAND IN ORDER TO HEAR
WHAT DISEASE BECAUSE YOUR
INITIALLY HEARD. AND THE
PHYSICAL PLANTS WE THINK OF
VACCINES CITING THE BROKEN
BONE. IS THAT ALSO THE CASE
WITH MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
HEALTH. IS IT HELPFUL AND
ETHICAL TO FORCE A CHILD TO
FORM A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PARENT. WHO WAS ABUSING
THAT CHILD. IS IT HELPS TO KICK
WHICH FROM STATE SAFE AND HELP
AND- IN ORDER FORCE A CHILD TO
FORM A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH
A PARENT WHO WAS ACCUSING THE
CHILD. IS IT HELPFUL TO
THREATEN A CHILD THAT DAY OR
THE PARENT WITH HIM THEY FEEL
SAFE. WILL BE JAILED IF THEY DO
NOT FORM A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEIR ABUSER. FOR MY FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE I CAN RELATE TO YOU
THAT THESE PRACTICES ARE NOT
ONLY HARMFUL FOR THE CHILD THAT
RESULT IN FURTHER BREAKDOWN OF
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
ACCUSER AND THE CHILD. THE
ISSUE THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
TO MY OPINION AS THE SOURCE OF
THE ABUSE THE REASONS THE
CHILDREN AWAY FROM PARENTS.
THIS IS BEEN PUSHED ASIDE AND
INSTEAD THE ABUSED CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO DENY THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN ACCUSED. WHICH
IN ITSELF IS AN ADDITIONAL FORM
OF ABUSE. MANY COMPLAINTS HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT TO THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY AND
RELATIONSHIPS FAMILY BRIDGES
RANDY AND YOUR TO RANDOM
SIMILAR REUNIFICATION PROGRAMS.
I'VE GOT. FAMILY BRIDGES
CONTINUES TO HARM CHILDREN
WHILE CHARGING EXORBITANT FEES.
THERE ARE LITERALLY GETTING
RICH BY RUNNING MONEY FROM THE
TEARS OF CHILDREN I'M LEAVING
THEM BROKEN AND WORN. THESE
CHILDREN ARE THAT MUCH TO
REPAIR THEMSELVES ADDING TO
THEIR ALREADY STRANGE
CONDITION. THIS REQUIRES TIME
ENERGY AND FINANCES AT A TIME
IN THEIR LIVES WHEN THEY SHOULD
BE GOING FORWARD WITH COLLEGE
CAREERS AND RELATIONSHIPS.
FAMILY BRIDGES AND SIMILAR
PROGRAMS NOT ONLY TERRORIZE
THEM DURING THEIR CHILDHOOD.
ALSO HANDICAPPED THEM DURING
THEIR ADULT LIVES. PLEASE TAKE
THESE COMPLAINTS SERIOUSLY FOR
THE SAKE OF EACH CHILD AND FOR
SOCIETY AS A WHOLE. ACCORDING
TO YOUR MISSION TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
CONSUMERS. OF PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CARE. UNLESS WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR OPEN GOING TO. THANK YOU
THIS IS CONNIE VALENTINE FROM
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION AND AN ADVISER TO
ADVOCATES FOR CHILD EMPOWERMENT
SAFETY. WE CONTINUE TO BE
GRAVELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LACK OF OVERSIGHT FOR SMALL
GROUP OF PSYCHOLOGISTS. YOU DO
GREAT HARM THEIR CUSTODY
EVALUATORS. THE BOARD'S MISSION
IS TO PROTECT THE HEALTH SAFETY
AND WELFARE OF THE PUBLIC BUT
IN THESE CASES ONLY A CERTAIN
SEGMENT OF THE PUBLIC IS
PROTECTED. SO I'D LIKE TO GIVE
YOU A TYPICAL SITUATION THAT WE
SEE. A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM
LEAVES THE BATTERY WITH ER
CHILD. THE CHILD FEEL SAFE
DISCLOSING SEXUAL ABUSE BY THE
FATHER AND THE MOTHER ASKED FOR
PROTECTION FOR FAMILY COURT.
THE COURT APPOINTED
PSYCHOLOGIST UNDER EVIDENCE
CODE SEVEN THIRTY AS AN EXPERT
WITNESS EVEN THOUGH THE
EVALUATORS NOT A CHILD SEX
ABUSE EXPERT. PSYCHOLOGIST
CHARGES THE PARENTS DIRECTLY
THE VICTIM HAS NO FUNDS THE
BATTERY PLAYS PC NORMA'S
UNREGULATED FEES UP TO SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THE
PSYCHOLOGIST DECIDES NATURALLY
THE MOTHERS TRYING TO ALIENATE
THE CHILD FROM THE FATHER
BECAUSE THE FATHER IS PAYMENT
PSYCHOLOGIST. AND THE MOTHER IS
MAKING A TIELINE. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT 72% OF THE
EVALUATORS. RECOMMEND THE
MOTHER DISCUSS CITY. THE JUDGE
CUSTOM OF THE CHILD IS A CHILD
AGENCIES MOST TO RE INJURE AND
SO I KILLED. THANK YOU FOR
SENATOR TO IS CREATE FAMILY CO
THIRTY ONE A- FOR THESE TWO
ABUSE CASES. BUT IF DID NOT
FALL THE PRO. WE DEVELOPED A
TEMPLATE TOOK TO THE BORDER. OF
PSYCHOLOGY ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
TINA BAYLISS SHE HAD IN FACT
CHECKED AND SAID IT WAS CORRECT
BUT THAT THE COURT HAD NO
JURISDICTION HAS HAD QUITE
JURISDICTION NOT THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY. SO THE LEGISLATURE
STEPPED INDISCREET A NEW FORM
FOR THE EVALUATORS. NOW WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE EVALUATORS
WHO APPOINTED UNDER THE
EVIDENCE CODE INCORRECTLY. WILL
NOT USE THE FAMILY CODE FORM
AND THE BOARD WILL CONTINUED
NOT OVERSEEING THEM. AS WE
SUGGESTED AT THE LAST SUNSET
INTO A REVIEW. WE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH THE BOARD THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ENSURE THE
PROCESS WORKS PROPERLY IS
SENATOR ORTIZ INTENDED IT TO
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC NOT THE OFFENDERS
THIS WILL NOT BE SERVED BY MORE
TRAINING. THIS HOT POTATO ISSUE
HAS GONE ON TOO LONG. THANK YOU
FOR HELPING US. PROTECT THESE
CHILDREN THAT THE PREVIOUS
PERSON JUST DESCRIBED. THE
PROVISIONAL COMMENTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE TWO MORE
QUEUING UP.
AND SEVENTY FOR
YOUR OPEN GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ROB THAT WHILE MY NAME
IS KATHERINE CAMPBELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION TODAY WE SEE THE
BALLPARK STATE THAT THE AVERAGE
TIME IS FIVE HUNDRED FORTY DAYS
FRONT PORCH NOT YET WE KNOW ONE
COMPLAINT THAT HAS YET TO GO TO
THE AG'S OFFICE THAT THAT HAVE
BEEN REVIEWED FOR MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THIS PROCESS
TAKE OVER A THOUSAND DAYS ONLY
TO BE DISMISSED BY A FORM
LETTER EVEN THOUGH IT WAS A
VALID COMPLAINT. ON PAGE
FOURTEEN YOU CAN READ ABOUT THE
MOST COMMON TYPE PATIENTS MOST
OF THE MOST SERIOUS COMPLAINTS
AFTER YEARS OF RAISING THE
AWARENESS TO THIS PART OF THE
CRISIS OF THE FAMILY OF CHILD
SEXUAL ABUSE IN THE FAMILY
COURT BEING DISMISSED BY
INDIVIDUALS THEY AUTHORIZED.
THE BOARD IS BECOME LIABLE FOR
THE DISMISSAL OF CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE PSYCHOLOGIST OF
TRAFFICKING TRAFFICKING
CHILDREN IN OUR STATE. WITHOUT
GIVING INDIVIDUAL BOUNDARIES BY
REMOVING LICENSES WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM
PROTECTIVE PARENTS AND SEEING
COURT DOCUMENTS THE SPORT LIKE
TO SEE STATEMENTS SUCH AS- TO A
CHILD WHO IS BEING RE PORTED-
ABUSED BY THE FATHER IT IS YOUR
JOB TO IMPROVE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR FATHER
HE'S YOUR FATHER. AFTER A SLAP
ON THE HAND TO A NAME TO SEXUAL
ABUSE ARE TELLING THE CHILD
VICTIM YOU CAN WILL YOU NEED TO
MOVE ON WITH YOUR NEW LIFE AND
NEVER TALK ABOUT YOUR PREVIOUS
LIFE AGAIN. A TECHNOLOGIST
RECOMMENDING PERMANENT CUSTODY
TO THE NAME SEXUAL ABUSER AFTER
pABOUT THE SEXUAL ABUSE. OF
REUNIFICATION CAMPSITE COLLEGES
NEED TO LIVE WITH YOUR FATHER
pTO LIVE WITH YOUR MOTHER AGAIN.
I DID NOT KNOW HE WOULD DO THAT
AFTER THAT FATHER MURDERED THE
CHILD WE BELIEVE THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY HAS FALTERED WITH
THEIR ENFORCEMENT AND A
STAKEHOLDERS MEETING BUT THAT
WAY TOO IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
NOT ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
ADEQUATELY BUT JUST TRYING. TO
CULTURE TO DISMISS ABUSE AND
EXCUSE THE CRIMINAL AND
UNETHICAL BEHAVIOR OF A
LICENSING FOR THAT PERSON
WORKED HARD FOR THEIR LICENSE
AND IT IS THEIR PROPERTY IS A
ONE EIGHTY OF WHAT THIS BOARD
HAS. REPORTED GEO THAT THEY
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. I'M HERE TO
READ A PUB HAS NOT BEEN PUT.
AND NEED IN TO. KERN NOW TO
NAME A FEW AND- A CHILD. THANK
YOU. WE GO NEXT TO LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE YEAR OPEN GOING
TO. THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
I'M KATHLEEN RUSSELL THE
FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR JUDICIAL EXCELLENCE WHICH
IS COMMITTED TO PROTECTING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
ABUSE SURVIVORS IN OUR FAMILY
COURTS AND TO FOSTERING.
ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGHOUT THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS WE'VE BEEN A VOICE FOR
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND A
CATALYST FOR CHILD SAFETY WE
LET THE THREE YEAR EFFORT TO
SECURE THE FIRST AUDIT OF THE
COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE AND SIXTY YEARS.
NOR EQUALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
PROCEDURAL PROBLEMS THAT THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY IS
LICENSEES ARE CONSISTENTLY
HARMING OUR STATE CHILDREN WITH
IMPUNITY. I'VE ATTENDED NEARLY
EVERY BOARD MEETING FOR FOUR
YEARS AND I'M DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BOARDS I'M GOING
UNDERMINING OF IT SUPPOSEDLY
CORE MISSION OF PUBLIC
PROTECTION LIKE THE CJP THE
BOARD GIVE LIP SERVICE TO
PUBLIC PROTECTION YET
REPEATEDLY UNDERMINES THE
PUBLIC. IT CLAIMS TO PROTECT
WITH THE DISCIPLINE RATE OF TWO
POINT 3% OF ALL COMPLAINTS THE
BOARD IS FAILING IN ITS PRIMARY
MISSION OF PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC. ISSUE THREE AND THE
BACKGROUND PAPER REMAINS A
MAJOR BARRIER FOR THE BOARD
CRUCIAL ENFORCEMENT WORK WE'VE
REPEATEDLY COMPLAINED ABOUT THE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY AND WASTE
OF TIME AND RESOURCES WHEN THE
PUBLIC IS EXCLUDED FROM
COMMITTEE MEETINGS. THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S ENFORCEMENT COMMITTEE
HAS NOT PUBLICLY FOR YEARS SO
THERE'S CLEAR PRECEDENT FOR
MAKING ENFORCEMENT COMMITTEE A
FIVE BY THE OPEN MEETING AT
HERE'S A QUICK STORY TO
ILLUSTRATE THE COLOSSAL WASTE
OF TIME AND RESOURCES THAT THE
SECRECY CREATE. FOUR YEARS AGO
WE LEARNED THAT THE BOARD WAS
CLOSING ALL CUSTODY COMPLAINTS
IT RECEIVED WITHOUT CONSENT
FORMS FROM BOTH PARENTS AND
IMPOSSIBILITY AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES SINCE
PERPETRATORS WHO JUST BELIEVE
THEIR WAY TO WINNING CUSTODY
WILL NEVER. AGREED TO CONSENT
TO AN INVESTIGATION WE WERE
SURE THIS CAN BE RESOLVED WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENAS AND
YEARS OF BOARD MEETINGS ADDRESS
THIS. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
BOARD DISMISSED A FOUR HUNDRED
PAGE COMPLAINT BY A FORMER
LAWYER WITH THE D. O. G. U. S.
DOJ'S OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL
THANK YOU ARE TWO MINUTES
AROUND. THANK YOU. THAT WAS NOT
HUMAN. AND WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS SHOULD KEEP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME IF NOT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE TO
THE OF BOARD AND EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DIALOGUE THANK YOU FOR MAKING
YOURSELF AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE AND AS WELL AS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE IN THE PREVIOUS
BOARD WE APPRECIATE THAT
OPPORTUNITY LOOKING FOR TO THE
CONTINUED DIALOGUE. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR COMMUNITY
HEARINGS THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
ARE JOINED.